the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
favorites are rounding into form at the
U.S Juniors and Senior championships in
St Louis players were locked in and
racing to stake their claim at the top
of the leaderboard in the junior girls
section Alice Lee took down co-leader
Zoe Tong to claim the first clear lead
of the event the wins keep coming for
maxim Deluge getting his third win in a
row to maintain co-lead in the seniors
after an all-decisive round world's
youngest Grandmaster abimanyu Mishra
took down leader Andrew Hong to jump
into a three-way tie at the top of the
junior standings Front Runners are
forming can they keep up the pace or
will they stumble day five of
exhilarating chess coming up next
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
of the U.S Juniors and seniors chess
championships we are here in cubic at
the warches hall of fame it's the day
before the rest day we expect fire on
the board let's go back to the studio
and follow the action
the center's chess club is proud to
present the 2023 edition of three
tournaments in one junior girls juniors
and seniors featuring The Best of young
talent and talented veterans our
coverage from Saint Louis begins now
hello everyone I Am Woman Grand Master
Katarina yamsova and I'm here with
Grandmaster Yasser Sarah one okay this
has been fun but it's something about
the national championships they're
inspiring they bring out the best in the
players yes absolutely I agree Yasser
and we saw the number of decisive games
I mean they show that players are here
to fight hard they certainly are hello
everyone and Welcome to our broadcast of
our three national championships I found
yesterday inspiring especially because
of Mishra Mishra was in trouble he had
the black pieces pressure on the clock
and he refused to make a draw and he
went on to win the game his courage was
rewarded really an inspiring game
do the honors Kate tell us where we
stand after four rounds of play let's
start with the girls right so after
round four we have a soul leader Alice
Lee the favorite of this tournament
three and a half points and there is a
three-way tie for the second place
karissaib Rochelle Wu and Zoe tank with
two and out points and in the junior
competition in the Juniors we have a
three-way tie for the first place
Brandon Jacobson abimano Mishra and
Arthur Gua with three points each and in
the Legends I should say in the legend
let's go with Legends we have a two-way
tie for the first place Max and glugy
and Malik said katian with three and a
half points and then there is a two-way
guide for the third place vladimira
kopian and Gregory kaidanov with two and
a half points and Kate tell us about the
format the format is three 10 player Ram
Robins which means that each player
plays everyone else in their respective
tournament and the time control is 90
minutes for first 40 moves followed by
30 minutes for rest of the game and
there is a three second increment from
move one important to know there are no
draw offers allowed players cannot agree
on a draw they can only claim right yeah
and it's more difficult to click and
draw than you might imagine through the
magic of Television we talked about
yesterday this is a game between
mango and and Carissa yep and Carissa
wanted to claimer draw the first time
around it wasn't successful okay right
and the second time she was really
studying her score sheet and then making
sure she came she can claim it and here
we saw the bishop D7 but players laughed
about it because it looked like they
both want to make a draw so it was a
happy ending for both players exactly
but you have to do it correctly and once
again tell us about traditional scorings
the traditional scoring this 1.4 win
half a point for a draw and zero points
for a lot now tell us about the schedule
schedule is very simple we start each
day 1 pm central time today we had round
five but tomorrow there is a rest day
for all players in every tournament and
then on Friday we pick it up again
around six until around nine and if
necessary on Tuesday July 25th there
will be playoffs and tomorrow that rest
day is a very special day of Celebration
here in the Central West End if you're
anywhere close to the St Louis club and
Scholastic Center come and help us
celebrate our 50th 15th anniversary it
went by really really fast there's going
to be a lot of fun things to do and I'm
sure the players are all going to hang
out to do some signings
but we're very fortunate to have in the
studio with us Christian to tell us all
about the big head-to-head clashes
coming up Christian
good to see you guys fun exciting
moments here at the three national
championships but let's take a look and
highlight who the main protagonists are
as we are entering round five here in St
Louis and we're going to start with the
senior section we have two amazing
players that are vying for position
right now of course I'm talking about
Maxim loogie and Malik said katian who
are just having an incredible start to
distortment three and a half out of four
for both of these players but I have to
say back-to-back victories and Maxim
loogie has been impressing in the end
game phase of his games he has been able
to outplay his opponents in the end game
and take a look at this today they're
actually meeting each other is going to
be Melissa kachian with the white pieces
against Maxim Boogie this is a critical
clash and take a look at that they are
both ready they both arrived early at
the playing hole setting up the their
piece is getting ready to rumble and
let's take a look at what's happening in
the junior section as we are entering
round five we have a three-way tie at
the top Brandon Jacobson ABI Manu Mishra
and arturugo and I have to say as you
highlighted the yaser ABI manu's
decision yesterday to continue the game
in those final few seconds that was just
an incredible a Winner's decision
Brandon Jacobson also very very
difficult game and arturugu three in a
row after losing the first game I have
to say Arturo is looking good and let's
take a look at the pairings and who are
the main protagonists playing against
today Mishra is playing against Jason
Liang dagupati versus Jacobson and
arturuguo versus Josiah Sturman a lot of
interesting clashes coming your way take
a look at that abimaru is raised rock
and roll the usual intense uh there that
he has been giving us so many times Alex
was able to get it I think she snuck her
way
I think frisborg did his job on that one
and speaking of Alice she is leading the
event we gonna have out of four hasn't
lost a single game only one row but I
have to say she has been dominant in All
Phases of the game she's playing
incredible chess and I have to say right
now she is looking like the leader that
she is and uh take a look at who she
will be facing today another
up-and-comer in this tournament that is
Rochelle who is doing amazing in the
event two and a half one point behind
Alice Lee if she manages to defeat her
with the white pieces she is going to be
able to catch her as we are entering the
final stretch of the event guys a lot of
exciting chats coming your way indeed it
is a Christian and Kate do the honors
tell our viewers what they can expect
for round five pairings start with the
girls please right let's take a look so
we have in a girl section we have tank
against Atwell who against Lee that's
the big matchup of today in the girl
section Leo against Yen Yip against
prasanna and other acting important
match here agreed and then Mo against
mangalam and in the junior section the
key matchups key matchup so we start
with gazarian Wong but then Mishra Liang
Zhu Hong dagupati again Jacobson and go
against steel man yeah that board for
the all Grandmaster Clash that's going
to be good and of course in the uh
Legends and in the legend we have it on
board once belly katian against Maxim
loogie the leaders are facing each other
with three and half points and then we
go with Ruth against
facing Benjamin wolf novikov and
shabalov against accopian Wards one
three and five all Marquee matchups and
these players are fighting hard as we
see them getting ready for this round
five but uh
and Balaji I have to say look he's been
having a difficult start in the
tournament but yesterday's win without a
pieces yeah that was big that that was a
good one that was uh definitely an
improvement to his play to her to his
confidence as well huge huge result and
Brandon Jacobson he had an important one
yesterday against Arthur but a big win
because there were some chances for a
draw oh for sure yes there we see our
girls leader Alice Lee but I want to say
Rochelle and Carissa who are chasing her
by one point both Michelle and Carissa
have been very fortunate in the
tournament and you get that feeling when
you're when your opponents are not
taking advantage of winning positions
save them got to feel very confident in
Rochelle looking for an opportunity to
upset his tournament leader Rochelle had
a very difficult game yesterday exactly
losing but after that too and while
Carissa didn't have a lot of chances
afterwards but Rochelle could have
potentially won that game against ruyang
if you remember with the two pieces
Against The Rook so definitely what
she's showing in this tournament up to
this point is tenacity
starting D4 yeah
Alice is creating the board making sure
all the squares are nice right
C4 okay normal place so far what do we
expect C6 or E6 E6 okay
and that's one thing
that we can see with Alice Lee early on
in her career she's very well prepared
in the opening phase which is atypical
for a player her age absolutely
absolutely no I mean uh I think the
players today they're maturity their
knowledge of the openings is amazing
it's amazing I mean when I was 13 all
the way up I want to say to the 17
years of age I was flip-flopping in my
opening choices I wouldn't like this I
would like that
and A7 A6 a move that really I want to
say has been popularized by Magnus
Carlson and it always struck me as a
very very strange move in the A7 A6 I
mean you're not paying attention to the
center you're basically trying to force
white to resolve the tension because if
you allow black will take and likely try
to keep the pawn yeah and black is ready
to Define it with B5 exactly so and the
one of the one of the key benefits I
want to say of the move A7 A6 is if you
go E4 takes Knight takes you're in this
bishop B4 check position from the slav
instead of having a Pawn on A6 the pawn
would be on A7 but the C Pawn would be
on C6 where it stands considerably worse
the pawn on C7 covers the D6 Square so
in this position
uh takes takes which comes from the slav
that would be upon on C6 in Black of
course within this position clay Knight
C6 right have a perfectly wonderful game
so the idea of A7 A6 is on the one hand
to discourage E2 E4 and the other hand
to encourage white to resolve the
tension and we see Rochelle capturing
actually on D5 right so he takes he
takes I think that's the main line
exactly at least he's considered to be
the main line you can play in this type
of positions in a lot of ways exactly
and Bishop f4 on the board and what's
got your eye Christian is uh early early
moments of uh round five well we do have
another A6 early on in this game between
abhimani Mishra and Jason Liang and I
think this is particularly aimed against
abima news Catalan and we have seen
abhimanyu essay the Catalan he knows it
quite well that was the game against
Brandon Jacobson you remember that
preparation of Brandon but take a look
at this Knight to F3 this is a little
bit different and now A6 this
specifically as I mentioned against the
catalog because if you do go G3 then I
can just simply go B5 and this in fact
is considered to be quite okay for uh
black maybe not equalized completely yet
but definitely on a track to doing so so
generally right now after A6 you want to
stop the move B5 and the way to do that
which he did by the way is the move
Knight to C3 now we have D5 and this is
very similar to what we have in the
Rochelle versus Alice Lee because you
can take on D5 and then go Bishop to F4
and you will get something very very
similar but in fact I'll be money take a
look at this he chooses C5
taking advantage of the fact that the
pawn is no longer on A7 with the pawn on
A7 it would be much easier to play the
move B6 right because after C takes B6
you would be able to recapture towards
the center we are always taught that you
should recap recapture towards the
center in this case this is the way you
should be doing it A7 takes B6 you
cannot do that you will have to take
with the c pawn and then you get this
type of structure which it seems like
already with the pawn on E6 is good for
white because you no longer have a good
way to get your Bishop out Bishop to F5
or Bishop to G4 get the bishop over uh
this uh Pawn wall right so this is going
to be some sort of an exchange slav type
of structure but I have to say this
favor is white because he already played
the move B6 which in general you don't
see in the exchange slab you see
directly B5 so I can see a couple of
ideas that would point to the fact that
white is better or in this position I
have to say I really enjoy this move C5
and by the way
he played B6 C takes B6
and he didn't capture back he played the
move C5 I'm looking at the games there
are some games there's a big one vidit
versus Mama diarov a lot of intriguing
uh stuff is happening early on in the
games at the national championships guys
back to you thank you Christian and one
of the things that I always as a
competitor enjoyed is the day before the
free day I thought I could go all out
you know I'm going to get a day to
recharge my battery so I'm gonna put all
my energy in these games of uh the
rounds where it's the day before the
free day and tomorrow will be free day
I've got this uh crazy position in front
of me between Kelsey and Rue Yang Yan
Kelsey Lou and okay everything's fine
we've got a night or right Bishop G5 and
there are a couple of moves here the by
far the main line goes E7 E6 but we've
seen in
various stuff including don't even ask
me why I don't even want to go there G6
I mean but Knight B8 to D7 that
definitely had a surge of popularity the
whole idea behind this move is
occasionally enough you haven't declared
whether or not you're going to play E5
or you want to toss in a quick H6 and if
you could boot the bishop back even to
continue with G5 the drawback of this
move had always been considered to be
the move Bishop C4 that
the bishop now has this great square and
Bobby Fischer has proven time and time
again how effective the bishop can be on
C4
Queen B6
trying to capture the 1v2 at least
attacking it but but the poison Pawn you
don't you you you're not going to be
able to capture the the pawn on on B2
anymore after the move Bishop B3 and I'm
thinking the Queen's misplaced and if
this is a theory I'm I just am amazed E7
E6 so far everything's okay and then I
would have thought okay with the bishop
on B3 uh nicely pointing at the E6 Pawn
you the usual idea is to go F4 and F5
and you know blast open the diagonal no
she went A4 and I'm like okay what's
going on now because as long as the
Queen's in front
of the Pawn on B7 there's no threat to
play B5 so you're making a preventive
move on a threat that doesn't even
exists
now plays Queen A5 right okay stop that
pawn from advancing and by the way just
reminding white there is a tickle across
the board there there's also Knight
takes E4 Knight takes E4 as well as
Queen takes A5 in all the cases I think
I'm being provoked to play the move
Queen D2 at least covering so I was
going to say instead of the move A4 if
you don't like F4 you certainly gotta
like castles and put your King on H1 and
then play F4 and Away you go I also want
to just before we leave the girls I want
to go to the game of Carissa and uh
Gracie for just a moment so this is a
really low Roy Lopez jugorian variation
and I like all players of my generation
you just had to study these positions I
studied this also exactly it was just
like a writing you got to do it you just
gotta do it so after the move Queen C7 I
mean everybody and I mean everybody and
their brothers this is where we studied
night B one to D2 and the whole point
was not
to play the move d4 D5 not to play the
move d4d5 too early light you sometimes
wait for the Knight to go back
sometimes you wait for the bishop to go
to B7 and you only shut down the
position when black has committed their
Bishops to B7 or their Knight to C6
otherwise you keep the tension and the
reason is is because of this move Knight
C4 the Knight on C4 usually will get
booted back but it'll get booted back to
the square B6 where it's actually quite
useful it's not useful on A5 and
secondly this bishop is not on B7 but
this bishop is actually patrolling a
diagonal that's very useful oftentimes
as we've seen in numerous games Knight
goes to F5 well the bishop is ready to
meet the Knight on B5 so we always
thought that the positions after Knight
C4 B3 Knight to B6 Knight B8 to D2 were
equal at black at already equalized and
you could play A6 A5 followed by C5 C4
and you had nothing to worry about now
the crazy part is you would have
um
uh most especially Boris basky
most respect you you'd be amazed how
many how many times Boris basket did
this in his career
wow please sacrificed what just right
now what like what that's crazy right
and and his whole idea was you get these
two fluid pawns uh in the center like
this Knight is going to go back
You're Gonna Play Bishop to B7 and at
first you you you're very very confused
you can't understand what black is doing
then later later it slowly Dawns on you
that well it's not so easy to refute and
there is play for black and again you
you I I just encourage you to look at
the games of Boris basket because it was
a very confounding uh peace sacrifice
for two pawns and he did it often in his
career it's like unless you've seen it
and they obviously caught you by
surprise yeah you did that yeah it's
it's quite uh something but uh Christian
I want to jump over to you and ask you
in the other tournaments what's caught
your eye I'm looking at the junior
section there is one game in particular
which caught my eye because it's quite
interesting and it's something that I
actually haven't seen before take a look
at this early on in this real Lopez very
main line of the real Lopez we've seen
Knight A5 followed by C5 that gory brain
which we have in the Carissa game Bishop
to B7 is a very typical side playing it
side Sev Knight to B8 the Briar you can
play by the way Rook 28 you can play
Bishop but B7 followed by Knight to D7
you have a lot of setups right available
at your disposal but one thing and one
setup that I haven't seen yet
is Bishop to D7 take a look at this move
very strange move but there's some
tactical reasons behind it D4 and now A5
what's the first thing that comes to
your mind what if A4 okay that's a good
one yes yes to my eyes because I'm
trying to compare it to The Brighter
right was D5 right okay if I force the
Knight to B8 and Bishop is already on D7
that does make a lot of sense right
because this Knight usually goes to D7
but what you can do after D5 you have
this nice tactical shot with A4 you
cannot take because this is actually
lost after Rook takes A2 wow you take on
A2 I take back and you don't have a good
way to stop me from promoting that pawn
so very nice variation obviously this is
seems to be well known by Brandon and by
the way there's only one big game in
this line recently it's a game between
Dominguez and Eric Hansen I would assume
this was probably some sort of title to
use the Blitz game or rapid game
something along those lines
what else A4 as you were mentioning
right makes a lot of sense it seems like
this line which is going to be played A4
is on the board and we're going to see B
takes a for almost uh instantaneously
because we've seen Brandon he's he's
very good with his opening preparation
uh by the way he's been blitzing out his
moves A4 take take a knight to B4 and we
get to this position which seems to be
extremely complex but now we kind of
understand why the bishop is on D7 it
makes some sense it definitely has uh
that um
well this is a surprise that surprise
element to it right and as you can see B
takes A4 is on the board
talking about the night before about
Brandon who is playing really fast let's
look at players who are not playing
really fast what about the senior
section I think the main matchup between
Malay katian and Maxine blogie there are
only two moves on the board three moves
on the board right now they've been
taking it easy they've been taking it
easy okay uh what is happening is that
like a reverse right a slab with an
extra tempo for a while so uh Alexa
Knight F3 and Max played C5
so max is inviting an open Sicilian
would you like to play an open Sicilian
E2 uh to E4
and like I said was probably thinking
well it's an interesting invitation but
what are we going to get we're going to
get a Richter Rouser
um or do I want to play a ready I want
to play with G3 or maybe I want to
transpose back into some kind of a
groomfeld with C4 so there was my like
it said the thinking about and he says
you know what maybe I can get you into a
kind of a slob because Max doesn't play
slob and now Max says wait a minute you
you I'm not getting my groomfeld I'm not
getting my uh open Sicilian now what do
I have to play and literally they'd only
played two moves everybody's in the
depth trying to out Theory the opponent
right and so he said okay I'll take the
center with D5 D4 now this is an
invitation to go into an exchange law
which you know okay it does have a
drawing reputation but white is the one
who has the opening first move
symmetrical position slight Advantage
for white
no said max I'm gonna play E7 E6 and now
you're going to play either a London
system or some kind of a Kali system
with the pawn on C3 and I love these
opening duels where the players try to
out Fox one another and try to get their
uh opening on the board by the way I
believe that Bishop D7 is the Keras
variation of the rui Lopez is that how
it's called I think Paul cares played a
number of games with A5 as well as
Bishop D7 and more than anybody he
pushed the theory on that one I just
want to go to some of the other key
matchups uh Alexander shabalov versus
vladimiricopian uh
this um it's not the nimso what a BOGO
Indian I used to play the begolia buff
nobody could pronounce begolia buff so
we called it the BOGO Indian Bishop B4
check Knight C3 would transpose back
into a nimzo bishop D2 Queen E7 I played
this as black on a number of occasions
the idea is that I do want to trade
Bishops and then change the structure
dramatically by going D6 and E5
uh that did not take place uh uh Shabba
played Knight D2
d7d5 G3 it's kind of a Catalan with uh
Bishop on B4 normally I'm used to seeing
Queen C2 Bishop G2 here but theories
very early and then again another key
matchup Gregory kaitanov Joe Benjamin
we've been seeing Oh this is popular wow
suddenly
yeah who was the next one Andrew Hong
well it was like the first Carissa was
the second yeah and everybody was
playing this and well white was doing
really well this isn't like some strange
variation where the Knight was going to
uh B4 and the queen was being dragged
back to D2 Joel looks like he's just
going through the files
tell our viewers okay so you're coming
to the game
you've got your preparation
lucky lucky you your preparation is on
the board except now you're at a
Crossroads how do you remember your
preparation do you remember it as a do
you have a mental image is it a file in
your mind you're seeing the board how do
you remember your preparation that's
that's another good question
um
I think I I have a visual memory when I
was going through it what was happening
and also the connections like maybe here
it's very natural to get I mean E6 black
wants to get the bishop out Knight C3
I'm developing but then you know that
sometimes the queen retracts from
Retreats
right
but to be honest I'm not very big
theoretician my memory is not very good
so sometimes I'm just like you know what
let's just mix let's just make a move
that makes sense and and hope for the
best and how about you uh Christian when
you when you've got even lucky lucky you
you've got your preparation on the board
but you're at a Crossroads it is a very
very important Crossroads that you're at
and you know you have a choice between
two different variations do you see the
do you see the file in your mind as a
screen so if I still have it right yeah
you've got you you so so you're at this
position where you could choose a or b
prior to the game you thought you were
going to go with the line a but you just
want to recall for yourself line B do
you see it as uh basically what I'm
trying to do is
um I usually remember the end of the
line and how the end of the line looks
like so I'm trying to make my way back
to uh reverse entry reverse engineer
where I have to get to right that's one
way of course you know you you see the
generally nowadays you see and you
prepare with a 2d board right right in
general when you come at the board it's
a 3D board right so then it comes the
question do you uh uh practice with a
board next to you or do you practice
only with the computer screen next to
you nowadays to be honest I only
practice especially openings with just
with a computer screen right and it's
very rarely that even at the elite level
people still travel with a chessboard
and chess set with them they don't do
that anymore they just practice with the
screen they repeat those lines and this
is uh key they repeat the lines very
very often so it kind of becomes a
second language to them uh their opening
repertoire right so they have a much
easier way and this is part of being a
professional chess player you have to do
that in order to remember absolutely
everything if you don't do that then yes
you will be forgetting and then you have
to
um you know require some tricks such as
reverse engineering engineering things
of that nature and very often you just
forget stuff that's the way it goes you
forget stuff and then you play uh what
looks like the best or the most natural
move and then you take it from there and
try to make a good game happen but take
a look guys I mean we really need to uh
let's go to this game because this one
is speeding up to I actually have no
idea what I'm trying to understand the
assessment of the final position as I
will show you and you probably will not
understand either take a look at this
this game between abimanu and Jason
Liang Bishop to F4 Bishop to D6 you can
also take on B6 but generally after
Knight Wave 4 it seems like this gives
white some sort of an advantage I'm
going to take on C5 at some point you're
going to have to give me your Bishop
maybe you will restore the material
balance but it's not going to be enough
to get full equality so I like this for
white obviously Jason seems to have
liked it for white as well in his
preparation and he chose to go for a
different line Bishop to D6 take take
take take and by the way both of these
players right now are speeding through
these moves E4 novelty
early novelty E3 was played before Rook
to C1 as well E4 not so much take a look
at this one hour and 32 minutes he still
knows what he's doing both of these
players with a novelty they still know
and this is a peace Sacrifice by the way
right D4 E5 Queen to B4 Knight takes D4
Castle
they're speeding up through this Knight
to F5 Queen to F3 take a look at this
Knight to D5 take take peace sacrifice
don't go Rook to ba try to defend the uh
look that's Checkmate in one move so
don't do that you have to give up The
Rook which he does Castle Queen takes A8
Knight to E3
what in the world is happening here the
competition needs the F5 Square I'm
threatening some sort of a Checkmate if
you go B7 maybe some Queen C5 Queen C2
ideas you're in trouble if you don't
take on E3 you have to take on E3 check
first this is a position that we
currently have on the board and white
has a couple of options
King to D2 or King to B1 it seems like
after King to B1 we get to this position
Bishop to uh F5 Bishop to D3 maybe
bishop takes D3 you can also take on E8
we'll see which one is uh by uh Black by
Jason Liang but you can also take on D3
first at least to my eyes this looks
like the most natural right you take and
it doesn't seem like you will be able to
get the queen back maybe black is just
winning B7 no no no no no no B7 now
you're in trouble well if you go Rook to
ba the most natural you are in trouble
because I go Rook to C1 you have to
defend C8 maybe with Queen to f8 but
unfortunately for you you're just simply
not in time I can go Rook to C3 followed
by Rook to C8 get the queen back and
that's going to be winning for white
it's going to lead to a winning
Advantage for white so you have to do uh
after Rook to C1 first of all sorry
after B7 you have to go Rook f8 hide the
Rook on uh f8 Rook to C1 and now you
have to attack the pawn queen to B5 and
we get this position Rook to B3 Queen
takes E5 which seems to lead to some
sort of equality this is equal I'm not
sure exactly why
this is deep stuff guys how do you
remember this type of opening
preparation when your opponent surprises
you because
you can I can guarantee you he did not
expect this move A6 as early as move 3
from black right yet abhimanyu knows
this idea knows this novelty with E4 all
the way at movie 11. and then his
opponent Jason says yeah E4 no problem I
have this in my file I've looked at this
I've prepared this incredible opening
preparation and it comes back to what
you guys were mentioning broadcast this
is the round they're giving their all in
right right in their preparation their
older energy is spent on the preparation
and on the game itself because tomorrow
it's a rest day right and I mean it goes
with the conversation we're having about
preparation right both players seem to
be yeah dueling one another in the
preparation this is extraordinary right
I mean the the the the the position got
hosed
the clocks reveal that both players are
familiar but it was this move Knight E3
that is a real stunner because if you go
to the position right here uh mishra's
just grabbed the room he said do your
worst uh you can win the pawn back on B6
and we need to understand okay
take that pawn but this move Knight E3
is the cold shower move because
it's prepping the move Bishop F5 like
you would just love to take Queen C5
check King B1 and very happily put your
king in the corner until you realize
your Queen's hanging and now you
understand why the F5 Square was vacated
so this this position he did play King
D2 by the way after Queen C5 check your
move King okay this is the board King
the two is just a repetition Queen to B4
check Queen to B4 Queen to a five and
that's some work on the board by the way
and the problem is once again you can't
walk to a light Square King E2 he went
back to C1 he's going to back to C5 and
now you have to go King B1 to continue
the game right maybe I mean man you just
like got extra extra 30 seconds like
okay are you gonna give me a check on
before but you you were showing us this
incredible variation Christian that went
Shaq Bishop here and I was thinking to
myself that well gee this would be
dangerous for white
if he took the queen right you take the
queen
and if you took the bishop then you
would just take the pawn and I have a
queen for a rook and a piece you
probably have to go back into those
lines
takes takes we transpose back into this
completely you know obscure crazy I
don't even know
how you get to an ending through your
preparation it's like just incredible
preparation wow and take a look at this
yes please the line keeps going no the
line keeps going okay so you get to this
position I think this is where we left
it somewhere around here yeah and now
you play something like A3 as white wow
and now you only have one move as black
but if you go H6 for example then I will
go to C8 and unfortunately after E4
you're just lost because now I have the
extra Square A2 and my king is safe you
have to take I go King A2 and then you
cannot stop me from promoting
um so what you have to do after this
move A3 you can do it uh before work to
C8 or after Rook to see it you can also
play E3 at this point the response is
going to be uh the same after A3 you
have to go Queen B8
that's the only move in the position and
now you just basically wait King to a
two you go G6 maybe uh White is going to
try to push the pawns on the queen side
but whenever you push the pawns on the
queen side then you have to worry about
the King to my eyes and probably to the
engine eyes as well the engine of Jason
the engine of abhimani at certain depth
this is probably just triple zeros right
now the engine is saying 0.4 but I would
assume that at a certain depth this is
just uh completely equal and perhaps
Json knows it let's see whether rabi
money is going to buy the bullet and say
okay show me I can continue with King to
B1 show me if you know absolutely
everything and by the way we're at move
in my analysis this is move 30.
I don't think Jason is going to have any
trouble you know Crossing that four-day
move time control he may even have two
hours after those 10 moves that is
amazing imagine preparing a game all the
way to move 40. the one thing the one
time I remember it was I think it was a
game between Maxine last year lagrav and
Sergey kariakin that went all the way to
move 40 with opening preparation it was
just a ridiculous game at the single cup
remember many many years back so
incredible preparation everybody knows
what they're doing in this competition
finally we see I believe King to B1 yes
an invitation for a fight show me what
you got exactly Bishop F5 check they're
gonna go right into that yeah one of the
seniors said wait a minute what are
these guys doing what are these guys
what are these this is Junior chess what
are these guys doing this is move 34
guys right at 24 sorry
uh one of my favorite stories I
uh it was the Tata steel chess Festival
that goes on each and every year in
January and if I can say Holland and I
had come late to the round uh like three
hours after the start and I just hung up
my coat
in the media center I saw Boris gelfand
and Logan Valley and they were analyzing
their game
and uh so I understood they had made a
grand master draw these were the days
where draw offers were allowed
so I understood they've made a grand
master draw and I came and I was
watching them ah it was Patrick Wolfe
that was wondering what the heck is
going on here why do they play so fast
exactly I was watching them analyze and
they were analyzing an end game
and there's a group of people standing
around and I sat next to them and
analyzing the end game I thought it was
a grand master draw right so I said
excuse me Boris could could you give me
your score sheet right so score sheet
you know those move 46. they played 46
moves in three hours and you know this
is a draw like so I was going down it
was one of those groomfeld defenses
everything looked very very routine very
correct it was a wonderful game
46 moves draw wow okay so I said to
Boris so what was the novelty because oh
I think that move B6 B6 way back when
that was a novelty and there was a guy
uh Jan van der mortal who's just
standing behind me was a part of the
media center he says no that wasn't the
novelty
everybody turned and said well what was
the novelty he said well the novelty was
the draw for you were following a game
of Yvonne Chuck that went another three
moves
I was like what the 49 move uh the
novelty was the draw yeah which cannot
happen in this tournament and the
players have to have to play no draws
and look at that I mean Mishra and and
here we go yeah that was the whole thing
after Bishop check yep take the queen
you have to play B7 because otherwise
you're just worse and now they're going
into that line straight
into that line I mean wow by the way uh
just a big shout out to audience thank
you so much for uh joining us but there
is a way for our audience to join the
conversation and to stump our panel of
experts that is yourselves yeah
do you say everyone to ask us questions
or leave comments on YouTube twitch
Twitter Instagram and Facebook tag the
St Louis chess club or you use the
hashtag you as generous chess you're a
sinner's chest or a setlist chess club
we welcome your questions we've been
having some really good ones
and we have a tweet well look at that
asked and answered here it comes let's
let's see who is this this is from think
like on Twitch and the question is do
you think the seniors like the no draw
offers more or less than the Juniors I
would say that the seniors hate the new
draw offers I would say that for many of
the seniors who have played their whole
careers and really based a lot of their
openings over when to make that
strategic draw offer and although you
didn't see it when before we came on the
air or a broadcast uh Chris bird the
international Arbiter has joined us
during our rehearsals and said do you
know we have a problem with Dimitri
gurvich I said what's the problem Chris
well Dimitri he likes to write down his
move before he plays it because that
used to be okay then that was not only
was that a rule that it was allowed it
was encouraged if you um it was kota's
book Terror book book think like a
Grandmaster
where he said
write down your move
think about the move and then look at it
from beginner's eyes am I blundering
anything is anything on pre and then
when you see that nothing is on pre then
you make the move so so the training was
to write down your move before you
played it now it's illegal that is
considered taking notes and you're not
allowed to do that so Chris is going to
to Dima and saying uh you know don't
write down your moves you know I'm
giving you a warning right right right
and then of course he does it because
it's wired
Grace and he's like I'm sorry
so yeah I mean I think that the seniors
have always had the draw offer as a rule
and so they're a little bit thrown off
what's your take I honestly like it very
much I like this I don't have to worry
about thinking about offering draw or
thinking if my players you know if they
surprise me yeah here it is it's the
chief Arbiter yeah so I don't have to
think about it I know my opponent is not
going to offer me a draw I can offer a
draw and we just play uh and I just
calculate what is happening on the board
so I'm a really favorite of this rule
what about you Christian I don't think
that's such a deep question that
requires three answers no I think you
guys covered everything so I'm just
gonna go back to chess all right all
right we're gonna get to this game
between kurugazarian and Justin Wang
because take a look at this
by the way had a terrible game yesterday
you remember
96 Knight h8 my goodness what was
happening with uh the dance of uh that
night that particular night but take a
look at what's happening and he's shown
his expertise in the Catalan uh in the
first game against Josiah sermon right
now also getting a great position out of
the opening against Justin Wang take a
look at this
Bishop to B4 already a step in the wrong
direction and to be honest I'm trying to
understand why he made this move because
immediately Kurt understood that he has
to pin the Knight the best response in
the position Knight to D7 and now he has
a golden opportunity to get a great
Advantage with the move D5 perhaps this
is something that was missed by Justin
Wang because he's been thinking he's
definitely not in his preparation right
now and after D5 you probably have to
take if you take on c3a take on C6
you're completely losing in that
position so you have to take on the fire
I take back on D5 if you give me your
light score Bishop you allow my Rook to
potentially double up
um with the help of its body on A1 on
the D file I mean that's going to be
really really bad right and I'm getting
my Pawn back no problem I'm going to
recapture that pawn uh reinstate the
material balance after Queen takes C4 so
maybe you have to go something like
Bishop D6 but now I can go Knight to D4
and force you to give me the bishop
right you take on D5 I take back once
again you cannot touch this bishop
because you're losing the queen so I'm
looking at the position my knight is
coming to F5 my queen maybe will be
taking on C4 I have this beautiful
Bishop on uh the long diagonal the light
Square Bishop with no counterpart uh
from black so I mean this is looking
like a dream Catalan come true for a
corgazerian if he finds D5 he has a
great chance to bounce back with a
tremendous win against Justin whack
thank you for that by the way struggling
yesterday had a difficult game against
Arthur Gua remember that one it was all
going till the end but he was on the
back foot from the beginning and
speaking of Pawns on D5
right
white just captured Pawn takes D5 right
I was just going to say that we have a
Duo of hat tricks uh Arthur's one of the
duo or the other is Max delugie both
players on a roll of three in a row this
comes from uh this uh line of uh the
open Sicilian with this early Bishop to
D3 and it's always a confounded me
like as a beginning player I was always
told to capture towards the center that
was what we do is we capture towards the
center and whenever white gives black
the center that black should take it
occupy the center and have an advantage
so when I look at these positions with
the eyes of a beginner I always say that
black is equalized then I'm confounded
by the fact that in modern chess we
often see why doing this this is
actually a very topical line and after
Queen B6 castles well what's the only
problem that black has in the position
you trade that Bishop off if you could
magically reach across the board and
trade off the light Square Bishops no
issues right Bishop E7 castles black has
a perfectly saved King good control of
the center good development first pieces
uh he's he's he's got the perfect
opening so Bishop A6 takes on D5 and
this is where the crazy part is it's
confounding if for example you capture
on D3 which is the whole idea of Bishop
A6 you wanted to trade and if for
example you capture with the c Pawn take
towards the center well Queen A4 check
is gonna
leave you upset
like still I mean has to worry about the
king in the center you said Bishop B7
Castle but white is not going to give
you the time exactly if you capture with
the other font well then you've got
initials the other way so you're gonna
have to take with the Knight and then
after Knight takes D5 night night to C4
it's like you've got a good night but so
do I and this is a position where well
white probably had has uh an edge you
sit there scratching your head and
saying well didn't white break some
rules but he's better so Arthur uh I
think he's got a slight Advantage coming
out of the opening and we'll keep an eye
on this one I again I want to just go to
the all Grandmaster uh clash in the
junior section because I'm looking at
the position and I'm forcibly reminded
of the world championship match in 1990
between Kasparov and karpov it was a
zaitsef variation and it was a really
incredibly beautiful game that Gary won
where he had this exact structure and he
put his Rook back on A3 very very nicely
and he played Knight H2 and rookie the
third rank is a really really beautiful
game uh one of the did you have to do
that or or did your coach make you do it
or did you do it yourself but I made
myself go through all of the World
Championship
uh match games oh wow I had to I studied
every single one of them not just for
the history but I wanted to know how
world champions did it I think we picked
specific matches and then we went over
all the games but I don't think I I've
seen like it wasn't on purpose to see
everything it was more speaking certain
matches right how about you Christian
was it a part of your training as you
learn chess to go over all the World
Championships no no no but why not the
best players probably that's why I
stayed uncultured no
no I actually uh went through most of
the world championship matches uh later
on in my chess career by myself
um and maybe I don't remember exactly
what the coaches were showing me when I
was a kid I started off when I was like
five you started off when you were quite
late 12 12 right I started off when I
was five so probably whenever I was
seven probably some coach was showing me
the world championship matches I just
wasn't registering it
um what I remember doing with my coaches
I had some opening coaches specifically
opening coaches that were showing me
only certain openings that was one of
the things one of the specialization
items that I was doing when I was a kid
but uh no mostly on my own whenever I
went through this world championship
matches well just on that note sorry for
pressing the the point there just a
minute Christian you helped Fabiano in
2018. that's right as he went up against
Magnus Carlson a world championship
match do you know if Fabi made an effort
to study all of his predecessors matches
leading up to that match no no no no no
just magnus's matches he didn't no we we
looked through magnus's games obviously
we discussed them but I don't think it
was all of them or anything of that
nature and we didn't have any sort of
hey let's analyze this specific match
and see how it went that kind of went
into the general preparation intriguing
I want to turn our attention to the game
of Arthur Zhu versus Andrew hung for
just a moment because uh there's a
surprise move uh we've seen this uh
position earlier in the competition A7
A6 and in this particular game uh I I
think we've seen H3 and Bishop E3 but
Arthur decided Well what he really
really wants to do is play the move four
to play the move F4 you got to get up
your night out of the way which is what
he did he played Knight to D2 and then
came the surprise very surprising
wait a minute I stopped you from doing
that I was like you did not stop me
three pieces controlling that square
I've got the bishop the Knight and the
Fawn on C4 and I'm gonna play B5 anyway
so
so I'm assuming it's kind of like what
you might get from a benko Gambit some
kind of a Banco Gambit so if I go Knight
B6 I'm attacking the bishop if you take
I'll take the bishop I'll recapture the
pawn and you're probably very happy um
yeah let's say I've got full
compensation I'm assuming The Bishop's
going to come back and then I'm going to
take and I'm going to take because and
now the question is after a move like
Bishop A6 it's not a Benco Gambit but
it's a compensation what's your first uh
initial so here you have to move the
Knight back right because after A4 I
will simply capture it that's a bit
embarrassing the intention of of
defending the night it's a small flaw
this is small form okay you're right I'm
going to retreat okay I did it I retweet
it and then I'm assuming D5 D5 looks
very natural I right I'm ready with my
pieces I want to push forward is the
compensation worth about well that's a
good question let me let me think a
little bit I feel like we always have to
answer so quickly
but I think I would prefer here black I
always like the compensation I always I
mean I always like the active pieces the
initiative and here I mean the bishop on
C2 is really stuck right I guess white
has to play something like rookie one
okay
yeah Vladimir cram next move we teased
Vladimir When Vladimir didn't know what
to do as white he always put his Rook on
E1 and I'm not joking look it up look at
his games they're hilariously funny if
you're just looking for that in his
games
I'm like every occasion he could it was
very nice yeah but rookie won I think
it's compensation but again uh
let's look at that uh and by the way as
I'm going through the games let's just
remind everybody all of this Fighting
Chess what are they flying fighting for
very generous price one in the U.S girls
junior we have a price fund of twenty
thousand dollars the first place has six
thousand dollars second place four
thousand third place three thousand all
the way to the 10th Place five hundred
dollars tell us about the prize fund for
the junior Championship the Juniors
their prize fund is 40 000 and the first
place takes on 12 000 second plate Place
eight thousand and third place five
thousand dollars all the way to the ten
Place one thousand dollars the very very
big bonus prizes for those two uh events
as well right very nice Champions bonus
because the winners of the Juniors and
junior girls will be awarded the two the
ten thousand uh scholarship generously
jointly funded by the the Wayne Barber
foundation and U.S chess and that ten
thousand dollar scholarships will go to
the players choice of their college or
university plus the other direct
qualification top finishers
automatically qualify for the U.S and
U.S Women's Championship here in Saint
Louis in October and tell us about the
allegiance uh seniors championships the
nurse Championship has a very big price
fund of 75 000 with the first place
taking home 20 000 second place thirteen
thousand third place ten thousand all
the way to the last place three thousand
dollars thank you to the St Louis chess
club and Scholastic Center for your
generous uh support of the players as
I'm just going around which uh event
should we go to let's go to the seniors
seniors and the leaders
Alexian against Maxim loogie that's the
Marquee matchup as our two leader it
looks like it's funny it's a one
variation
colors reversed but it's a direct
variation where white is playing black
with an extra Tempo you know you're
usually the queen might be already on
the C7 Square exactly at this point and
after E3 E4 uh here we are
um
your take first
um E4 so we want to recapture with the
Knight
so what black is going to capture back
Knight takes so if if black were to
capture everything well at the end of
the day you'd have to prefer white
because it's sort of like this bishop is
rather active this Rook is controlling
the bishop on C8 unclear where it's
going to be developed doesn't make a
very very pleasing impression which is
why oftentimes you do see this move
Queen C7 the idea behind Queen C7 kind
of controlling the E5 Square you want to
avoid uh you know E4 E5 and getting a
cramped position still early days in the
opening let's just go around the horn a
little bit off versus a copian and uh
Christian let's jump to you and see what
caught your eye we have a winning
position guys
Aryan found this idea with D5 and right
now black Justin Wang didn't respond
properly he played this move Bishop
seven which by the way looks like the
most natural response in the position
and if you don't find the next sequence
of moves then maybe black is going to be
more or less fine but
and by the way this was played uh Anand
made the same mistake in 1996 in a game
against uh Pickett
Lars Hansen larsbo Hansen Ripley Zoltan
a lot of grand Masters got to this
position made this mistake but it's
completely losing take a look at this
Knight takes F6 Bishop takes F6 and now
Knight to E5 everything is hanging in
the position the bishop on G5 tonight
only five of course you cannot take the
Knight on E5 because it was the queen
if you take on G5 then I take on C6 I
take on D7
if you move the Rook then I can just
simply go Knight to B6 oops that's going
to be an exchange you have absolutely no
compensation you don't have the light
Square Bishop to create any problems
against my king in the absence of my
light Square Bishop so this one is
looking completely winning easy win for
white and what else can you do you can
take on G2 I guess but after 97 this is
even worse
you take on G5 I take on f8 then I pick
up the bishop guys this is completely
winning if he finds Knight takes F6 and
Knight to E5 they can sign the score
sheets wow
uh I always if you can uh win out of the
opening that's great because look at the
importance of this Kirk would jump on
the trampoline right and he it would
catapult him to the to the lead together
with Brandon Jacobson
I think that's for me one of the worst
things it's if not the absolute worst
thing in chess I don't mind losing
that's part of the job you you sometimes
you're just gonna tip your hat but I
really love it when my opponents played
a great game and beat me really really
splendidly I learn a lot thank you very
much but when I lose out of the opening
I feel like such an idiot because my
opponent didn't even make an original
move and you said so wow you mentioned
some really great names that have fallen
into this uh opening trap there world
champion I mean hello I mean one of the
Great oh prepared players by the way
here we see Kirk thinking I just wanted
to turn our attention to the seniors for
a moment because I I'm having a senior
moment here and I can't understand
what's going on with me uh the I want to
refer to the game of Gregory kaidanov
and Joel Benjamin and help me out on
this one oh let's see let's see Knight
takes E7 he's not taking on F6 oh no no
no no he missed the opportunity no it's
equal oh no
oh oh oh
just that extra little thought and the
the crazy part if you had told him oh
you standing standing
I haven't seen what one of those in a
while uh if you had done that uh if you
had said to him and in this position you
have a winning move do you have a puzzle
Rush yeah then he would see it like 30
seconds because we are looking for that
winning trick right I I wanted to just
refer to our again our game between
kaidanov and Joe Benjamin because
something really it confused me and I
need I need your help here Kate
um
it was just move nine and Gregory played
the move Knight C3 nothing moved from
wrong whatsoever with the move Knight
c3u developing nothing could be wrong
looking at this position it was
scratching my head and I'm saying what
am I supposed to do after Knight G5
I'm threatening very quickly attacking
F7 well I mean we you know you've got to
play night afterwards right fours
I took it took us you take I take back
right and G4 maybe Queen H4 here Queen
H4 and I take
I take did I win a pawn no oh you have
this um
it's like an intermezzo
check
our producer Tom loves Zeus it says
but you are getting the point so if
Bishop captures back just okay to
complete the line yeah I mean I think
there's a compensation don't get me
wrong but uh I saw Knight G5 and I go
wait a minute it's like it looks like
such a dumb move right because it's such
an absurdly direct threat this move
Knight G5 but then I was thinking well I
follow it up you know if I follow it up
with G4
then I think after 1996 somehow
life goes on but I was trying to somehow
uh punish uh Black Knight F7 king of
seven and I didn't see an immediately
forced draw so if I go yesterday Queen
B6 Queen just kind of trying to attack
that diagonal sure
and
maybe even you want well although no
right now I just recapture back you just
recapture but but isn't your king more
vulnerable
I don't know I mean uh it's it's it's
struck me as pretty strange and unusual
opportunity you don't see that all the
time in the game by the way Knight C3
was chosen and the players have reached
I don't know if this is a theoretical
position or not it looks kind of like a
French defense but somehow the bishop on
D3 is missing so maybe black is fine uh
what do you have Christian on your board
I'm looking at this game between Zoe and
Rose Atwell and Zoe has been doing uh
tremendously well in this tournament up
to yesterday yesterday she had a
difficult game against Alice Lee we
remember that one but right now she's
looking to bounce back and that's
exactly what she's doing at least up to
this point this move H5 the last move
allows this expansion with A4 and this
is something that black really has to
stop if they want to have a good
position after E4 it just simply doesn't
look good because you have to start
retreating I'm threatening if I you
don't have time and perhaps this is what
she missed you don't have time to H4 if
you go H4 E5 this is looking really
really good for
um White Queen 26 maybe Knight to E2
Knight to have four things of that
nature I'm not going to take on F6
because you take on G3 but I'm just
simply going to push my knight back
um so after A4 I'm looking at the
position and the best move is to retreat
with Knight H7 but this allows me to go
E5 followed by f for it just seems like
white is playing well the players are
playing on one goal and that is Black's
goal F4 F5 the attack is devastating and
black doesn't really have a lot of
compensation for it so I'm seeing this
position she played E4 and Zoe is
definitely on her way to potentially
bouncing back rose is struggling in this
event
she came with High Hopes but right now
she really needs a miracle to get back
into this game wow okay I just uh as we
get prepared for our break I wanted to
jump into the game of Rochelle Wu and
Alice Lee that was the A7 A6 I don't
know if this has a name I'm sure it does
it's a Queen's Gambit decline with this
early a7a6 again uh variation
popularized by Magnus Carlson amongst
others and the players more or less they
they quickly achieved a position of a
mutual satisfaction I would say and
uh this was a surprise uh I think for
Rochelle when she played the move Queen
C2 I think she was being cagey herself
she was saying aren't I clever uh having
committed my night to either E2 or to
the F3 squares I'll first make a useful
move Queen C2 until uh Alice said excuse
me I think he made an error yeah because
96 is like double attack exactly the
Dual threat of Knight takes D4 oopsie
Daisy thanks to the pin on the king the
pawn is on pre and also as in the game
night before and you gave up a very
crucial Bishop I want to say this bishop
on D3 versus the bishop on C8 favors
white so against Knight C6 normally you
would like to play A3 and stop night
before so Alice I think has equalized
pretty comfortably out of the ending and
this is an important game for the
standings uh Kate right we see Alice Lee
leading with three and a half but
Rochelle chasing right after her with 12
half points so if Rochelle wins she
catch up she catches up but if Alice
wins then she's really getting a very
good start a crucial game for Rochelle
and I think Rochelle knows that she's
really given up her opening initiative
here I always hate that when you make
that one little error Queen C2 premature
but as we take uh get ready for our
first break we like to check in with our
good friends at Q Boutique and find out
what the specials are for today and
let's take a look here it comes we have
the 2023 us junior Championship polo
shirt this is a limited edition and it's
perfect for any chess Enthusiast the
poll features the tournament logo on the
breast and the St Louis chess club logo
on the right shoulder show your pride
for the game in style and comfort shop
for all your chest needs at Q Boutique
St louis.com and these are very very
comfortable shirts I've got the senior
the perfect girls you got the girls okay
okay yeah I mean I guess it didn't come
in large for me it's like my swollen
pectorals they don't have it for me
but we're gonna take a break and we'll
see you on the other side
[Music]
in 2019 the Missouri Bicentennial
commission along with Governor Mike
Parson approved the building of a
life-size chessboard to celebrate the
200th anniversary of the state of
Missouri Dr Jeannie sinkfield a lifelong
patron of scouting in Great Rivers
Council board member proposed that the
project be built as an Eagle Scout
project Genie invited 16 year old Andrew
Dowden of troop 6 Jefferson City to take
on this incredibly important project
my name is Andrew Dowden and I belong to
troop 6 in Jefferson City Missouri so my
troop we were down camping down at the
sing fields and Jeannie came down and
asked you know is anyone close to
getting their eagle or needing a project
she had this idea of the Eagle Scout
project chessboard and she wanted
somebody to kind of work with her to see
what we could come up with at the time I
kind of had a project in line but when
she brought up this idea obviously I
wanted to choose it because it was a lot
better idea than what I had started
prior to this project I did not really
know anything about Chess once I got
into this project I downloaded an app on
my phone started playing chess and I
took the chest merit badge down at Scout
camp this was a bicentennial chessboard
for the Historical Society of Missouri
there were a lot of people that helped
me with this project because whenever I
I got the pictures from the Historical
Society to engrave onto the granite I
wasn't very familiar with the technology
needed to engrave on there so I needed
some assistance with that and learning
how to do it and after all that I'm
pretty sure I know how to do it now so
to engrave those Edge pieces I went down
to the Lake of the Ozarks Scout
Reservation and we use the epilogue
laser me and Thomas Yang did I wasn't
really expecting it to end out this big
but as we me and Jeannie were working
um it just got kind of got bigger and
bigger and bigger which I didn't have a
problem with I thought you know I can
take on a little bit more and a little
bit more and
it ended out to be a really really cool
project so we had a ribbon cutting of
the chess board and there were a whole
bunch of people there including the
governor the St Louis chess club the
World Chess Hall of Fame the State
Historical Society which all helped out
during this entire project Jeannie was
there I had to give a little speech that
I didn't really know I had to do but
that kind has taught me a little bit
about speaking too so I think that has
helped me too this project it's made me
real proud that everyone is enjoying it
like every time I go down there
somebody's playing
um and then they're taking care of it
which really makes me proud because me
thinking all that time and everyone else
that's helped me sinking in all that
time I like to see people use it but I
also like to see people appreciate it
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today hello I'm women's grunt
Master William takorjonova I will be
doing social media for the US Juniors
and seniors chess championships follow
us in our social media and get more
exciting behind the scenes action
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess has
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
foreign the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr Jeannie
Karen sinkfield and Rex sinkfield the St
Louis chess club is a non-profit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
posting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions and our Galleries and sign
up for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchest hof.org
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
hello I'm women's Grandmaster begin
Tucker jonoa I'm doing social media for
the US Juniors and seniors championships
here in San Luis follow us for more
exciting behind the scenes content
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program in the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these
[Music]
thank you
hello
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the
2023 national championships and we have
a result in one of our most important
games as Mishra one of our tournament
co-leaders in the junior Championship
made a draw with Jason Lee hang and one
of the most remarkable pieces of
preparation Kate that we're ever ever
likely to say uh Mishra sacrificed his
Queen early got upon on B7 and on it's
only with perfect play Jason could
secure the draw but guess what he was
prepared for it throughout the whole
thing I mean these Juniors they are
ready for this tournament we saw it
yesterday we are seeing it today again
their preparation is very very deep so
here we go uh Queen E7 Rook B3 I mean
it's unbelievable to find these moves
Queen E7 Queen takes E5 uh Christian put
us through the paces and said uh with
perfect play Black and draw but he was
suggesting
even that white could play on with the
move A3 and I realized the response here
after A3 right A3 move oh sorry A3 move
yeah and this queen V8 just retreating
back guarding the C8 square right and
just defending or kind of attacking the
Portland V7 exactly Mishra did not play
A3 this was the repetition that what had
occurred uh back and forth they went and
a draw yeah the thing is after Queen B8
you you don't have a way to make any
progress that's right exactly it's just
that's it I'm just going to stay I'm
going to wait but you're gonna have to
wait as well sure you're waiting from
the better side but it's all a waiting
game at this point exactly uh remarkable
uh as that game uh made a draw let's go
to one of our uh Marquis well the
Marquee matchup is at least this is
their concern our two tournament
co-leaders are duking it out uh here in
round five and interestingly when we
elected it it was this reverse Murano
variation Rook E8
um so you were saying not to capture
only four right not to not to capture
but I was saying also you want to
control the E5 Square maybe move like
Queen C7 rookie eight invites this move
a move that uh well White
played E5 uh Knight G4 if you play
Knight D7 that kind of makes it easy for
me Knight D7 Rook E1 and I can defend
the E5 Pawn as as many times as you can
attack it Knight G4 on the other hand
has a dual purpose right it kind of
makes it impossible for me to play
rookie one and we have Knight B3 on the
board Bishop B6 and I'm expecting Bishop
F4 or queen E2 just defending the pawn
on E5 I'm not worried about some Bishop
takes H7 I'm very worried about Bishop
takes H7
sacrifices why not
what I mean this actually works
Knight G5 King back Queen captures night
Queen takes Knight takes E5 is Queen H5
I think Maxine green F6
um
evenish I don't know
right so I'm not check mating but it
looks like white is
well you're doing something dangerous is
it because
maybe not Queen H5 maybe G3 but yes if
you have to go Queen G3 then at least
you're not checkmating yeah yes I
completely relief right story yes
but it's like you can keep that move in
your pocket Bishop takes H7 check isn't
necessarily going away is it can I can I
not begin with Queen E2
but that doesn't really change anything
right English page seven is not a threat
not that I'm thinking about it what
about if I play Knight G5
you have to take no I have to I have to
defend my night and chat
[Laughter]
yeah I thought f8 as well okay and then
I wanted to put the question to the
night
um May I just just let's pursue this a
move or two you're gonna have to go back
I'm assuming I'm assuming Knight takes
F2 is not a good idea let's try it out
why not so if I take
queen of six
Knight D4 so they are stopping me then
forever I think we have to take that all
right so Bishop captures Rook oops
excuse me uh immediately right and King
takes so I've got two pieces let's try
to catch that trap that Bishop on H7
somehow uh How does it go Jesus accept
me if you can or is that catch me if you
can
uh
G6
wow you guys are really asking for you
do have you're asking for tricky ideas
big trouble right yes you do have some
trick here
[Music]
so what if we start with check queen of
six
my king
at the moment I have two pieces
for the rook and the bishop on C8 is
just yeah do something a little bit
different because this is actually a
huge game for for for our senior section
Knight G5 now obviously it's a dual
threat right I want to take the Knight I
want to take the pawn
and there and that's why this game is so
important whoever wins this game is
going to maintain at least a one point
advantage and if vladimiricopian and
Gregory kainana do not win it will be a
point and a half Advantage which we seem
to be huge very solid now you do have
this crazy move F5 F5 does two things it
stops me from playing uh Queen takes G4
and it stops me from taking on H7
if I take on H7 which is a kind of a
cheeky move you could turn the tables on
and you're the one maybe
you'd have to and everything else so
maybe F5 on the song Knight takes F6 and
why did I play Knight G5 I don't know
and it feels like black is happening to
proceed E55 yeah exactly exactly very
intriguing game going on here but uh let
me take a pause and turn it over to you
Christian as we have a special guest in
studio everybody you came here uh you
looked disappointed this is the second
time it happens your opponent comes with
just absolutely incredible preparation
and takes uh the game all the way until
the end like what are your feelings
right now yeah I need to stop playing
such forcing lines this line I've even
the final position I remember I can do
some moves I can try but I wasn't able
to remember all the details and like
this kind of position where you're down
a queen like I was worried that okay I
might end up in like some slightly worse
like at some point uh in my analysis
like black plays A5 apparently white
goes A4 yeah at the right moment if that
goes Queen E8 at like during the game I
was worried that maybe I might get into
some slightly uncomfortable positions
but of course it's
but yeah I was able to remember all the
details of otherwise I would have played
and it's just very very difficult to
make any progress at that point yeah it
goes Queen B8 and just stays like this
you stay like that and there's not much
progress for either side yes at least my
game with Brandon like even though he
was prepared all the way it's
the fact that he was playing all those
moves instantly was actually making me
feel better as I was playing all the top
engine moves even that kind of position
because I remember like after I went
back and checked there was a game
between uh
Newton newy and Thai Thai Dai Van versus
uh yeah yeah and he didn't find E6
Bishop for so it kind of made it made me
feel better that okay I'm able to find
such such good resources so that gave
you some confidence in your play I mean
you showed it yesterday in that critical
moment uh you could repeat the moves
with only a few seconds on the clock and
you chose to go Rook to E8 get out of
repetition and that actually
incentivized the mistake from Andrew uh
how did you come up to with that
solution in that particular Moment In
the Heat of the battle Yeah that game
was very interesting for the the first
move itself was a very very big decision
to make whether I stick with my knight
off or I prepare something altogether
different and I decided that okay my
game with Brandon ended like three hours
four hours early so I decided that okay
we have I have a lot of time I decided
to prepare French from the black side so
that because I knew that Andrew is a
very good dietitian so I decided to take
him out of his comfort zone and get a
game so you prepared a new opening in
like a day yeah yeah sir how many months
did you have to prepare your openings
for before you actually played them
months years
a day get out of here
how about we prepare the French coach
yeah let's do that
difficult rounds definitely you would
have liked to get more with white pieces
but you definitely get some positive
energy from yesterday game as well and
you're still in the league most likely
depending on what the other results are
yeah yes for this game it was very it
was very interesting I said like around
this point where you went Knight F7 I I
felt that I should be better but it
turns out whenever I played is the best
solution and if I don't like I felt
during the game that like when we both
got down the last 30 seconds I started
playing terrible moves but it turns out
like whatever I did if I don't do those
things engine already says like plus two
plus three it's very it's a very sharp
position and it turns out I did I played
well definitely playing well so far I'll
be money congratulations thank you we'll
see you in a couple of days after the
rest day thank you Mishra I have a
question for you if you don't mind first
of all a comment uh thank you yesterday
very very much I think it was inspiring
what you did courageously playing for
the win and issuing the repetition but I
wanted to ask you about your preparation
because it seems to me that you're
putting an enormous amount of study into
your opening play is that what is
required for you to get to the 2700
class that you're improving your
openings
getting to 2700 is a very difficult task
it consists of a lot of other things
other than openings if you get good
positions you need to convert you need
to convert them and yeah mostly mainly
I've been I've been trying to work on
all aspects of the game
but yeah my openings I I still need to
improve because as of now as
just about everyone has said I'm very
predictable
very predictable well they're not going
to say that about you too long if you
play new openings after one days of
preparation good luck in your campaign
enjoy your free day and we'll see you uh
you tell me the schedule all the time
but I got to think in terms of Friday
draw on that game let's just go to the
all Grandmaster matchup uh that's going
on between Balaji and Brandon Jacobson
because I find it intriguing that um
uh you know if you know your Classics 60
memorable games Bobby Fischer we all
grew up with Bobby Fischer Bobby
explained that when you have the central
pandu Duo against the rui Lopez the
place you put your dark squared Bishop
oh that's a quiz question yes is
um
I know B2 F4 F4 and uh well I don't I
think Balaji just got into that
conclusion himself by getting to the
position on the board uh but I thought
that was a very insightful comment by
Bobby and at first I didn't want to
believe him
it's like why would you put your Bishop
on B4 would you want to put it on a
secure Square E3 wouldn't as you're
you're kind of gut reaction was maybe
you should just be in Shadow reinforce
the green side beyond the diagonal right
but Bobby said no you put your Bishop on
that four and he goes on and explains it
in his six even World memorable games
and then it was only after my refusal to
believe he was right and to really
analyze it but I came to the conclusion
that he was right it was like yes Bobby
Fisher he is Bobby Fischer for a reason
Bishop F4 C7 C6 and we've caught up to
the player players White's enjoying uh
his spatial Advantage but in truth
um it's very hard to get at those
weaknesses and attacked upon on C6 the
pawn on D6 is aren't what you would call
Easy targets so they're only weak if you
can attack them and that's what's
branded saying is I'm going to play H7
H6 I'm going to drop back with my Bishop
in a kind of a philador
style you're not going to have an easy
time coming right and getting it proving
an advantage A4 is interestingly
position right it's like we can bring
the other Rook to attack the pawn on E5
but we thought it may be white wants to
be fighting in the center so not
necessarily kind of moving The Rook to
the E file exactly we'll keep our eye on
this as Christian I'm gonna throw it
over to you what caught your eye we
haven't looked at this game uh March
does game between Patrick Wolfe and Igor
novikov and a lot of interesting
transitions have happened in this one
take a look at this uh position Knight
takes E3 and of course the general
reaction would be to just simply take
back with the Knight right Knight takes
E3 you take take and you cannot take the
pawn on D4 because of Bishop to B5 so
that pawn is secure it looks like a
normal middle game position you can sure
give a check but then I will just simply
go King to eat when I will Castle
manually Castle I will go kingy two
queen Rook goes to D1 and then I will
hide my king to F1 we've seen that quite
a few times so it's a normal position
but he takes with the F Pawn F takes E3
cementing the presence of this Knight on
a D4 for the moment and then taking on
C6 Queen to F3 a lot of transitions I
really like how Patrick is taking uh is
using his resources in this one and now
Queen to E4 creating some more
weaknesses whenever we're going to see
F5 this is what I'm expecting once again
another transition and this is why I'm
talking about transitions this game is
all about it Queen to E5 let's go into
the end game by the end game I'm going
to make use of your weaknesses newly
created weaknesses the pawn on C6 as
well as the pawn on E6 and of course the
Pawn C8 is really struggling you
would look at this position you hear
that two Bishops in the end game with an
open Center well they're going to be
better than the Knight and the bishop
they're going to be an advantage not in
this case because you have too many
weaknesses and you have this bad
bishopon CA I really like what Patrick
is doing and I have a feeling he might
be on his way to getting his first
victory of this senior championships or
getting that first Victory is really
really sweet I'd like to turn our
attention in the game between Kelsey Lou
and Rue Yang Yang as uh this was that
night night off position with like crazy
things
and the players have reached this
position and white has played a move to
Tony miles likes to describe as
attacking the king to bed like you your
your King's on C1 you've castled long
and somehow there's always an issue that
maybe the queen could drop in on A1 so
you tuck your king over you get off the
C file but it wasn't any Sicilian you
like to move the king to B1 even away
from the C5 precisely and very important
is you prepare to jump with the Knight
so the night so you don't Queen takes D2
is not met with a check and I remember I
was I was kind of starting out 13 14
years old you know I'm on 1200 you know
getting that I think Class E they called
it you know I was very very proud
walking around and I had such a position
and I think I even had a rook on E1
showing my understanding bringing the
Rooks into the center and I played the
move Knight D5 and I really expected you
know somebody to come on you know tap me
on the shoulders say good job kid uh
because what I was trying to do and even
I think the bishop was undefended right
was uh playing uh
I was trying to be able to play Knight
takes F6 check and after G takes out and
then I was going to recapture the queen
and again my Rook was here so my Pawn
wasn't hanging
and my opponent played a move I just
didn't see him my jaw just kind of
dropped down if I don't play Bishop
defending the queen
never mind never mind just kidding just
kidding but that little Bishop d8 unless
you know it's shown to you you don't
right it's not a movie you always think
about just it depends and it was pretty
a pretty funny move an embarrassing
moment but Kelsey did not have such a
moment she went I did it to E2 uh
hitting the pawn on uh
uh D6 and I just wanted to say that
whenever you've got this this situation
where you've got this bishop over here I
do like these ideas very much I think
it's very much in White's interests even
at the cost of the pawn like if you
sacrifice upon on E5 I'll get the D5
Square you know I get some pressure so
we have this position between Kelsey and
ruyang 92 your first initial uh media
reaction did Black come out of the
opening okay I see black wanting to play
B5 right be very quickly to attack but
we do have to be careful about upon on
these things because that is a crucial
Pawn right so I understand your first
initial kind of reaction to quickly move
the biggest bag defense but that is the
whole point if you do play Bishop E7 and
you do play F5 and you do play B5 uh
right now we are fighting in the center
and on the side it's a it's it's
right but the two Bishops as Sicilian
are you a sicilian player yes I am yeah
I like two Bishops because they're
really fast on those diagonals
um I think black I mean black did not
Castle it so we may be not happy about
the king being the center but the center
the king in the center is very safe for
sure sometimes we are like King safety
is very important but what if kick in
Castle is actually not as safe as in the
center so you want to keep it there and
then just launch the attack exactly my
my first impression was that I like the
two Bishops I like the bishop on F6 even
I can sacrifice the pawn on D6 I've seen
Gary Kasparov play Such uh lines he's
one of the greatest Sicilian experts
there ever will be as far as I'm
concerned so I I like uh Rue Yang Yang's
position and I Rely tonight on C5 right
that's an excellent place now usually
it's on C6 where it's not doing that
much but here on C5 it's targeting the
bishop Dupont the other Pawn that is a
fantastic night exactly exactly uh
Christian what do you have for us uh in
the Juniors let's go back to the Juniors
back to one of the leaders the
co-leaders going into this round arturgo
who is on a roll so far hat-trick in the
last three rounds just an incredible
performance so far and I think we left
it some around here after taking on D5
and we were wondering how Josiah is
going to retake what he actually started
with Bishop takes D3 first and we will
understand in just a second why he
really wants to take back with the c
Pawn C takes D5 in this position Queen
to A4 this is the problem man white has
to do something and he has to do it fast
because if Black Goes Bishop E7 and
Castle somehow of course after spending
the Knight on D7 and black is going to
be perfectly fine very beautiful compact
structure for black so there's some
strategical pitfalls that white could
fall into if he doesn't stop white from
Black from finishing his development
this Pawn on D3 is not going to be that
good in the end game so let's see what
he did Rook ac1 Bishop to D6 you have to
stop any sort of Bishop C7 or Rook to C7
is a big problem as well so you cannot
do this Rook take Rook 2 C7 would in
fact more or less finish the game at
this point so you have to stop that
Bishop B6 I really like what he's doing
so far Rook to C6 putting a lot of
pressure again there's some urgency in
his moves right yeah and if you allow me
to go Castle black is fine right and
this is a big move right now big
decision for Josiah but he found the
right move Queen to B8
you have to keep control of the C7
Square you're going to give something in
return and that is control over the a3fa
diagonal which will allow as we will see
just a second after Queen to B8 for
white to go Queen to A3 and stop at
least momentarily the black king from
going Castle so this is a big moment
right now Josiah needs to find the move
A5
and this is the big plan A5 followed by
Queen to B4 very basic you just want to
get the king to Castle if you manage to
do that you're fine once again so A5 big
move if he finds it black is more or
less fine if it doesn't then his
borderline losing right so this is a
critical moment for Josiah for this
reason in fact instead of Queen 283 a
very interesting idea would have been to
go Rook to A6 first
but you have to think about it you have
to deconstruct the whole uh position
Rook to A6 then the queen is going to
defend most likely the Knight on D7
getting ready to Castle and now I go
Queen to A3 you no longer have the move
A5 right no more A5 so unfortunately you
cannot set up black that is this A5
Queen to B4 stopping the action of the
queen on this diagonal so now it's more
difficult to get the castle going you
have to find some really precise moves
to not be completely losing Knight to B8
being one of them this is the start
it's difficult again if you move the
Rook you lose the pawn on A7 right yeah
so you have to do something this is not
easy I think this would have created a
lot of problems for at least for from an
objective point of view but also from a
practical point of view for Josiah right
now Queen A3 A5 more or less frees up
Black's position and I think uh he would
be perfectly fine if he finds that
thank you Christian I'd like to look at
some Marquee matchups the first one I
just want to stay with the uh girls for
a moment it's the game between Rochelle
and Alice this was that Knight C6 the
night to B4 we thought that Alice had
done quite well and had equalized the
game Queen C3 Rook C8 castles Rook E7
there was a trade of queens and I found
that decision a little bit perplexing I
if I was in black shoes back here after
Queen C3 I'd probably want to keep the
Queens on the board I want to play C6
with the idea that as soon as White
Castles to go Rook to E8 and queen to H6
and start to Menace you know sacrifice
H3 that's it that's it but once the
Queens came off I think it's a really
equal game and for Alice uh a draw with
black against a key rival keeping
Rochelle down and a point behind her is
something that she's going to want I'm
turning our attention to our
seniors we've got Gregory kaidana versus
Joe Benjamin and we left it I was trying
to go Knight G5 and it happened on F7
Gregory listen to you well
a little bit softer you know it might
hear us across the street uh H5 H4 H5
and Joel basically said okay I'll give
you the G5 square but I'll get the F5
Square you can't play G4 Bobby Fischer
famously said to get to get squares you
got to give them and uh White's got a
nice Square for his night Black's got a
nice Square for his night as well 94 to
Target the Knight on F5 and then the
move G7 G6 uh this position for to my
eyes is what I try to avoid when I'm
black in a French defense because I'm
looking at night takes and I'm assuming
you're going to take like this I don't
know or if you want to take the other
way the light squared Bishop right
remember what it's all about I'm going
to Castle I'm going to play Bishop B4
I'm going to challenge the C file your H
Pawn looks miserable
if you capture the other way which
probably you're obliged to do and
it really struck me I don't know where
you got this but I got it from Michael
budvin he was annotating one of his
games and he explained in one of his
games that uh I was really young and
Bishops of opposite colors
oh it's an easy draw Bishops of opposite
colors and he said no the player who
whose King is the most vulnerable is in
big trouble like you're dead meat and in
this case Black's King is the most
vulnerable right and the fact that this
bishop is raking this diagonal keeps
your king in the center this is right
over I mean I was always taught that you
know when you are attacking their
opposite colored Bishops you have an
extra piece exactly right no one is
going to be targeting those dark squares
because they just you don't have an
opponent there yeah exactly so it looks
to me like Joe has misplayed his opening
because in the current position and I'm
thinking oh by the way he did Castle uh
I like messing I like messing up my
opponent's Pawn structure I'm a pond
grubber so you gotta weaken the
structure but Knight take I like Knight
takes F5 Gregory has played castles Joel
is is borderline busted right bastard
right right it's just a it's a bad
position for black not looking great no
exactly okay now by the way sorry
Christian because now I'm kind of
stopping the trade of Bishop before in
the future right by targeting the Knight
takes uh take with the what do you take
yeah exactly this is the problem if you
take back with the Jeep on and if I ever
play Queen of three you're not castling
right so if you take like this I'm just
I'm not worried about the B2 Pawn you
hear what I just said I can't believe
let me slap myself I'm not worried about
the it's about the the play on the C
file right let's let's be more
aggressive yes E6 E6 let's go yes let's
do it that's the other thing I can play
it just feels like yeah Bishop C3 Knight
H7 once you go that King is staying in
the center and it's not going to get
better anytime soon right and if I
capture a Jeep on I know that the H5 is
weak but yeah that's the problem
I
no I don't know I might keep the Rook on
A1 because it might be useful in the
near future we'll say Bishop C5 Bishop
whoa oh are you gonna
do that uh Bishop C5 I want to put it on
D4
uh Yasser smells sometimes
something uh is gone wrong here uh
Bishop why not B4 why don't you want to
go B4 yeah no B4 is very good move I
like before
all right okay yeah this is very
uncomfortable for black well just the
pieces are not coordinated the king is
okay the king can be weak in the center
yeah but the other thing too uh okay
once we trade the Bishops I'm taking
away your plus which was you had the two
Bishops the Gosh Look What remains on
the board septilicus
um let's just uh Jump Around the seniors
games for just a moment because there's
our Marquee match up between malixet and
Max and guess what we did see the bishop
sacrifice although truth be told it's
not really a sacrifice because we're
getting the night the minor piece back
right away I think Willis and Christians
saying Queen H4 instead of Queen H5
anyway they have reached this position
intriguing imbalance but don't play
Knight you soon
don't get tempted there's a nasty trick
right check and I go Bishop don't block
with the Knight because that's made in
one and you have to block with the rook
and then you're not happy I'm going to
be an exchange up as soon as I defend
the night like something like this one
yeah you can wait with Captain but don't
play Knight G6 highly desired as it
might be
um no that's that's the big one that's
the big game right there
in the senior section how are you going
to stop I know I'm sorry but I'm just
having a
a brains a brain spasm here how am I so
I can play Knight C4 right
okay thank you that does defend this boy
you know sometimes you like you don't
see it right and you do want to play E5
which is good and you can even agree to
a slightly damaged Pawn structure yeah
but once I get E5 I'm very happy from C8
is released
uh the two Bishops and a three result
game Let's Just Jump Around the Horn I
want to go fishing after Knight C4 oops
sorry can we just stick with that one
for once before sure continue this one
Knight D2 and again you have to look at
this D6 square right you don't have time
to take that's right that's the key I
really want to trade Queens I want to go
uh and I really want to avoid
oh your knight gets out on C7 sorry
you can go uh my intention was that
after Knight C4 that I get a Tempo but
you get the tempo right back and your
night does get out on C7
I mean even if it doesn't but even yeah
okay count I gotta learn to count so
Queen F6 Knight C4 Knight D2 right so I
then I guess I'm back to E5 after all
yeah and I take C4 Knight takes C4 takes
on C4 it should be three I I'm trying to
pretend that I'm not concerned I mean
what are you are you concerned I'm a
little concerned actually me too right
so Bishop to E3 inviting come on trade
sorry let's try it for want you to trade
on E3 no no no no I oh C4 no
G5 is hanging so you you don't get to
take on C4 ha ha ha
yeah very complex position right didn't
you have just rookie one instead of
Bishop E3 that's some tactics yes
I like the way you're thinking
but but I don't I've now guarded the the
key Square H7 you're not invading
anymore
and maybe the bishop will anchor by the
way we have Queen H6 on the board uh Let
me refresh and what did you say 0.86
queen H6 yeah
there was something about this move that
also attracted my eye uh in this case
I'm giving up I'm not sure I like this
though uh okay I I'm I'm I'm literally
one move away from winning as white if I
could play the move F2 F4 here I I think
black's King is toast so to play F4 I
have to
and this is what Bob thenick was talking
about this is what you were talking
about your piece up when you're
attacking when you've got Bishops of
opposite colors like something you
should create
and oh Bishop d8 thank you you most
certainly do
I mean you're just in time
oh oh I was so close to playing F4 and
getting a full grip Bishop f8 ow
okay you're off the you're you're off
the Thanksgiving dinner list
nice move yeah I I like it Bishop d8
um what do you have first Christian
let's stay within the senior section
sure just a second because a big blunder
just occurred in this game between
Douglas root and guravich and take a
look at this Knight to G6
get the Queen off the C file right you
see this Rook on CA there's some Knight
D4 lingering summer right right take a
look at this he plays 95. allowing
Knight to D4
just simply gives black a tremendous
Advantage right oh no the blunder is the
Palm not only the pawn the pawn the
center the two Bishops so I this is not
actually not the two Bishops but yeah
upon on the center that's enough right
enough or objectively winning Advantage
Queen D1 Knight takes F3 Knight takes F3
E5
this one is just play on one goal this
actually is close to being over because
Bishop D3 is not coming because of E4 E4
F5 I have so many ways in which I can
continue this position that this one is
looking really rough for uh Douglas and
I have to say yesterday what a golden
opportunity he had uh in that game
against Joel Benjamin Knight C2 that was
winning in one move I'm sure he saw that
and he probably uh bit himself
um before he went to sleep last night
it's tough to recover from those moments
because you know you were just winning
one move away from winning right an
important game against such a tremendous
player it's difficult to come back from
those and it's going to be even more
difficult to come back from this
particular blunder allowing I to D4
that's rough yeah how do you overcome
that because you know we've all
blundered really badly and you you sit
there go gosh how could I do this I'm
such an idiot yeah you got to forgive
yourself we just go with it how do you
do that I mean it's very difficult I was
really looking forward to listen to
Carissa Steve she was saying
right kids falling down no I I don't do
that but I just try to take my mind off
so I maybe read a book do something but
then I come back to that situation I
think I give myself some time to like
really feel sorry for myself really
understand what's been happening and
then I'm like okay that's it no more
times left we need to move on uh there
are other games to be played to
determine still continues and I have to
get my mind straight exactly yeah to get
that correct mindset though that's
that's tough uh let's just jump around
and go to the girl section and just once
again I'm going to check in on Alice
Leighton nothing has happened how about
the next nearest competitor let's jump
to Carissa's game against Gracie
yeah
don't be gusta I don't like this for uh
Carissa when we left it I had explained
that with the move Knight C4 back in
these in this moment that the move D5 is
frowned upon premature that black is
fully equalized after the the move
Knight C4 and let's see what has
happened since so C4 makes sense right
Bishop B2 Bishop D7 Knight F1
93 G6 by the way Gracie's doing all the
right things as well right I mean uh she
looks like she's going to Pieces yeah
she looks like she's been playing the
classical rui you know her whole career
and by the way the inclusion of the move
G6 defending uh the F5 Square inclusion
of Knight H5 this is beautiful play by
black I'm not so pleased with Carissa's
play by the way I mean after all what is
their dark swear Bishop doing the Knight
comes
this is inviting even H5 and you know
you're not going anywhere but forward
even dropping in on the D3 Square so you
can open up the C file looks very uh
promising I want to say for for uh
Gracie H5 here we go wow
that's it I want to say first
impressions are it's a little modest a
bit okay nothing wrong with modesty uh
Brooks belong on open files everybody
Rook could be one Bishop Essex king a
king G1 indication that Charissa is not
a happy camper either King G1 and
the night is on H2 the king is on H1
black is clearly for Choice Carissa
Carissa's Karissa is struggling yeah I'm
wondering what is King H move King H1
movies so like I think she's prepping
something like H4 and G3
she doesn't know what what to do
basically right she doesn't have a clear
plan so she just is trying to improve
her position potentially maybe get away
from Bishop takes H3 sacrifices things
of that nature make her King safer for
the future but at the same time it just
shows and signals a clear
misunderstanding of the position but
also a clear uh misunderstanding of what
to do next he has no idea what to do
next because there's no good planets in
the position and as you mentioned put
the Rook on the open file exactly yeah I
like this movement not committing to any
plans right I'm just developing a piece
right but that's what strategic play is
all about is you look around the board
and you ask everybody how they're
feeling and one thing that's good for
your resize her time management
she's got plenty of time on the clock
plenty of time and Gracie only with 30
something minutes on her clock compared
to one hour for Carissa and we see
Bishop G7 on the board yeah again this
is a
kind of a modest move
um for my taste you know I asked the
bishop on F6 how are you doing the
bishop says I'm perfectly fine
I go okay how about the night okay the
bishop on the okay so for me you know
the Rook says well I could really be
improved I'm not 100 sure like if you
take this for for argument's sake if I
go Rook B8 and you take my knight I'm
not 100 sure I'd rather be on G7 maybe
I'd rather be on E5 maybe I'd rather be
on C3 but my Rook
is really a hero he's saying I
definitely want to be on ba so Bishop
G27 is impressed maybe you know clearing
the diagonal for Queen maybe she's
thinking I may want to go Queen H4 okay
uh for me if I'm in white shoes I start
to look around and I say well what
pieces need to be improved on white side
of the board well I'd rather have my
Bishop on E3 I'd rather have my Rook on
B1 P6 maybe on a really really good day
I'd rather have my Pawn on A5 but for me
it's not easy for white uh to
to find the right squares this Knight on
H2 also makes
really bad impression so yes if we move
back so let's say you get your Bishop
yes here no not that back not that far
uh Still Still H5 Knight H2
and now you are not happy about Bishop
F6 so you play Rook B8 right no I'm okay
with Bishop F6 uh I was a little bit uh
unhappy about Bishop G7 I was thinking
that I would play Rook B8 yes and if I
go let's say Bishop E3 and I'm thinking
I want to drop in yeah say hello
and drop in here too
maybe
apologies maybe Queen A5 just to tag
and only now drop in just a tag
right because this is what I thought
it's interesting it looks like black is
attacking the king side but actually
black is very happy to also you know
play on The Queen side I agree I agree
and
because her pieces are more active The
Rook on V8 the Knight on F4 uh blacks
play on both sides of the board come
naturally by the way Carissa is really
struggling in this I want to say the
first half even there's no such thing as
a halfway point because you've got nine
rounds but I want to say that yesterday
really a bad position and their opponent
allowed her a three-time repetition
twice twice Rochelle also has been
struggling even though both Carissa and
Rochelle have decent scores it's not a
reflective of their play and this this
game Chris is not going to be proud of
uh Christian what's called your eye well
one player that doesn't seem to be
struggling is Zoe tang and also in this
game she's really taking the bull by the
horns ah take a look at this position
you have a lot of ways in which you can
continue the attack and we've been
discussing this idea of going E5 and
just simply taking space on the king
side that's exactly what she's doing
there is no counter play being created
by Rose on the queen side she's trying
C5 that's not going to lead to anything
if you take on D4 in fact that's going
to help me because I take back with the
Knight centralize my knight get another
piece towards the attack and I don't
have any structural problems in the
position so I really like this last move
Knight to G4 you're getting ready for
things of this nature Knight to H6 maybe
Queen to H6 yeah Knight to F4 right I'm
starting to look around your dark
squares around your king there are some
checkmates brewing in the position right
yeah if you try to go Knight H7 very
often you will have to deal with ideas
of E6 softening up the pawn on G6 right
maybe after Queen to H6 and Knight to F4
but she found the plan this is the key
in this position she found the plan with
the white pieces Knight G4 Queen H6
maybe you can even drop back with the
Knight and then push F4 F5 you have a
plan
what's Black's plan in this position I I
simply don't see it I see ways in which
you can try to defend but not much more
than that and objectively right now
white is cruising a decisive advantage
and Zoe Tang is headed towards a nice
bounce back and an important bounce back
Victory and Zoe is also enjoying time
Advantage 96 Prime Advantage yes
again you can continue with Queen H6 you
can go F4 now right F4 F5 backs to be
played right it's just uh it's a very
sad position for black I have to say
okay just a
reprimand there for Rose
when your opponent's clock is ticking
the rule is hands to yourself you don't
you don't have the right to to touch the
pieces because your opponent's thinking
uh make you do make I adjust when your
clock is ticking when my clock is
ticking don't go around adjusting all
the pieces and keeping your hands on the
board it's my clock that's ticking so
just a little etiquette there don't do
that uh I I hate I hate Joel Benjamin's
position Gregory did do what we
suggested which he did capture on F5
messed up Joel's structure and Gregory
is just thinking would I like to play
beef four
and followed up with A5 and just improve
my Bishop which I just uh am I am I
comfortable sacrificing the pawn on B2
should I just play Rook C1
um it really is a very very nice
position for Gregory checking in on uh
Max that was an interesting move here so
you were thinking about like Knight D4
right maybe this bishop d8 move yes and
Malik immediately went Bishop F6 which
makes a lot of sense in the face of ship
to d8 right now Max uh interestingly
enough he went uh with the immediate G4
here because he could have played your
move Bishop d8 giving up the two Bishops
but then hoping to play F6 in a certain
moment but after G4 where
yes we have caught up with the players
um
for for me if I could just I want I so
desperately want to play F3 and bring a
rook to
uh a Rover and then I can check me so
from Black's point of view this bishop
is too strong black would love to get
rid of the bishop either King H7 or E5
and Rook E6 those are his options right
so from White's point of view let's say
I play the move Knight D4 so a dream
position
right so you've got to do so you got to
be quick too right you can't you can't
dilly dally uh I'm going to play Rook A1
to E1 and F3 and he asked her what if
you instead of an id4 go immediately
Rook 8u1 because I can transfer the Rook
through E5 right also so I've got to get
rid of this guy
can I can I get rid of the guy if I can
then Max will be fine then he'll he'll
repair his position with the moves F6
and E5 and maybe he'd even be fighting
for
more than equality right so now I bring
the Knight 94 is that our difference do
you prefer tonight to go there first
well that's the whole point I now my
Bishop has to move but I was trying to
do
with the move Knight D4 was play F3
right so so like for example this would
be a dream
yay
but more importantly I've maintained the
bishop and when you play the move E5 I
am well first of all I can't move the
knight uh important point but I was
going to use uh the uh pin with the move
rookie one uh
it's it's a very by the way Rook A1 E1
on the board uh
sorry uh Bishop F6 G4 Rook he didn't
play Knight D4 he played Rook 81 is on
the board
he's dreaming
so maybe the key move here King H7 just
to really go after that Bishop kick it
away as fast as possible then maybe play
for F6 E5 do I does black have a choice
though even I mean if you don't like if
you play a move like Bishop D7 I think
uh White is is threatening to win the
game on the spot right and if I go
Bishop d8
ah Bishop D7 rookie five Bishop d8 yeah
but then the whole thing is why did you
play G5 right before if you were going
to play Bishop D well maybe in this case
you would be taking I'm thinking Max is
in serious serious serious trouble here
but the next move or two will decide
King H7 by the way on the board and such
a huge game for the senior Championship
as both these players uh have a point
lead three and a half uh out of four and
as we prepare for a break let's get in
our celebration reminder tomorrow
everybody is a free day and during the
free day we're going to be celebrating
the 15th anniversary of the club right
we will have ice cream we will have duck
chairs we will have book signing a
things happening
stand so if you are nearby feel free to
you know come and visit the chess club
and see also all the players because a
lot of them may be here they will have a
rest day so they'll be happy to just
chill and enjoy chess atmosphere
absolutely maybe we'll hang out and play
some dog house too I mean uh yeah get
some bug chess going that would be very
nice and we're going to see you on the
other side of the break
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to Saint Louis it's lovely
to see you here thank you uh I checked
video and your rating is 26 12.
currently and you were of course over
2700 at some point how do you keep such
a high level
I used to keep a higher level more
harder than that
okay I don't know I used to play on
higher level of course yeah and this was
but also that time I mean I I did a lot
of work edges I was working on
everything on chess openings now also
sometimes but somehow whenever you're
over 50 it's already more difficult yeah
you have some other goals in in your
life and episode that it's not like I
would not say that I don't even know
that this is only 12 told the truth I
didn't know that's such a low oh I'm
sorry for me it's still a very high
rating and what are you what are your
goals you mentioned that after 50 you
have different goals can you no you just
note that like you already enjoy your
life you don't spend that much time on
chess
and you already normally if you are like
something like this you all lose all
those you lose motivation actually when
I was young I remember that just you
should play and you should win and you
make everything for that uh
both preparing and during the game and
now I see you lose yeah this like side
this this part of but still yeah still
of course I mean nobody likes losing so
if we come here we try to do our best
it's clear but of course something
something is lost
it's completely different whenever
you're young it's a 20 or something like
this
okay so this tournament is kind of new
for you did you make any particular
preparation for it or you try to work as
you would work before mostly physical
preparation
because
yeah it's already difficult again
because of of your age
just mostly this some chess some chess
but not more yeah again whenever you are
young you can actually skip that because
you are you are fit normally
but now it's already some some some some
problems they already uh and so yeah
physically yeah I did I mean going to
gym and making some exercises everything
like this chest like already like um
some seconds you already have it right
yeah Alexander shavalov also mentioned
and then actually he send us a video
saying that he's focusing on on physical
progression more than chess and probably
this is the one thing we can see who's
gonna handle better I guess and how how
are you feeling about the tournament in
general about your opponents
U.S very interesting a great tournament
again this was a very pleasant
experience last year I mean I knew that
there is such a tournament but uh I mean
you should be 50 yet to take part here
so that was great last year and of
course this year I expect also
um I mean very very good opposition of
course it's it's it's not easy I mean
it's not easy it's it's very tough and
last year it was also very tough and
this playoff with fifth actually five
players we played the playoff was very
tense actually this year they changed
this because last year I remember after
the immediately after the last round I
was just totally exhausted and playing
this playoff after that was very
difficult but now I see that this year
they changed everything and this is of
course great you can have rest after
that and on the next day you play
playoff
so they're always improving and of
course
this is this is great of course this is
Eric glad to hear that and good luck
with the tournament thank you very much
[Music]
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as high
profile tournaments that attract the
world's best players become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why just as
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the games the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
hello I'm women's Grandmaster William
Tucker jonova I will be doing social
media for the US Juniors and seniors
chess championships follow us in our
social media and get more exciting
behind the scenes action
foreign
chess club is the Premier chess facility
in the United States and is among the
best in the world thanks to co-founders
Dr Jeannie Karen singfield and Rex
sinkfield the St Louis chess club is a
non-profit organization committed to
promoting the game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American cop as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions and our Galleries and sign
up for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
thank you
hello and welcome back to our live
coverage of the national championships
these are results in the Juniors thus
far Cape right round five we have one
result Mishra against Liang they made a
really amazing draw very deep
preparation
remarkable remarkable stuff I draw in
that game and in the uh girls what are
the standings so the girls we have a
soul leader Alice Lee with three and a
half points out of four and then we have
a three-way tie for the second place
Karissa Rochelle and Zoe tang with twin
heart points and in the city and as soon
as so we have a big matchup today with
the two leaders who are tied for the
first place Maxine blogie Malik said
Katya with three and half points
fighting each other today and then there
is a two-way tie for the third place
vladimira kopia and Gregory kaidanov
with two and a half points and jumping
into the games I just want to say that
the game between Rochelle and Alice a
key game for our standings again Alice
is coming in uh with a with a point lead
over Rochelle she looks like she's
comfortably drawing I would expect that
this game to end in some kind of a
repetition in the near future Carissa
hopefully correctly claimed and
correctly claimed indeed as uh uh you
just play C7 C6 uh bringing the king
into the center of this one weakness but
these Rook endings notoriously drawn
Carissa though in our game with Gracie
we didn't like what Carissa has has done
and we think that Gracie is the one
who's really enjoying herself let's just
continue our Just
Around the Horn when we left it remember
this game this was this night we were
wondering should black drop back with a
bishop
counter-attack the E4 Pawn wow long
castle
that is something unexpected but truly
it's another way to you know defend upon
on D6 exactly Queen takes D6 Bishop
takes A4 on ruian's agenda after castles
H4 not the most obvious move Queen B4 in
the immortal words of Nikolai minneap
gift me your Pawn
nothing not impressed I like Black's
position I think she she's got whenever
I see these open Sicilian positions as
black where you've got Bishops on C6 and
Bishop on the F6 give yourself credit
you've done something right and blood is
targeting point on e4 ready to capture
it also targeting A4 maybe not capturing
that pawn right now right but who knows
you know what the future brings exactly
I think black species are really well
positioned me too me too uh Iris uh
let's jump over to that game you had an
important win yesterday uh game I
haven't been able to fully decipher
what's going on I like the imbalances I
I believe the imbalances are favorable
to Black uh first first take is you know
you play Bishop G5 Bishop H right F5 F4
and you get it going it's not so easy
for white yes you can play C4 and C5 but
you're not really going to go D7 DC
anytime soon it just looks like that's a
nice position for for black I'm going to
go quickly just around to Zoe and Rose
before tossing it over to uh Christian
but Zoe's position for some time I
really really love her position she's
looking like she's about to break
through F5
f45 Knight C3 takes D5 the F6 square is
weak once I play F5 and I land Queen F6
I mean F5 that's gonna be a killer move
yeah it's Splat I I I don't like Rose's
position at all and that takes care of
our girls Championship what do you have
for us uh Christian let's take a look at
what's happening in the Juniors section
as well this one is a big game the one
between uh abalaji dakupati and Brandon
Jacobson and we were kind of uh looking
at the deposition and trying to
understand what's happening there is a
lot of strategical maneuvering going on
in the position take a look at this Rook
A1 Bishop to f8
both of these players are trying to find
the ideal squares for their pieces maybe
at some point with this bishopone f8
maybe I will have ideas of G6 and Bishop
to G7 but for the moment I have to pay
attention to the weakness of the Pawn on
D6 and this is exactly why and you are
mentioning this as well yes or this uh
Bishop has to be on F4 that's the ideal
Square for the bishop H6 Rook to E3 I
generally like this type of moves uh the
swing of The Rook uh on the third rank
potentially on G3 maybe even on A3 if I
go something like Knight A4 Rook to A3
things of that nature and now he played
the move D5 finally a big decision in
the works day five E5 and C5 you cannot
allow me to stop you with a move Knight
to A4 you have to do things fast because
otherwise you're going to be in trouble
strategically so he understands that
Brandon Jacobson that is he plays the
move C5 and D takes C5 it's a very
complex battle between these two grand
Masters going on right now still very
balanced nevertheless I mean you know
how this type of Rory Lopez positions
can go they can simplify very quickly
but also if you make a mistake you can
be much much worse strategically very
very quickly so both sides are risking
at this moment a lot of imbalance let's
see what the next few moves will bring
let's take a look at what's happening in
the Kirk gazarian versus Justin Wang
position this one has simplified a big
opportunity lost by gazerian when he's
going to see that I'm I mean he's not
going to like it we know how ambitious
this young man is he's going to see
maybe he's going to see also that Vision
none missed it as well and then he's
going to feel better about his own Miss
but I have to say that was a golden
opportunity Knight takes C7 Knight to E5
pretty much game over at that point if
you find those moves it's just a
conversion uh discussion and he would
have converted that Artur gu versus
Josiah Sturman well the king is safe so
this is big we know that this is big
he's been trying to get the king to
safety for a very long time Josiah that
is let's see how that happened A5 the
move that we prescribed Queen to C3
Castle Rook to C1 Knight to E5 it's all
about the way the structure looks for
back black is very Compact and that's
going to help his case moving forward a
for Queen to D4 Knight to G6 and Knight
to F3 this is what we have right now
still very balanced but I have to say
due to the fact that you have a weakness
at least to Maya is on B2 he played the
move Queen to F4 I like this move
it's asking a very serious question do
you take on F4 I don't think you want to
take on F4 if you take on F4 I take on
F4 no that one is hanging check 92 is
hanging the only way to deal with that
is something along the lines of Rook to
D1 but now Rook C8 Rook B8 I'm taking
over yeah
this is not looking good so Queen to F4
is a good move he's also putting a lot
of pressure on the clock right now 42
minutes for Josiah 22 minutes for Arthur
and a lot of moves still to go 18 moves
to go so definitely Josiah is feeling
good looking good in at this position
Arthur
um simplified position doesn't have that
many resources I have to say he's going
to try to find a way to pull the brakes
right now and find equality with the
white pieces in the position because
right now he's on the back foot
absolutely uh let's just jump to the
senior section kind of go around the
playing Hall see what's happening with
the seniors Doug root blundered he
blundered badly some time ago he dropped
his D4 Pawn due to a pin along the C
file and Dimitri's just cruising he's
just got a huge Advantage extra Pawn up
in this Center is just overwhelming so
Dimitri's doing great I like Patrick
Wolff's position against Igor Novak
just improving uh everything and the
problem for black is these Bishops
they're just not
wait a minute hold on
I'm just wondering if the queen no the
Queen the queen it was trapped yeah
exactly across the board it was like if
I could get in just one move H4 and then
play B4 uh things could be very very fun
but it sure looks like a move you would
like to make right to Target The Pawn on
G6 to open up your H file so even if we
are not trapping the queen yeah it's a
very useful move exactly I like
Patrick's position Gregory kaidanov I
just think has a a really by the way
huge Advantage for Gregory sorry staying
with that position for a second Patrick
peeked at the engine for a second sure
B4 is in fact winning for white it's the
best move in the position winning
because after Queen G5
let's try to figure it out I would
assume Quincy seven
Queen C7 why not and now the bishop is
hanging so we are threatening I think H4
is a big threat but we kind of made a
commitment there didn't we we made a
weakness when we played before dead we
did do we have something even more
maybe bishop E4 what about that move
even H4
H4 was the move play
instead of B4 which is the second best
move no I was thinking like B4 Queen G5
H4 and just looking at the resulting
position I mean position this looks so
pretty for white I know Bishop to E4
Knight to E5 is kind of taking over yeah
he played H4 good move and I'm I'm
thinking B4 is just a killer threat I
have no choice I have to play Bishop A6
right
I mean everything else it just looks
awful and I am assuming that we want to
play Knight E5 today D6
what what what
making a pin just a second what what
what
you know earlier in the tournament
with Elan Patrick had just sacrificed a
piece Bishop takes H6 against chivalov
and just went and lost the game but he
did it in a very smooth fashion now when
you when you played the move Knight E5
very smoothly you know it's all a part
of you know like
just the way we had intended to
Checkmate our opponents no I have missed
Bishop D6 of course no but I mean it
actually could be the case by the way we
have a result this was looking for an
Arbiter to confirm a repetition
threefold repetition most likely uh we
think Patrick Wolf is doing very well we
think Gregory kaidanov is doing very
well shabbalah has a very nice two
Bishops as well look at those nights
yeah as well as isolated Queen Pond but
yeah look at the dynamic compensation
this Knight on C4 night on e4
our as a chess commentary dictator
dynamically balanced right in some Rook
A3 coming hello you know I've got make
sure your queen has space yeah I've got
activity for for it does uh Vladimir all
right how do you do it though so how how
do you stop that and all the other
threats because I have a feeling
I don't know their Rook on D4 doesn't
feel very comfortable it's not a comfy
Rook maybe you have to cement it with E3
but
that's not not not the square that I
really want to cement it with right I'd
much rather have my knight on
um on D4 so let's say I go back
so let's say you go A3 let's say I go
back I know I'm playing Fisher random
I'm Shuffling the pieces but for the
moment
I I'd much rather have my knight on D4
than uh
my uh rook and so I have some some
tactics right oh do you like B2
Knight B2 oh who invited you to the
party Knight B2 my goodness what a move
oh
Knight B2 I apologize that that's a
strong move well it's funny because it's
just one of those moves that you uh uh
how do you say you don't uh anticipate
because you don't think that the Knight
is doing that much on B2 right it's not
clear it's still not clear I I take on
F2
Rook F1 oh Rook F1 excuse me
pardon me
and we do have a result and that is
official then
uh
yeah as
that was the missed opportunity yeah
very big chance uh Justin Wang probably
happy making a draw with black pieces
especially uh after that oh he's
definitely difficult situation but it's
unclear whether uh whether Justin wank
realized that there was maybe a problem
in his position I don't think he did
yeah sometimes I think it was a mutual
blindness yeah mutual blindness well
we'll keep our eye on the game between
uh shabalov and akopian and Believers
yeah I wanted to go to our tournament
leaders uh it was funny I coming to the
coming to back to the game
I was actually thinking Max had the best
position he had for a long time because
uh I see this position as in like two
moves is over uh just Knight D4 followed
by F3 you maintain if you can maintain
this bishop on F6 forget about it you're
done you're dusted and from Max's point
of view he got what he wanted he got rid
of the bishop you know okay he's a pawn
down but he's a big favorite of winning
the pawn back right Rook takes Bishop
takes yeah I really like this E5 move
can we maybe go back a little bit and
look at that so F3
uh uh oh here no yeah I know E5 right
because that seems like a really strong
response we are forcing the trade of the
Bishops exactly uh but Malik said he had
an idea in mind and that was related to
the move G5 yes you can win your Pawn
back Rook takes A2 which by the way
but he's got check
okay so now if you take this one that's
a good trade from White's point of view
White's thinking to himself haha two
connected past bonds uh aren't I happy
can I continue uh sure Bishop to E6
to E6 just to pause
gosh that King looks so vulnerable 65
sorry
all right you have Rook xc5 I cannot do
that
check yeah yeah oops but I don't like
King thanks G5 can we just go King G7
yes yes King G7 oh you're gonna play The
Rook F1 no there's Bishop B6 okay okay
you're good uh the move I would really
like to do is night
uh C1 so my idea is that if you play
Rook takes B2 you're not forced to play
Rook takes B2 I want to play Knight
takes E5 that's a dream
position I think
because Black's Pawn structure is all
messed up right and whites but it's also
very limited right the material is very
limited so maybe I can continue even in
that position like Rook C2 maybe Rook C2
so you're tickling my my little peshki
okay I'm I'm here right Rook E7 I'm just
trying to say that you're kind of stuck
on that PIN
better get off the bin uh but you're
right the material if you were to take
and take I go up you take I take on G5
or maybe rookie two yeah I might survive
right well that's what I'm saying Max is
probably happy with his position because
he got rid of that Bishop on F6 and that
was huge uh Christian gonna throw it
back to you and uh
ask you what caught your eye well it
does seem like Patrick is in fact
winning in this position once again
decisive Advantage after H4 and Igor
said I'm not waiting I'm opening up that
light Square Bishop
yeah but the question is okay what if I
just simply take I understand you got
your Bishop out you can go Bishop E6 but
isn't my H5 Pawn going H5 opening up the
position you have to go G5 strong if you
allow me to take on G6 you're getting
checkmated yeah so you have to go G5 and
then I can just simply go Queen to F4 F
Queen to E4 F5 Queen to D4 I'm a pawn up
and the compensation it seems right I
have the attack I have a central Knight
you have some structural weaknesses sure
I don't see where your counter play is
as black right my king is perfectly safe
so after E5 take Bishop to D6 probably
is the way he wants to continue this
game but as you were mentioning guys
Rook takes D6 okay let's give it up
let's give the exchange right let's go
H5 let's try to Checkmate perhaps this
is what Igor is uh hoping for but this
is not objectively good because you're
getting checkmated then there is no way
for you with the black pieces to
exchange the Queens if you don't
exchange the queens and if you don't do
something quick I'm taking on G6 I'm
going Queen H6 I'm checkmating you on H7
right you're in big big trouble and if
you try to take for example let's say
let's make some moves right Bishop to E6
right take on G6 you take with the F
Pawn Queen to H6 you try to defend on
the seventh rank right Queen to E7 or
queen to C7 let's agree to C7 to keep an
eye on the pawn on the Knight on E5 I
continue I have so many resources all of
my resources are in fact aimed at your
King right the Knight the bishop the
queen and the Rook everything and the
pawn and the H Pawn right so I have so
many attackers and very often is very
basic right
how many attackers versus how many
Defenders do we have in the position
right I have a lot of attackers right
now I have five attackers and you have
how many Defenders maybe two Defenders
maybe two Defenders that's an
overwhelming majority for my attack
which is going to lead to a decisive
Advantage so this one is looking good if
it takes on E5 decides he has a couple
of decisions ahead of himself Patrick
that is to take on E5 and then to give
the exchange to continue the attack but
I feel like he's going to go for it
we've seen him uh generally taking this
type of aggressive decisions in the past
as well I have long long maintained that
chess is a game of confidence confidence
really and you know you look at
Patrick's score
he's got what a draw out of four games
his confidence has been shattered and
that game where he played Bishop takes
H6 and sacrifice for the king's attack
against Chicago if he looked terrible as
a result now you get this position
against Igor you go Knight takes E5 and
you know that after the only move Bishop
D6 otherwise you're just a pawn down
it's and it's terrible you know you're
gonna have to sacrifice The Exchange do
you have the confidence the internal
fortitude to say yeah I'm good let's go
let's go that setback that happened last
week if the ancient history I'm ready to
sacrifice it's about confidence but on
the other hand like if you move back
yeah
and you don't take like with shabalov it
was like it was a chore it's right you
sacrifice but the choice here was Queen
takes
so like if you take my knight I take a
bishop now am I just to pawn up and you
know but I don't have to say all the
attack is out right well yeah yeah
I still you know okay on a good day I I
might have some stuff so I mean I'm
saying that I could play it safe with
Queen takes E5 or I can you know risk
The Exchange sacrifice but boy that
looks so promising the attack looks like
it yeah and here it comes Bishops and
there's no choice now you're kind of
forced yeah I've got I've got to burn
this bridge I've got to give up my
exchange I burn the bridge already
back but that's what I'm saying it's the
confidence sometimes you've put you've
had a bad score in your confidence has
shattered and you're playing the safety
move over the over the
the right and you know it's right to
sacrifice you know it's good for you but
you just don't have the confidence at
that moment to follow through and well
here it comes uh Patrick ready to do to
do Rook takes I just want to check in
again our Marquee matchup between our
two tournament leaders we do have Rook
uh the move that you like to play uh
King G7 I think that King takes G5 was
just two wrists I I I wouldn't want to
go into it either and King G7 on the
board and Max on the back foot uh but
I'd really like to remove Knight C1 here
because the Knight on B3 is doing
nothing exactly and just like yes I'm
giving up the pawn on B2 but
transferring the Knight to D3 attacking
that one on E5 exactly and you know
really you ask the Knight on B3 which is
a lousy night where would it like to be
well we kind of go well I gotta Rook on
F6 you know the night on E5 would
harmonize with The Rook on F6 so yeah I
would like to put the Knight will tell
you I want to stay Anywhere But Here
get me out of here
it's terrible I can't go to A5 or C5 or
D4 uh get me out of here right right
plus like after Rook takes me too I I'm
really forced to go to C1 anyway exactly
so uh we'll keep an eye on this all
important uh senior uh matchup as again
tomorrow is the free day uh boy whoever
goes in if Malik said were to win this
game he'd go into that free day
confident soaring foreign Health points
out of five and you have a rest day and
what's happening in the Carissa and by
the way he played that move or Knight to
C1 that you were recommending exactly
and what about Carissa you got her game
on your board an important matchup uh
Christian that's right Carissa is doing
well I have no idea how it happened
but she's a pawn up all right I'll show
you how it happened yes Rook to B1 and
now for whatever reason Gracie decides
to play Brook to B8 giving up upon what
take I think C4 Queen to C7
um
my guess is that she thought that the
only retreating move with the Knight
that makes sense of course you don't
want to go to E3 because that actually
gives me the pawn back right Queen takes
C3 cuts the uh defense of the queen and
if you go Knight D2 maybe he just want
she just wanted to go Bishop to H6 makes
sense which in fact it gives you quite
some compensation in the position the
problem is that you actually go Knight
B2 which was played Karissa just played
this move the Knight is protected
everything is protected you don't have
entry squares C4 C5 C4 C5 is coming C4
Queen C3 C5 something along those lines
and white is really happy the king is
now longer on G1 right otherwise there
will be some you can see three tricks
yes very nice so let's show that let's
say you go something like this you go
like this very nice yes yes oops
and we were wondering why in the world
did you play king2h1 I said that well
she just doesn't simply uh see a
different plan right right but perhaps
she was seeing in the future that's
exactly what's happening right now
Knight to B2 Pawn up Carissa is in the
driver's seat and I have to say despite
the fact that she's played badly let's
just put it as it is she's played badly
this game right she was worse with the
white pieces out of the opening and
through the middle game but in last few
moves she's completely turned it around
putting a lot of pressure on the clock
as well 16 minutes for a Gracie prasanna
and 44 minutes for Carissa Karissa is
feeling good and she needs a victory
right she really needs a victory to keep
Pace with Alice Lee exactly and Alice
Lee by the way is probably going to be a
drawing that one right exactly I've got
the game between Alice and Rochelle
Rochelle Wu with the white they're in a
rook and if I'm in Rochelle's shoes I'm
playing B4 A4 A5 basically using my
minority my my queen side pawns I'm
going to block uh the majority Alice's
majority and that's going to leave two
versus two on the king side and that's
going to be a draw Carissa if she does
win then she is going to be a half a
point behind and we were talking about
the rivalry at the very start of the
tournament it's living up to our billing
the rare thing in our commentators uh
curse given the positions she had to be
only half a point behind that is that
right that's that's amazing exactly what
happened here
after it was this move Queen before and
we were just saying we really liked uh
what Ru yenyen was doing this these two
Bishops are making a great impression
and after the move Rook E3 Kelsey said
do you want my H4 Pawn
yes yeah I'll take it Bishop by the way
we haven't been talking about this uh is
this Pawn hanging
takes B3 Knight takes me 3. I mean we
have to be careful about some discover
attacks exactly I think that Kelsey was
trying her best to set a nasty trap and
lure black into capturing that pawn yeah
the square is A4 and C4 are mined you
step onto this uh Royal Fork yeah Knight
B6 check okay we had an amazing night on
C5 this kind of sad Bishop on B3 we
don't even think about capturing that
exactly you you said it very well the
sad Bishop pawns on F7 and E6
a formidable barrier closing down the
diagonal and well okay
very healthy Pond I'll take it Munch
Rook takes uh pardon me Bishop takes uh
and well not much going on here it's
time maybe just to come back and say
good job Bishop you grab a pawn
Logistics let's consolidate you know
let's be like the caveman you know you
go out you grab some food then you bring
it back into the cave Bishop E7 and uh
definitely uh for sure is for choice and
I want to go Iris just yes black was
four Choice here yeah she's just she's
using her majority white is doing her
best
actually it's I'm still recovering after
G3 luckily I have 93 there but no way uh
this is one of those uh moments where
it's like Ben Larson would say nobody
believes you you're just barely hanging
are you gonna be like sneaky with some
Rook E5 and Bishop F4 right okay
wow look at that yeah you you you have
you you won my heart
rookie five Bishop F4 and Rook H5
yeah I can tell you've been you've been
doing the summer camps you've got those
chess attacks and those tactics on your
mind now this looks overwhelming and F3
is
vice is dangerous I mean if you don't
play G3 I capture Queen H3 Bishop F4 I
mean wow okay I mean F3 came in that's
gonna come with massive massive Force
Christian I'm saying it over to you what
do you have for us whoa shocked you you
were mesmerized by F3 and queen H3 is
like whoa
you are through a Hardball
um this one Zoe tank versus Rose Atwell
I have to say rose has the best position
she's had in a very long time despite
the fact that she's an exchange down
forget about it that's okay you're still
losing completely losing but you have
some ideas some tricks in the position
for example
if you take on C5 right you would be
asking why not take on C5 right that's
on Pawn I get back with my queen to F2
I'm defending everything around my king
Bishop takes G2 comes on the board oh
man and actually this is just seems to
me like a draw if you take I go H3 don't
go
if you go between G5 or queen to G4 and
now I go here you cannot go to E2 you
have to go back and then we forget the
Perpetual nice beautiful that's that's
the best you can get in the position and
you might get tempted by the fact that
hey what if I go
to G3 it seems like I'm safe right but
in fact you're not because you cannot
touch this Pawn
don't take it that's a Checkmate in one
move so you have to drop back and
basically we're getting the same thing
I'm checking you on the f file and you
cannot go on the e-file or the H file so
that's a trick in the position that's
the best thing that she could have hoped
for I have to say because uh her King
was in danger right all the way here
when these pawns were going down the
board and it was looking really really
bad and somehow she managed to just give
up the exchange and perhaps get some
chances at least some practical chances
I like what she has done Bravo to Zoe
she didn't take debate defend that pawn
on G2 with Rook to D2 good move she's
not joining yasser's Club of the pond
Grabbers Association no no no uh just
turning our attention to the senior uh
championship for Mom and Alexander
shabalov and Vladimir okobian uh both
players have their trumps and I thought
for that reason that a balanced outcome
us to be expected we got to this
position and
um after the move B6 B5 by Vladimir
shabalov drop back I didn't like the
Rook on the D4 Square I wanted to
transfer the Knight to the D4 Square
well guess what Knight B2 Rook D4 Knight
C4
and it looked like a peaceful draw was
in store for us and uh means an early
dinner and all that good stuff for us
and getting ready for a rest day no no
no no no after Rook the four route D1 it
was Vladimir that said I don't want a
repetition I think I have uh my trumps
are better than yours yes you get your
knight to D4 I'll play the move Queen B6
and tell me
why you're so happy with the bishop and
so forth and so on so I just thought it
was intriguing that in the Judgment of a
copian he wanted to play on did he make
the right choice
I can't wait for the answer I'm very
happy to see my knight on D4 I was
worried about the Rook being misplaced
agreed so now I understand the knights
are still pretty strong on e4 and C4
right but I don't see a direct kind of
attack so maybe we can do something like
Rook D3 Rook it goes back to D3 yeah
it's sort of like okay I'm not great I'm
not a big fan of the queen so I would
love to transfer the queen maybe to F4
or F5 how I am going to cross the
barrier I'm not really sure Rook to D3
with the idea of Rook to D1 maybe I
would also love to play like F3 and
Bishop F2 but I'm scared of weakening
the E3 Square so kind of Defending it
before you weaken it yeah you think
um I would ask Christian to break the
tie but I know if I ask him if it's a
draw no he will say only time will tell
who if Vladimir made the right decision
and uh if I remember correctly the
assessment the objective assessment of
that position he is slightly better now
slightly black is slightly better yeah
slightly better is not much right it's
still a very complex middle game
position you have your trumps I have
mine right of course strategically with
the isolated Pawn you could be at some
point in trouble as black right so you
do have to have some sense of urgency in
the position at the same time I'm
looking at the clock I'm looking at the
fact that I don't see a clear plan for
white either and I say okay why not
let's try it out I'm two and a half
points one point behind the leader right
so I need to uh catch up to them back by
the way night to from D4 back to B3
intimating that he's ready to either go
Knight to A5 or maybe on a good day take
this night and go Knight to C5 as a way
of getting rid of these very very
powerful nights I wasn't sure myself I
actually like white trumps in the
position but for for for me the question
was could I play the move F2 F3
immediately or not because if I could
get you to play Knight D6 Knight F6 I
don't care just please just go back you
can figure out later how far back you
want to go and then I was going to go
Bishop F2
and this is where I'm getting my
transfer that I want I want to bring my
queen to FM I'm not a fan of my queen
being on B1 and uh you well now that you
see what after F3 to go Knight D6 no no
no no no no no 92 92.
because here one night is going to be
three the second one is getting ready to
jump to C4 well are you getting uh the
second warranty to like okay can I I was
trying to force you to take on G2 and
play Bishop's office of color but uh
Christian's clearing the cobwebs I'm
playing F3 with the dream of getting
your knight to retreat you're not
retreating yeah oh wow yeah now I'm
making this pin
Rook takes E2 that's nasty all the way
so F3 didn't work Knight B3 on the board
and again from shibalov's point of view
he may be thinking okay I can sacrifice
a pawn Knight C5 I could play fortnite
A5 just to close the a file and so on a
big fight going on they're checking in
with Max
and what happened here so no this is
just this he did play the whole night C1
I mean they went down the whole pathway
there I think we had this on board right
rookie seven and I think I was trying to
play with the move Rook F1 by the way uh
Dimitri's cruising I mean it's just wow
these three pawns everything everything
has gone his way and Dima boy I tell you
he just
the last two rounds with the white
pieces as well I mean you Retreat Bishop
to F1 and ig4 and game over yeah no Doug
yeah he resigned he resigned he resigned
that was that was uh yeah the tragedy
came uh oh man right here and it's sort
of like you have this blindness that you
say to yourself oh my Pawn is so well
defended
there's nothing to worry about
except
oh no now excuse me that was the uh but
it was the it was uh missing this Knight
takes D4 moment
uh you whenever I get these positions as
white I I quickly play around if you
want it Queen hi the Queen the queen on
the D1 Square I go and then you don't
worry about the default I bet I don't
worry about it there is this point
because of this type of a tragedy can
befall anybody I mean I've followed for
this more than once I can assure you and
uh Christian what do you have for us
well I'm looking at Jose's turman's game
and this one is completely crazy
um take a look at this point and I think
he's uh in big trouble in fact oh Arthur
has a golden opportunity but how did we
get here and we were discussing about
the fact that the d-pawn is not that
good we have the better structure with
the back pieces but take a look at what
happened Queen to F5 Knight D5 Rook to
C8 and I feel this is already a step in
the wrong direction Queen to A3 and
instead of Knight to G6 just get this
Knight away from this diagonal right
Rook takes C5 came but this allows D3 C5
and perhaps what Josiah is looking for
with the black piece allowing this type
of things it's just some sort of counter
play but this was completely unnecessary
Queen to C2 B4 Miss B4 that's the whole
good movies yeah he just he was going to
play Rook B8 on his next turn and take
them have some fun yeah and but before
cold shower that might be the cold
shower though immediately after B4 he
played very quickly Rook to B8 C6 on the
board is it on the board on the board
that's the that's the money move that is
the money move that is the money move
and uh right now Josiah is in big big
trouble because first of all you cannot
take you take Rook to C1 game over
so you have to do something else you
have to create your own counter play if
you allow me to go Rook C1 C7 B5
good luck you're you're dark right so
you have to go D4 it feels like Knight
to C8 I don't see this move happening
forget about it this is not practical
almost no human plays the move Knight to
see it try to create some sort of
blockade Knight C8 Knight B6 and then I
don't I don't see that happening I see
D4 coming on the board and then Rook to
C1
this is something that Arthur will have
still some big decisions along the way
take a look at this
Queen to E4 or E2 let's say E2 C7 I go
to C8 and now you have continue with B5
wow right
um hitting the Knight on E7 that's the
thing I'm looking at the position I
don't think it's that difficult because
you take on E5 I take on E7 and the
thing is you cannot touch this Pawn
because of Queen to d80 you're just
simply not in time right you're one move
away from being okay but you're not
right because of Queen d8 so the game is
over
big moment right now a lot of details to
uh to calculate a lot of lines to
calculate for both sides I see that R2
is down to his last 10 minutes so that's
an encouragement for Josiah never
nevertheless the position is not
right now the position is borderline
losing for black
wow uh C6 so let's go again it was D4 D4
yes Rook C1 only move by the way Queen
E2
everything this is normal Rook CA mb5 B5
and I wanted to play the move knight uh
to defense is the only move to stop B6
to I mean I'm dreaming that you would
play Knight C6 once again perhaps this
is what he missed now I go B6
oh sorry because it's not over I I I was
dreaming Knight C6 and like hey
76. why is it not spectacular B6 and now
Knight takes B6 Queen D6
okay Queen d8 is coming queen so this is
on Tab
this is on tap
difficult stuff very very difficult
stuff I'm not gonna I have to go King H7
to stop Queen d8 check
well I don't know what if I take and I
go Queen no I cannot go Queen B8 so I
probably have to do something else
that that that's a cute Point by the way
how embarrassing would this be
very
I mean the X-ray right I mean it's a
little like oh thank you very much no
you can promote but I'm gonna grab that
Queen right put me back my everything
back but I can perhaps just simply go
uh say it
before
capture it no I take you take right I'm
fighting can I take take B6 take only
five and queen B7
yes that's a fair move I mean I you
still have Queen G5 I think it's the
only move
but then I go F4 and you don't have a
way to get to E3 wow
so I think that's over yeah that's a
strong Secret
I mean who I think it was
El Alaina the Ukrainian player who once
made this maneuver where he gave up a
whole rook and they took like three
Quiet Moves and it was a Perpetual check
it was like just like one of the most
amazing combinations I've ever seen in
my life and you're going to promote and
I still get a Perpetual check that's
crazy stuff that's crazy I know you
should show the the continuation because
we actually have
a guest in-house with us no no keep
going keep going okay that's a position
and we have a guest in-house yes who
just won his game and wants to propose
some moves
commentator to chicken Rook should win
one single Rock should be in the name
game but he will play King G6 but you
know and be careful like you know
because you make a queen and all of a
sudden some Perpetual check you know so
so it's not not over yet you know
but it's very nice he was saying that he
won't take your queen
well maybe I can go after five I have no
idea what's happening by the way maybe I
should go Queen G8 first queen G8
live Improvement making sure we are
targeting F7 yeah so that way when you
play F5 checks
you guys are having too much fun
yes to the show Christian you're with
Dimitri Garvin absolutely Dmitry first
of all uh congratulations so thank you
nice game it was it was it was a gift it
was a blunder also it's not even a pawn
it's a Central Pawn it's a central point
yeah this moment when you saw the move
Knight G E5 what was your reaction I I
saw it in advance so he cannot do that
yeah yeah and when he made it well
unfortunately Doug blonde that he also
this one big problem for really senior
players he's not dead singer than me
it's it's uh blunders because everything
else is
so so understandable yeah and you're
talking about the blunders I remember
that game against uh Maxim loogie you
play that move G3 Bishop E3 game over
but then immediately you showed no King
F2 was making a draw yeah showing on the
board well well it wasn't it was a drop
position but it wasn't that simple I
looked over it could be some trips and
well I played badly he had played me
very nicely I had a great opening at
some point and then uh he uh we got
equal position because I played a couple
of bad moves and um a little bit more
and then he started playing for win and
he had played me very brilliantly and
definitely he deserved to win this game
yeah he was winning before one move
before he was in position so but you
came back with black pieces well
yesterday I played also America the
great game can be in the book
into his variation but they didn't play
correctly so yes yeah and after he took
on D4 you executed the attack perfectly
uh it was some well first of all he had
the move which was better than what he
did yeah I mean it's lost position C4 is
not a good move okay C4 is not a good
move he should play Bishop D3
okay
this well it's a bad position but right
so it's not resignable
you take you take this B Point okay
because because the other one is
probably something else it's like
before Bishop D5 Bishop oh Bishop takes
F3 Justin yeah this is a yeah this is a
thing no no bc3 it's not over okay yeah
it's not doing well I mean I mean Source
position but it's definitely a playable
this is what you think you should do
right yeah create some ideas some
chances yeah of course yes
it was a moment when I uh you attack on
a f8 and I could probably
uh
sacrifice I could probably play E4
but I looked a little bit I didn't see
immediate win and it is dangerous to go
for position which is uh not winning and
then you think why did I do that and or
to spend too much time you know to make
so you have to play solidly It's Not
Practical yeah I mean you have porn up
you have a winning position you have two
Central points of course it's if you
don't see immediate win them then that's
a great lesson by the way yeah
never complicated when you don't have to
in a winning position if it's no problem
something like Murphy's law but not
Murphy's if it's no problem you don't
don't try to solve problems that don't
exist very nice and he resigned at this
point Dimitri you've been here in St
Louis you've played in St Louis how are
you enjoying the atmosphere seeing your
old friends as well playing chess so you
don't play that much you're mostly a
coach nowadays yes yes my my best
results from my students
I was working with Victor Kushner in the
80s and then I just a little bit not but
then also tremendously happy that it
happened in my life and it was a few
results he's like he wanted his own was
helping human 1980s
my student selfish Michael just got his
first GM
very nice and of course honestly it's a
star star students a few years was great
and she's amazing and I hope she'll go
much higher to become world champion and
whatever so you're seeing your friends
you're also seeing some of your students
here mostly yes my my friends many
people I know from the ages yes uh some
from the 90s Greek I don't know I know
from the 70s so they all I enjoyed to
see them with a great great players
great people and that's that's very
enjoyable you know is a unique
atmosphere of what we have here great
conditions and to see wonderful people
and great comments yeah sir
thank you for not playing that's a good
one
Kate has a question for you yeah
congratulations on your game today you
seem to be really enjoying you know
chess your games but you are also the
winner of the 2022 us seniors Open
Championship so are you looking here to
to win the tournament not just enjoy the
atmosphere
she's saying that you won the U.S
seniors open championships
yeah
one is my student my my best student my
grandma he's now my teacher excuse me
and also he beat Alex and he bit another
Alexa maninski so in five out of five I
made Wonder of his uh Alexis and then
last round I just had to play for me and
I had no choice so I I tried and at some
point I was lost and that one that was a
miracle yeah and she's saying that he
won that one do you have Ambitions of
winning this Championship as well oh
what do you mean this this thing you're
open this one yes oh it's in Europe
there but it's going right now it's
going to be this weekend so I cannot
play both even if I had the rocket level
got it no no but it was a miracle to it
then I don't think it's because I'm
senior but other seniors are like Junior
Jesse greyler in this one with
vladimirock open I remember when he was
a teenager a teenager and now he's 50.
he looks still very young you know it
looks looks Junior
congratulations thank you very very very
nice I like this another mirror another
miracle happened nice
um again I'm just going to check in on
our tournament leaders
um
malikset and Max delugie when we left it
we just the the night had been
transferred to E5 Rook E7 and now here
was the moment where we were we had been
looking at move like Rook um F1 F1 to
kind of well I I want to get off this I
hate being in these pins but more
importantly uh to capture on F7 uh Alex
said you know what I really like this
bind and I'm willing to give up my C3
Pawn to continue my attack so he's
sitting there saying look I've got
Ambitions I want to go H6 check if I can
force your King backwards then I can go
G6 and you know we could be talking and
there's Rook there is night I mean there
can be even some checkmates exactly some
checkmating patterns so we have H5 on
the board I don't know if clocks are a
factor hard for me to tell by looking at
them on my monitor so we see Maxim logi
he has 30 minutes and Malik has 16
minutes 13 13 13 to 16. so okay and
they're on move 31. something uh to to
look out for Christ is definitely
looking good but take a look at what's
happening at Patrick Wolfgang maybe you
can see it on your own yes I'll bring it
up this was where he sacrificed The
Exchange that's right and he did it this
was way back in this moment there it
goes thump
definitely opening that file
going for the Checkmate uh well that by
the way that's Pond number two right so
we've already got two Pawns in the
pocket for the exchange
no this is this is he's cruising right I
think he's crumbling yeah oh everything
oh oh wow 98. oh ding ding ding and
Bishop B3 could be there in the future
oh oh that's exactly what's gonna come
on the board very very soon oh you can
take on F7 maybe first right
yeah
you you want to do it with style you
know like flash
have you got it flaunt it you know like
you flash right Queen F6 flaunted
and is there any way to save this no
there's no so Knight d8 there's no
saving this one and uh if if clocks are
definitely not a factor now of course
you could always you know uh Knight
takes F7 but I think there should be
three is really a sweet this may be the
first win for Patrick will but deserving
win we have to say this was a great game
so far very attacking
there's another really attacking game
can we go to Alex chavalov and Vladimir
akopian because Vladimir just started to
run with his age Pawn there's no age
Pawn there's no running website anymore
but we left it we there was this uh
dynamic balance going on and I kind of
like what
um shabby uh did he put his Knight on C5
and said okay look this is your best
piece you know please do me a solid get
rid of the and I will
[Music]
not interested said Vladimir uh I don't
want you taking my Bishop which I found
to be an interesting decision by the way
Rook D3 keeping as many pieces on the
board and
Alexander is rerouting the night to back
today yeah well somehow he's achieved
something and from Vladimir's
perspective from Black's perspective
he's got to do something
soon because
there are the two Bishops long term if
if white white might even be thinking
Rook D1 Rook takes sacrificing exchange
so but also since the Rook moved to A7
now black was maybe even threatening to
uh to capture the Knight on C5 right to
just get them yes yes exactly which is
why he dropped his nightmare rook and
again kind of intimating it's I'm not
forced to but I I definitely don't don't
think that the Rook has perspectives
shall we say on the C file I like the
move Rook C1 to D1 H4 I like capturing
this Pawn not just because I'm winning a
pawn or anything like that but I don't
want to see a weakness occurring on the
G3 square and maybe I don't know uh
still it feels to me like it's a three
result game and uh crazy things is going
on what's going on uh Chris oh you have
the other Junior well let's take a look
at the Juniors yeah right and we're
going to start with one of the
co-leaders going into today's round
Arthur go is uh beating on Josiah's
children right now take a look at this
C6 Knight F5 already a bad move bad
Direction already a difficult position
and I have to say I cannot blame Josiah
too much for not missing the next move
after Knight to F5 Queen to C1 came on
the board completely unexpected but
right now that's going to support from
behind my C pawn and you no longer have
the Knight back into place so this one
is really really
urgent for Black Knight to D4 and queen
to F4 and I have to say I'm looking at
the position probably the best way is to
give up a couple of Pawns like uh like
this queen takes C6 is going to come
this one is completely busted Rook f8
Queen tc6 two pawns up I'm going to
retreat back to uh E2 maybe I defend
with Rook 32 not looking good this is
over so what's happened and by the way
Arthur go with a victory in this one is
going to be four in a row hello that's
absolutely amazing and he might actually
go into the rest day as the sole leader
because what's happening between Balaji
and Brandon and we were discussing this
type of positions and we're seeing that
so far so good it's very balanced but if
any of the sides will make a slight
mistake it can go bad very quickly and
that's exactly what happened take a look
at this Rook to G3 I really like what
Bellagio is doing trying to uh set up
some traps against the King on the G
file and Knight to A4 and I believe this
was the move that Brandon uh missed by
the way instead of king2h8 the best move
in the position was Knight to E4 not
easy because right now you're basically
giving up a pawn but of course I cannot
take it because I take back the pawn on
E5 and in fact on the G file you don't
have enough resources to continue the
attack and in fact my Pawn on e4 is more
valuable than the pawn on H6 so
he played King h8 Knight to A4 I really
like this move Rook takes A4 and it's
all about where are my pieces are they
on their ideal squares as white
and the answer is yes
what are your pieces and where is your
counter play and the answer is nowhere
to be found because the Knight on B4 not
doing much they reconciate beautiful but
where are you going I am at best you're
going to give me a check right on C1 but
that's not even going to happen it is
Knight F5 uh in this position it just
comes naturally I have so many attackers
against your king side and it's just not
looking good Bishop to f8 Knight to D4
I'm not really sure why they're
repeating but they are repeating right
now if he finds this move Knight to D6
objectively Bellagio is winning
this one is a win we were expecting this
one Bishop to B3 finished the game for
Patrick Wolff and by the way what an
important victory that was when you're
scoring a half out of your first four
games you're feeling really bad you know
uh what am I gonna and you come back and
you play really wonderful game like this
yeah
and now I have a rest day so I'm ready
to to you know to do better in the
second half of the tournament exactly
and I'm looking at the position of
Arthur go uh versus uh Josiah and uh
this last move Queen F4 wow I mean
that's just that's a real visual move it
you know hits the Knight it hits the
pawn on F7 yes I agree I invite Knight
episode Knight check but boy when I pick
up that pawn on F7 I got everything
going in my favor
this just looks like Arthur is in Cruise
mode and you know winning four in a row
I don't care what national championship
you're playing in you're just like you
know this is Cloud Nine marvelous after
losing the first round I mean yeah and
especially after losing the first round
very impressive so what if we go now to
the girls term and I feel like we did
not visit them for some time what is
happening anyway no results whatsoever
yeah they were all fighting uh Rochelle
and Alice were just uh who just check in
on because again that is a a marquee
matchup uh Alice uh having a point
lead over uh Rochelle looks again like
they're they're heading towards a drawer
do you see this going badly for
a draw Rochelle
no I understand it's a draw objectively
but can you see this going badly for
Rochelle because I'm starting you know
the pawn is not on A5 for y the pawn is
not on B4 I haven't closed the shop on
the queen side
yeah I'm saying that uh let's imagine I
go here and I don't know what you're
supposed to do I I'm just gonna say okay
now how will your king ever uh close
it's not it's come so into my account so
maybe instead of H5 I go King F5
yeah I mean I don't think it's promising
too much but I can try if I can get to
E4 never mind
scram you bother me
okay but Carissa's game when we left it
Carissa was up a pawn
no that's not Chris's game that's the
union Carissa was up a pond she was
about to play C4 C5 you see those pawns
on the king side it's like
okay but no who is attacking now uh it
feels like like this attack for black is
not really much of an attack at all it
looks like C4 C5 this is actually play
on one goal
I'm ready to munch I'm ready to play H4
undermine this night okay so I'm not
going to capture yours okay I'm going
I'm going to capture an E4
uh Well Done Right uh Knight C4 let's go
so giving up on an IFA on D5 I don't
know if I want to take that I was
thinking that if you did I was going to
go Queen takes E4 and queen G6 check
okay
just giving you fair warning that's
that's fair there's a storm brewing all
right Bishop F5 Bishop F5
okay
um eventually I am going to take
something aren't I
oh
okay uh let's just continue with my idea
of
taking
something
at the moment Knight takes by the way
Queen takes G5 is awkward
to say the least right so I'll go nice
work Queen d8
I'm afraid you're you're suffering a
position that really is not it's not
that that there's no there's no joke
there was a there is an expression that
I just fell in love with there's no joy
in Mudville
you know like it's just a terrible place
you don't want to be there so queen I'm
looking at this looking at Knight E3
you're extra Pawn okay G4 I'm not giving
up not giving up look at you I can't get
no Jedi Mind Tricks for you huh not
giving up okay let me go after this guy
Bishop Harry and I will take this
yeah
I may not have done this in the most
easiest practical man okay I go back
Bishop C8
everyone goes and I want to
um I want to promote this Pawn so any
trades would probably benefit me
I want to say if I can
get this guy sorry no I I like that oh
you did I'm sorry I need
let's say Bishop A6
wow uh just feels very very very very
very good for Carissa let's just
continue uh to the ruian game this was
where she
yeah but how did The Rook get to B4
there was a queen on B4 when we left it
I swear there was a queen on B4 okay we
left it around these parts let's just
quickly catch up night before
so the rock Rook swung across to C3 King
B8 very logical very logical getting the
king to safety Rook to C4 look at this
The Rook that is like if you had told me
like how the Rook on H1 gets to B4 like
five moves ago I would say you know
you're a genius like I didn't see that
coming E5 takes takes and
well you know you're targeting B7 and
it's no joke I cannot play Bishop C6
because I'm still attacking what is
still attacking you two times right
so she's defended the F Pawn and she
said okay uh there's a storm but you
know we've been louding how powerful
this Knight on C5 is and it it really is
it's doing everything can we
can we play something no we can't I I
want to play Rook takes D7
I want to make an illegal move ah no I
can't do it oh sorry I was about to I
was about to say let's play Knight F5 so
that I can play after captures the night
do me a do me the favor of capturing the
night so I could capture the bishop but
Bishop C6 just oh yeah that's that
answer me that that closes the door yeah
that that shuts unless I have oh sorry I
thought Queen C3 but
I don't have that Rook takes B7 because
you're captured with that night that
night dessert deserves a medal exactly
uh great service uh being provided we
think uh this is a going very well free
ruling Ian and Zoe and Rose uh that was
the that was the exchange
um
and one more game we have Iris small
against Shreya mangam what's going on
there oh that was the F3 game we thought
it was completely uh busted F3 oh sorry
uh F3 Bishop A4 how about that forcing
me to play the tragic Queen G4
and
you like the rookie five too right oh
Queen C8 okay that's this game it isn't
as clear-cut as we thought this is
I mean why they're surviving the king is
safe right now right yeah no knights
around giving checks the light Square
Bishop is never going to give check to
the King this is Bizarro world this is
not uh clear I would say uh something
was Mr something happened that uh yeah
and by the way is the clock times a
factor I see 17 minutes yeah so Iris has
less than four minutes three minutes 20
seconds and Shreya has 17 minutes I
think you guys should check the junior
section okay let's do it there's some
really some crazy stuff going on in
crucial games in that one oh wow I see
Brian Jacobson Juan versus Bellagio I
mean Bellagio went absolutely berserk
with a peace sacrifice
right Bishop takes H6 and right now
Brandon is trying to figure out what in
the world what just happened uh berserk
indeed so we we were seeing the back and
forth going happening right it was
questionable thing in id6 right yes
Knight D6 was but what
uh help us out Kate so uh Take tape
yeah I don't know
okay thank you
it's like you know it was otherwise uh
doesn't make any sense so Bishop takes
on D6 Queen takes H6 we got that part
yay we're also threatening
that Knight takes F7 check too right so
just excuse me just boldly pointing out
what the threats are now Rook to C2
no no that's Knight xf7 yeah I just
wanted to see that Knight takes F7 King
to H7 Queen here
I was dreaming
I think we saw this in one of the games
or it was a bishop C5 remember it was a
1992 yeah 92 check and Bishop C5 here's
a kind of a similar similar pattern okay
by the way he didn't take it though we
have a special guest in Syria and then
Bishop H6 were key five uh on the board
by the way he didn't take Rook takes E5
crazy stuff Chris Christian uh over to
you Patrick uh first of all
congratulations thank you difficult
tournament up to this point for you but
you were just simply not giving up and
finally it paid off for you tell us
about your initial feelings after this
Victory well it feels really nice of
course I mean you know it's much better
than being a punching bag and
um being on the other side of the
punching is better and
um I feel like it was a pretty good game
I mean I need to check it of course with
the engine but um you know I think the
position out of the opening was pretty
good for me and it didn't I didn't feel
like I ever lost the thread no no and I
really like this moment when he took on
E3 and you could have taken with the
Knight and well have a normal position
oh this is still yeah this is still
Theory the theory here is very
interesting like this position is known
but it's not very well worked out so
it's the 11 is like that it's really
really kind of fascinating to me they're
it's very complicated it's like you've
entered some alternate universe because
not a lot of people played right no
although I've noticed that um uh uh some
like nepomanishi has been playing at
some and and um no I people are starting
to play it but um I mean there's lots
and lots of games with it and there's
lots of theory but it hasn't somehow
been fully worked out and so a very
strong player like Igor
um I didn't know how well prepared he
would be I knew he if I played against
this Knight or if he'd be very well
prepared right so I figured this was
probably a better idea I knew that he
played something like these systems in
the games I found on him so I figured
some probably something I had no idea
how well prepared he'd be but I think it
goes to show someone as strong as Igor
as well prepared as he generally is
didn't seem to really know how to play
the opening
um which gives you an idea sort of how
like tricky this can be yeah absolutely
no and uh it does seem like you already
have some sort of an advantage and I
have to say this long Castle Queenie for
very forceful moves very concrete moves
well what's really interesting about
this position is there's two ideas and
you really have to work both of them
simultaneously so one is of course the
attack against the king but the other is
there are a lot of end games that are
very good right and so this is actually
like the the secret to this position
somehow is like you have to be willing
to take the end game and you have to use
that perhaps something like this yeah
yeah yeah I mean all oftentimes whenever
you can trade the queens in a pretty
good like oftentimes this Knight versus
like the light Square Bishop is really
bad yeah the C6 Pawn is really bad
you've got the D file so long as you
sort of hold hold control it should be
generally pretty good and so of course
Queen E4 perks G6 right so now there's
this big weakness and now Queen F4 and
now maybe this was not the best move I
don't know I saw an email right now but
I like it but uh well the computer knows
better than all but maybe but Queen F4
by the way it's the best one oh okay
well that's the best but but now like he
has a very difficult choice right he can
go into the end game but that's a really
painful end game to play yeah or he can
move the queen away but now he's created
this big weakness with G6 so now the
attack is always going to be much
stronger yeah yeah and uh well how was
Bishop C2 is that a good move yes yes
yes yes yes no Bishop C2 is filed
best move in the position oh that's good
yeah opening up the D file may be
hinting at 96 very nice oh so it thought
before was that that's interesting yes
hard move to play
yeah that's interesting I wondered about
before I couldn't bring myself to do it
and H4 just seems so natural and if you
go Queen G5 you have to understand that
this end game is just like really really
bad for you yeah yeah that's interesting
oh wow but the H4 I mean kind of plays
itself almost right well you know
yeah so E5 was a mistake right yes yeah
I mean it's so difficult to play this
position with black right it's so so
difficult because
the best moves still leave you with a
very bad position yeah and it's it like
it's very natural to try to get active
but the thing is actually my night is
very strong well I mean of course taking
on D6 has to be correct right like to
give this exchange I mean his dark
squares are terrible nothing else you're
kind of forced to play the best moves
yes exactly and then the night there's
but that night was really a hero right
it went Knight A3 C4 E5 c68 yeah I
thought that was very fun no no indeed
tell us a bit about your routine because
I've been seeing you quite a few times
at the gym you're working out tell us
about your routine I'm 55 years old I
wouldn't call it working out I would
call it trying to just stay healthy be
active but yeah I like to go to the gym
in the morning I try to stay fit
um it's very good for tournaments very
good just sort of to wake yourself up
and
and then I just try to prepare I mean
um I like I like to think of myself a
little bit like Rip Van Winkle I mean
I've been asleep for 20 years and I've
come back and um A lot's changed and I'm
trying really really hard to catch up
um and somehow like sometimes I I have
like opening knowledge like in my
computer but it's not actually in my
brain yeah so I'm trying as hard as
possible to like put it in my brain
um
do you do any coaching on the side do
you help some of the Juniors at all or I
haven't although it's something that I
think would be nice to do I I don't
teach professionally
um but um I really don't do anything in
chess professionally but um but you know
I I mean it would be nice to be a mentor
but quite frankly I'm looking at the
Juniors here and I don't think they need
my help they're so good they're really
good really good
um some of oh my gosh they're so by the
way what on Earth was that game that
finished really quickly we saw you
looking at what was going on what was
that insane preparation no some insane
preparation from Jason Liang yeah is
that new like 35 moves of theory
abhimanyu came with a novelty that but
he was ready for the novelty 35 moves
deep basically holy
maybe they'll Mentor me that would be
nice
congratulations thank you thank you guys
any questions absolutely yeah Patrick
congratulations you know thank you very
nice fighting game I'm curious you know
a few days back you had this game with
uh Alex shabalov where you where you
sacrifice the piece and then it didn't
work out today you sacrificed again this
time of an exchange how did that feel
did you think about that previous game
or did it nothing in your mind yeah that
game was painful you know
um it's interesting one thing I've
noticed as I've come back is part of
what I need to do is get it back into
the Rhythm right Max and I were having
dinner the other night he was talking
about how for him he had to get back
into the Rhythm and part of it is using
your time but part of it I think is
um managing the emotions and the energy
of the game and there's an old
expression maybe you've heard it when
you see a good a move sit on your hands
right and there might be a better one
and so this game against Alex well
Bishop A6 was the right idea but it was
it was the wrong move the right move in
the position is Queen E3
and then when Black Goes King H7 then
Bishop takes six Bishop takes six G5 and
in that position all three results are
possible right and what happened in that
game is I played the opening poorly Alex
just outplayed me but I still met I
still had an okay I think he missed like
one shot to have a really big advantage
and then I still had a normal position
but I felt under a lot of pressure and
when he castled I thought oh my gosh
this was my chance but I didn't think
right this is an incredibly important
moment in the game and I should have
just thought more carefully and I didn't
and afterwards I realized like part of
what I need to sort of get back into and
manage it's again it's not just the
opening preparation it's also just the
rhythm and and and and the emotions so
to answer your question this time
sacrificing The Exchange well of course
it's much easier when you have a good
position to start with and
um I I think I did a much better job of
just sort of like thinking carefully you
know Bishop C2 like I had a long thing
you know queen queen E4 Queen F4 like
these moments I was I took I think the
right amount of time and was able to
figure out good moves and for Bishop D6
I didn't see it all the way out to the
end but I saw Rook takes D6 Queen takes
and H5 and I analyzed that enough and I
just figured I mean this has to be
really good so so it felt very different
and I think I think I did a better job
but of course I was helped by the fact
that I got a good position out of the
open
our congratulations uh once again as we
have two results in as little girls uh
competition yeah Kelsey Liu lost Yen and
Zoe tank won against Rose atoll with a
really nice
um yeah no the Finish was great uh Zoe's
finished just at the end I mean it it
deserves a diagram and a visual and uh
right maybe viewers can think for three
seconds what do you do for white here
yeah a chess puzzle Rush a tactic yeah
white to move and win and Zoe found a
Zinger yeah rube takes F7
check and
text and resigns very nice and then you
said
also one and another result what
happened in the Balaji dakupati against
Brandon Brandon Jacobson lost he got
checkmated
what oh he blundered made into he played
knives Knight C6 guy oh my goodness oh
my gosh that's unfortunate for him
because he was the leader of the
tournament Rook takes one of the
co-leaders yeah I mean so we've left it
here and it was Bishop Rook takes E5 we
thought he was fine but then what
happened
thank you oh my God
for The Rook from one side all the way
to the other oh that Rook that was just
like chilling on A4 for the whole game
it was just waiting for its opportunity
to cross the board and that's what
happened and it was made on the spot
check King and he didn't want to see
roof G3 nice back into the tournament
two out of two really really
back-to-back victories but hold on are
we saying Arthur Arthur is going to not
winning anymore what no the winning not
winning anymore Arthur blew it and right
now it's just a draw and here's one
minute on the clock but they they made
the move 40 so yes actually oh my gosh
when we when we left it we just seen the
positions Praises for all the moves she
should have taken on F7 first that was
the easy win
F7 first yes how can you not take a bond
with check I mean it's sacrilege no
and now we're prepared yes
sure and Andrew honk great
black is just doing great here there's
just an extra piece for sure right and
next move is D3 and
that's all that in fact is just about
[Music]
um
yeah I mean it's also Andrew plays D3 I
think it's time to give it up oh Knight
takes E4 Knight takes C4 he's gonna take
them let's just take the pawn
then I'm gonna play G6 kick the Knight
away and Knight G3 Checkmate I think D3
Rook B Rook A1 is nice yeah I am
expecting uh easy win going on here but
I do want to turn to the seniors because
it was a
maximum we're just gonna see the mate
on board and here it is Rook A1
Checkmate handshake and Andrew Hong has
another important win
wow by the way I think the loogies is
completely losing as uh White's pawns
are like Space Invaders they're coming
up we're going to see another Shake of
hands in the steerman Gog game perhaps
we can move on to that one just to see
the handshake okay because I believe
they have repeated already three times
yeah that's the draw what a wow for
Arthur he'll be really sad that he let
one get away here because never mind I
guess he's still trying okay let's move
on from this one
let's go back to Malik katian against
Maxim Logan okay
yeah because I was just saying that it
looks like like
well
from White's point of view if I could go
uh King F5 and G's G5 G6 and promote the
H Pawn That's All She Wrote uh here okay
by the way I think we had a couple of
results that we missed zoitang won her
game we already
identified those two wins okay yes Zoe
tank had a really nice tactics we looked
at that can we see my pick yes
when we left it uh Vladimir had gone
Whole Hog on the king side H5 H4 uh oh
wow H5 fun
stopping Rook G6 and check this out the
Rook on G3 that is a solid Defender I
yeah it's a new white who's attacking
you know wow talk about oh no now
everything's it's like a flower the
petals are opening up this bishop on E1
that was doing nothing
suddenly massive attacker and guess what
H4 oh my gosh no this is all going
well it's over I mean
Shabbat he was just gifted a victory
here because uh everything's working The
Rook on G3 the pawn on H6 is useful this
is dropping
blunder alert something happened here
for a copian fans and it's over
less than two minutes he has to make two
more moves but it's the position yeah
it's gone it's gone so shebalaf will
knock off uh our our tournament uh
favorite uh but Christian we have a
guest in studio Zoe a difficult game
yesterday but an immediate recovery in
today's game first of all
congratulations it was at this moment
that it seemed like finally after the
move knight uh H5 excuse me you got the
move E4 on the board so G6 for black
isn't the best move I think it's
supposed to be some Bishop D7 or
something all the way here yeah okay
because Jesus kind of weakens the Kings
I didn't really see the point to it and
um so then I had some extra turns to
play the F3 E4 idea once I get E4 and I
think I'm better already you are yeah
yeah not only better maybe just winning
objectively winning at this point I
thought after she played C5 I was kind
of releasing my advantage because
doesn't she have some sort of F5 later
perhaps but it seems like the computer
always said that you're in control it
looked difficult during the game in fact
that this point it felt like maybe she's
getting some tricks in really here was
where I was like oh my gosh I'm up in
exchange I must be winning did you see
this idea of Bishop takes you too uh
I didn't consider taking the pawn I was
just like Rook d2's sort of with Tempo
threatening Rook F2 it's safer so you
felt uh the danger yeah position very
nice Rook to D2 and after that you
finished uh quite nicely in style
with Rook takes F7 my Rook F7 was nice I
didn't see it until the move happened
Zoe tell us about your Ambitions because
so far you're doing amazing in this
event sure a difficult game yesterday
but you're still in this tournament
you're here to win it because my
ambitions are still the same as the
first round I still don't want to
embarrass myself I want to play good
chess and I'm not too concerned with
results I mean I start off what fifth
seed it doesn't really matter right
three and a half out of five quite a
very good decent results so far guys any
questions well for me congratulations
and the the final position the final
combination was a real visual it was a
beautiful finish Zoe well done thank you
absolutely and a lot of results they're
coming in thick and uh heavy hot and
heavy as Alexander shavalov has won his
game at least I've been told uh that uh
is that true it looks like they're
talking king size yes on the white
squares oh ether if he did play E3 three
he probably played E3 he resigned at the
same time because he said no
oh even that Bishop takes D5 with a
check with a check with a check you
don't even think that you're going to
get a check or anything like that so for
for uh and Gregory kaidanov Joel
Benjamin that was a game I couldn't make
heads or tails of this one because it
just seemed to me that when we left it
Gregory had such a overwhelmingly good
position right here like just everything
Black's King is stuck in the center but
somehow Joel saved the game and made it
wrong right remarkable and which means
that we have
three decisive games in the seniors one
draw and we're expecting that uh well in
the matchup of our tournament leaders
Max is losing
uh
at the current position and Christian uh
over to you what do you mean we have
another guest in the studio ruyang first
of all congratulations we haven't spoken
to you in a long time finally you got
that crucial Victory tell us about this
game it felt like you signaled from the
beginning with your opening choice that
you're here to fight yeah I mean I I was
gonna like try to play some other stuff
I just kind of gave up prepping sorry I
like what I usually play and um in the
opening like I think A4 was really
unexpected very ambitious Yeah by her
yes I had never seen this before did it
surprise you a lot and
what did you base your reaction on
um so I kind of like use like my
previous knowledge of the position like
like what I usually a place like Queen
D2 at long castles like F4 and stuff
yeah but like I figure like this middle
would kind of weaken the queen side a
little like if she wanted to like long
Castle again it would be like much
weaker and I have like B5 breaks later
on yep and yeah and I just choose to
like let her play A5 and that's exactly
what happened it feels like combining
both long castle with A4 is a bit yeah
that's a it's a bit dangerous yeah right
and after that when you feel like you're
finally gaining full control of this
game by the way so I think I could yeah
she had nice cp5 I realized like right
after I played it and I was like oh crap
like you know how do you keep your poker
face so I just put so I have to play
Queen takes D2
it's gonna play like night King tasty
six or like at 96. I was like evaluating
this position this is wild yes
she gives you a check you have to run A5
is that it yeah I think A5 or Knight
takes yeah I wasn't sure if I had like
okay but this is some sort of crazy line
yeah yeah
then you can go to A5 and who knows
what's happening here yeah we're not
even trying to I think I was like during
the game like instead of um
instead of King takes D6 I was after
work takes D2
um
yes yeah I was considering Knight takes
B3 but I wasn't sure
okay Knight takes B3 yes oh Rook tasty
yeah rotation King D6
and I don't know I thought like wild
wild position yeah right computer is
getting rortex B7 but I honestly don't
think and she played Queen I was really
relieved when she played that yeah for
good reason you picked up the pawn and
nothing bad happened to you so that's a
good thing of course and after that it
felt like your conversion I think this
was quite smooth
you never let go of the advantage very
nice this must uh feel like a relief
after the last few rounds finally
getting especially after yesterday
finally getting a victory
congratulations
we'll see you after the break
our congratulations as well uh nice uh
finish at the end too I like that very
much Queen D1 check and queen takes E2
and and we thought the Knight deserved
an award yes right on that C5 that night
was just fantastic a medal for uh
Services beyond the Call of Duty that
was a great night night on C5 just
wanted to say that Rochelle Alice that
is a game that uh well we've been
expecting a draw for some time the
players have been shuffling back and
forth uh expecting a draw in that as as
soon as black plays the move King A6 we
always meet King A6 with King A4 we've
also got a B5 check when we need it too
so expecting a draw in that game and
Carissa uh is well we we've known that
this game has been in her favor for much
of the way her last move Queen E7
hitting the pawn on G5 prepping hitting
on C5 hitting on C5 prepping D5 six
maybe even Knight to D6 everything going
uh Carissa's way as she's saying to her
friend Rachelle just make a draw over
there let me let me close the gap a
little bit with Alice and back over to
you uh Christian with another guest
Balaji a huge victory for you back to
back victories right now you're fully
back in this tournament but this wasn't
straightforward and especially this move
Bishop to D7 early on in the game it
definitely felt like it surprised you it
surprised everybody tell us about this
yeah I mean I feel like this was such
like I mean this this line has been
played for hundreds of years and
suddenly did like make bishop D7 which
I've never seen before so I was
definitely surprised I felt it should be
a bit dubious but I thought maybe later
it wasn't so without reason because
trading office Bishops really helped him
later on as
um usually his light squared Bishop
would be worse but in this case I
definitely think I may be forced things
too much maybe I should split slower
because as soon as it's not gotten to B4
I felt that this was super annoying I
couldn't figure out how to get rid of it
and here by already I feel like he
basically he equalized without too much
trouble you thought that he could last
year yeah and it was not and I think you
you objectively you were definitely
right but yeah you still had some
tension maybe that favors you right in
the position yeah I mean I didn't
responding for 46 yeah I didn't see
anything too easy to play with so I was
just trying to like slowly make moves
trying to see because I knew he has to
go to D5 seemed like the critical line
all the time so I was waiting for him
just trying to get ready for D5 as much
as possible and trying to get this type
of structure and trying to figure out
okay how do I want to play after he
plays this and the way I dealt with it
maybe it's not the best
but it at least kept some play on the
board I liked it I really like this
transfer of the rookon G3 and this was
the critical moment when he played this
King to h8 battle would have been Knight
to E4 but the position already gets a
little bit dangerous yeah with so many
pieces swarming around the king king h8
and you came up with this idea yeah I
don't I don't think Bishop takes H6 I
don't think it was the cleanest what was
the critical line that you I mean I
thought she takes H6 has to be Knight D6
Queen C7 and what I forgot about is
Queen F4 Queen C1
aha take take and I forgot his check
still I thought I can take the Rook on
E8 and that it's just full Rook but no
let's check and so he gets away and this
is just winning for him yeah and in fact
I think the best move was King H3 yeah I
thought about King Of Tune rookie when I
wasn't sure what I was gonna play it
because I did see this I didn't see that
after 65 I saw he can cleanly grab this
pawn and all the stuff after Knight
takes Queen takes and queen D4 he has F6
which is very important oh 96 actually
okay yeah
perhaps you can take on A5 first yeah
yeah
that's probably more accurate yeah still
a complete mess yeah I mean this is very
playable so I wouldn't say like one side
is better I think it's unclear anything
can happen here but
I would probably choose white in time
trouble at least just because we can
yeah yeah no it definitely felt like
completely crazy position he spent a lot
of time took on E5 and after that
this moment came yeah I mean what when
he saw this move Knight C6 what what was
your rear because he still had time it's
not like he was in a huge hurry to make
his move I mean honestly I wasn't okay
of course I was a bit surprised you saw
it immediately you saw the show I saw
this beforehand because I thought Knight
C6 he might play this because if there's
no Rook H4 it's a very logical move
you're just you're not you don't want to
put your Rook on it which looks very
yeah
um but it's sometimes it's just like a
blind spot for getting you can go all
the way and especially after such a
sudden change in position whereas like
it's literally like terrible for him to
suddenly like it's really hard to defend
such a structure I think a sudden change
in probably all that just in his head
kind of just made him forget Rook H4
well he lost patience and he definitely
took advantage of that congratulations
for this important Victory thank you
guys back to you yeah congratulations
and welcome back to the tournament yeah
congratulations on a very important win
I mean you won with one of the leaders
my question is what are your for the
rest day now that you've kind of caught
up with the maybe the you know the major
players in the field I mean I wouldn't
say I have anything too special planned
it's more just resting and getting ready
for these final four rounds which will
be very crucial I think because this
tournament is definitely opening up so
anything can happen anymore
okay great so we should good rest in the
in the during the rest day and for the
rest of the tournament thank you let's
take a with so many results suddenly in
the books Let's Take a look at our
standings and results
so we have the standings here for the
juniors where all the games finished I
believe so standings after round five we
have a three-way tie for the first place
all with three and a half points exactly
two decisive games and maybe go was
Arthur is gonna be oh and results for
the girls so far we have two games that
finished tank one against Atwell and Liu
lost to Yang in a crucial matchup Wu
versus Lee we are expecting Alice to
make a draw with Rochelle and we are
expecting Carissa to win and in the
seniors what's happening there the
seniors we have a bunch of results here
still the leaders are playing catching
against loogie but all the other games
are done root lost to which kaidanov
Drew with Benjamin wolf won his first
win against novikov and a shadow of one
against akopian
the last game of the seniors were
designing they're going to decide is
going to be decided very very shortly as
the move G6 has just been played with
this massive killer threat of Knight F6
check and G7 you can give a check but at
a certain moment you're going to have to
take and let's just take a look at what
happens if we take right away shall we
takes King ticks and now it's about
playing check right and if you play
Bishop E8 check very sneaky sacrifice
exactly takes
takes check now you can't go after the
night because this guy's going to go
home and if you go after this way takes
looks like you're cleaning I'm gonna
play H7 make sure the king does not
Escape
H7 yeah make sure the king does not
escape a 96. so I'll let you to promote
a queen uh under promoted and they're
promoter and I'd have seven a very
beautiful chat mate indeed okay so
that's what's on White's agenda is there
anything that uh Max can do to avoid it
I don't think so I think that this is
just it's very very straightforward
again whether or not we start with
Bishop t7 checked and I wouldn't imagine
why you would want to put your Bishop on
pre we're gonna have to take take and uh
well could I play D3
shall I have a look let's take a look
take a look
here I see the problem you're going to
land a rook on H7 mate
[Music]
check
oops
that one plays itself as well right uh
the the mating patterns are too brutal I
don't have any timing as black here and
uh well that's just a huge huge win
uh for
um like I said as he would be our clear
tournament leader four and a half out of
five again let's go to the girls as our
tournament leader Alice Lee has been
repeating moves for some time I know
they're not allowed to offer to draw but
they can at least claim right to remove
repetition as
time a factor I don't think so
and well
just arcing time I guess
King A3 king of three
and after King B7 I feel like Rochelle
can claim a draw but maybe you're gonna
play a little bit more around just so
they know that this position is just a
draw
and they need time control so again
time's just not a factor to the game
Irish Mo against Shreya mangalam because
we were thinking black is winning then
it's unclear so what is our evaluation
now
my last move was Bishop
okay we've got we have finally our
majority is doing something and with the
move B5 we're ready ready A7 and queen
so Bishop to E8 and it just feels like
black has gone backwards I don't know uh
the problem is distill upon on G2 right
but why this I mean black is one Pawn up
right check coupons up actual black no
yes two pawns up
right and so I see there's a that
there's a problem right Bishop takes C6
and Rook D1 uh check on the back rank is
a problem I really don't want to expose
my king by taking the pawn so the other
Rook will go to G5 yes so let me just
take a pause and
drop my Rook back in order to defend the
first rank but this is a Bizarro
position for me I don't know uh what is
going on I wonder if I can do something
like
Queen H3 you know threatening Rook H5
forcing you to capture on G2 so I always
have Rook G5 uh skewer okay
I don't get that I can maybe chase you
away
then if I go I mean if I go some kind of
queen F3 or queen F5 at the moment
I don't know what I'm feeling but
I mean that one is a little scary but
now I capture on C6
ah now you have a rook chat yes yes
and that I have to take but that that's
a very forceful and a clean check to be
sure and if I start with no A6 then
there's Rook H1
yeah I was thinking that if I go A6 and
you go Rook H5 and I go Queen G3 haha
defending the pawn on H2
you pick up my Rook I know which one
oops luckily I have this yeah very very
important uh jump in Christian and tell
us what you think is going on in this uh
around uh five well I think we should be
looking at uh Carissa's game also right
I think that's
the one that matters in the junior girls
section quite a lot and Carissa has been
coming back in that one maybe maybe we
can look at it on your board yeah for
sure well yes sir kind of called this
game already right yeah well I thought
it was much much better but that's
that's the one we need to analyze
because she is much better but it's not
there yet right
like we have to figure out how to finish
black in this position well all the
threats are on white side of the board
and queen takes G5 Knight takes F5 and D
D5 D6 or three massive threats that
black is facing and what can black do
okay let's just
I'm gonna close my eyes and go G4
a closed mind oh no this is
I'm gonna keep my eyes open now
oh
that actually you were we were talking
about it and you were telling me how
blindfold chass and visualizing the
board uh blindfold it was a big part of
your training uh 93 yeah dude just too
many threats that Carissa has is
what move number are they on oh 45 oh
they made me time control
and uh Christian you have a guest in
studio Alex an incredible game back and
forth strategically very complicated
from the beginning to the end tell us a
bit about this game specifically let's
start with this moment when he decided
to play C5 change the structure and then
you spend some time here you're trying
to figure things out and decided finally
to go for A3 yeah I wanted to get to
Bishops one way or another but uh you
know against such a classical strong
player that's just a small advantage and
what were your worries about the
position after take take or two yet you
have the two Bishops you're playing
against the isolated pawn it doesn't
seem like he has a big attack against
your king yeah but I also know myself
I'm I'm not really good at those
technical positions for a unit slowly to
grind your opponent down
and that's exactly what happened I guess
he's slowly gradually grabbed the
initiative
and I really didn't like my position
because I almost was out it was getting
a bit uncomfortable here yes I'm around
here I was almost running out of moves
but then I finally realized it for as
long as I can keep my night on D4 uh
were you ready at this point to to make
a draw oh yeah okay yeah absolutely no I
was I was worried that move H6 uh to
Vladimir I didn't like after the game he
said that even though in a lot of lines
the back rank is an issue uh maybe a
rook A3 instead he suggested that with
the idea uh after 94 to uh into laser
was one of the night goes to D2 probably
the C Knight probably the other one yeah
so we keep F2
going to B2 right now or B2
rugby three right
oh whoa okay yeah I know
still it's crazy
yeah yeah maybe forget about it yeah
fundamentally White's position should be
fine because of Bishop on B7 but uh yeah
that's so nice
so much tactics I really felt
uncomfortable oh yeah I mean
but everything could change right and
everything did change in fact as soon as
two Bishops will get some squares and
diagonals yeah the position might become
real unpleasant for black and uh he
basically is distracted with it
yeah it felt like a bit too ambitious
right my problem was I Rook on the third
rank had no squares to go yeah and the
reason I took an H4 the finally I got
the square on H3
so that's why I wanted to you know to
get rid of this Pawn on G3 and uh and
also yeah he he absolutely blundered
this idea of takes takes on Rook G3 and
G3 and suddenly the bishop on E8 is
unprotected yet
Alex no he didn't play three I don't
know why this move appeared yeah maybe
you guys analyzed a little bit after
that we just talked yeah probably that's
uh uh what can I say it's the every half
a point in this tournament coming as a
gift and today I got like a great gift
from Vladimir the whole point uh totally
on dessert but it's good before the rest
day exactly welcome the gift before the
rest day congratulations Alex we'll see
you in a couple of days thank you our
congratulations as well as that was a
very nice finish there the Bishops just
took over the position one game
remaining in the senior section as Malik
said versus Max and the loogie Max just
played a move frankly it's so obvious
but at a certain moment right here in my
mind I had chalked up the wind for white
because I saw that white is ready to
play Rook to E7 Rook H7 and well it's
just Checkmate and the pawn is way too
slow Max played the bishop I felt like
an idiot well I mean he's still kicking
I mean if you can play Bishop check
defend the the H7 square right okay
right like
blindness Bishop A4 uh put me out of my
misery how do how should uh White uh
finish things off is it time
is there a a nice finish
I mean if there is one I am not seeing
it right now to be honest well you you
would love to just like G4 G5 maybe I
yeah if I go G4 I will be happy if you
push your opponent forward right because
that's gonna block the diagonal right
for you and then come then you're ready
yeah then you're ready to jump
so oh that's easy on not that easy right
so if you go Bishop check
and if you go King F7 I'm not going to
push I'm going to give I'm going to keep
giving you checks until you go uh to the
H5 Square I'm actually going to push and
then I don't know I'm going to push it
okay I understand for black I get you I
want to get it to kick the king out
though and play King to H5 and uh well
this is not so clear so first question
let's put the Rook on E7 right well how
do we do that in the game position in
the game let's start with rookie okay
check
and now
we can pretty much realize that
that Bishop is not going anywhere else
the pawn is not moving the d-pawn the
one that matters is not moving so what I
have to do is probably just get out of
Dodge King G5 or King H5 and then just
push the pawn right
so the idea what Christian is saying is
that as soon as we play D3 we allow mate
in one very much
like what happened here I mean you don't
have a lot of
Goods good positions if I go Rook f8
you're just gonna
Rook f a i like that move
kicking kicking him screaming all right
now I go back King G5
chain G5 again I can't don't don't reach
for the D3 Pawn don't touch it don't
touch it all right I'm gonna run with
the other Pawn B5 makes a lot of sense
all right let's kind of pick up the pawn
hmm
let's pick up that pontoon
all right now I can play D3 finally
maybe root before
so we've managed to munch the two pawns
and with the thread of Rook to D7 it's a
bit frustrating for black right because
right you really want that pawn to
finally cross the island go to D2
so what if I'm gonna be very passive and
I will just play Rook B8 I know it looks
super weird but I just don't want to
know G4 now it's time to push the pawn
[Music]
white is ready to mate but what you can
do right is give a check first and then
go back
and say that wait I don't have
to get G6 or Bishop no no G5 G5 yeah
yeah keep going oh I'm sorry uh
in the king H5
no Rook B8 here okay
yes then we are in the good line G4 B5
G5 and Bishop D1 check
then go back to situ
and then go back
holding on to the light's choirs hoping
hoping praying praying for for a draw
I'm praying for something I'm not sure
what I'm praying for but
for something right now yeah this is
looks terrible though but how do you
finish me because look if I get a couple
more moves in B4 B3 then okay I'm happy
oh I think I can pick one it will say
goodnight to G4 waste what okay let me
go
maybe even a D3 now that you allow me
do you have any uh uh the idea was that
I didn't think you could play D3 because
of G6 and I wanted to go check
and meet
yeah okay
so if you go D2 let me just show
Christian what he missed no I didn't
that's the configuration
so this is it's not the Arabian made
Christian but it's one of those mates so
I'm gonna go before no D3 I was just
testing you okay Bishop C2 I I didn't
know I want to play G6 but if I put my
knight on E5 I can play for G6 so now I
go B4 and now I now I go B3 right and
now I go
B2 show me the mate show me the mate
okay let's show him the mates where is
the maid
last night check
it's a good check I have to go there
check that's another good check I have
to go on A7
or do we want to play Knight and six
first no it's seven eight seven first
okay one move away oh I get my queen you
do you do you clean first that's not
enough not enough uh
yeah that might be it that actually
might be it but it it feels like there
should be a setup that we really like
I'm going to refresh the board because
we've made some moves uh for all of this
and Bishop A4 on the board I liked what
you were saying put the Rook on the
seventh rank keep that pawn on us so
that the the pawn can never cross D3 so
yeah credit where it's deal Christian
suggested
ah okay sorry rookie but I liked it uh
put the Rook on the set on this ring I
have another idea yes
I'm going to start with Rook f8
so what the bishop is on no no keep
going keep going
Bishop C2 King H5 Rook f8 so that I uh
force your king or at least I tried to
say that I'm forcing the king to G5 and
and yeah we do and now I go to B8 back
now I'm saying that maybe we'll do the
same thing but with an extra tempo for
me
do I get that extra tempo so he's put
his King on G5 anyway so he basically uh
White is saying I don't need
the G Pawn whatever I'm going to do I'm
going to do without the G Pawn sorry let
me just refresh my board I I get it
messed up as a
and we're expecting group B8 right
and we're saying where you want to
slowly slowly slowly uh push our button
up the board where does this bishop
belong on this long diagonal where is
this bishop going to be nowhere
like if I just tickle the bishop okay B1
tickle the Bishops some more
oh you're serious about attacking
now I can go to A2 I'm not worried yeah
I wanted to I wanted to show that Bishop
D3 I pick up this guy okay so oh sorry
Bishop to D3 Rook to D1 as what I wanted
to show Bishop to A2
okay Bishop to A2
Rook to C2
now if you go here I'm I'm trying to
hunt down this bishop and drive it back
but maybe I've done it wrong maybe your
Bishop is happy to go to the G8 square
covering H7 from this angle intriguing I
mean this is going to be interesting end
game I think we're gonna come back to it
but let's look at carisas because she is
about to promote to another queen and
that is the key matchup in the girls
junior Championship exactly by the way
Alice and Rochelle made a draw while we
were interviewing one of our guests
left it here let me just refresh
yeah
Gracie okay sorry yes takes takes
yes this is no Queen b893 this is where
we left it and uh Gracie defended her
Bishop yes not like unlike me who just
played before
uh closed eyes Carissa said okay I've
got a passer let's push
and we've caught up to well just
everything right
Bishop C2 Bishop C2 looks like one way
Bishop takes H5 and under block that
looks like a really really strong move
as well I mean you're setting up for
Queen F7 check and give me this bishop
uh yeah Carissa's got uh her choice
of uh winning moves I would say
even Queen E8 check I think Bishop C3 is
the easiest yeah I think so too okay
Bishop C2 looks really really good for
uh for Carissa and for Carissa a victory
here would bring a half a step closer to
Alice Lee our tournament leader who only
Drew today okay I saw a way to mess it
up please so here we go Bishop C2 yeah
Queen D2 okay
now we take on FR with the bishop let's
say okay
Queenie one okay now we forget that we
have Knight F1 and we go King HD
uh Marathon would win right yes okay but
we forgot about it we forget about it
and then we mess things up after Bishop
but I was trying to figure out is this
is this losing probably
keep it up and you might yeah but Knight
F1 I think it's winning even this
don't go here but your knight F1 was
sufficient that I'm sure this was a
great way to mess it up yeah yeah yeah
yeah by the way Bishop CQ is on the
board Karissa played Bishop C2 and queen
D2 is on the board so this is the
current position so don't capture an F5
no no capture on F5
right yes
yeah you you can take it no problem yeah
just don't go King H2
the last the last of the last trick in
the position is uh
is foiled Knight F1 and that would be
that's it that's game over
Carissa man I mean look she
said the very first half her place shaky
somehow uh despite her bad
position she's half a point behind it
she's she's right there in contention
for the first and remember these prizes
I mean it's just really really wonderful
scholarships and and invitations
although I must say that both Carissa
and Alice would would get an invitations
to the Women's Championship uh
regardless right whether they were the
rating is really high so they will
qualify exactly based on writing exactly
all right let's see
let's see if Carissa
she has so much more than 30 minutes yes
grabbing that Bishop of course
the fine and after Queenie one she will
Blitz outside
[Laughter]
don't give your opponent any hope all
right we see the check
here it is of course
and I think that's that's it
yeah and we see a handshake
well then Carissa
didn't like her position but boy she
keeps fighting back that leaves us with
Iris and shriya it's a crazy uh messed
up game but uh now it does look like
black is for Choice
um much safer
enjoying that one Pawn Advantage exactly
the extra pawn and the a pawn is not
scary uh
monster it was when we had a light
Square Bishop that was supporting the
promotion Square uh going back to the
Juniors the juniors are all complete
and leaves us with just uh two games
this one and the big one in the seniors
right The Clash of the leaders which I
have to say I mean
maliksat is really doing an amazing job
in this game
he didn't get much out of the opening
but in that end game he managed to
completely outplay
maxi
he did absolutely rookie seven check
King G5 B5 on the board not Rook B8 so
maximum is not worried about the pawn on
B7
uh well maybe he should be maybe he
should be
truly true that why not let's take it by
the way uh maybe the most accurate is
Rook C7 here
just asking the bishop where it would
like to go
because again that diagonal it's not so
many
uh move not so many squares and once you
play D3 we have a check in Checkmate in
one right Rook H7 game over exactly
so here we force either to D3 or B1
right and Malik just grabbed
okay no no subtle improved nuances uh at
all just give me the bond you you're not
you're not threatening D3 go ahead play
B4 uh if you'd like
not worried about that one either
so uh
I mean what a tournament so far from
like three and a half out of four and
now playing the other leader of the
tournament and having very good position
exactly
loved this interview where I think it
was with bacon where he was saying you
know like I played last year was feeling
really good expected to be on the podium
I took last now I came to this year's
tournament saying yeah
it's all gonna be good I'm just having
hair I'm going to enjoy myself and uh
it's all going well
and let's take a look at the uh girls
results thus far yeah a lot of results
only one game is remaining uh tank one
against Atwell who drew Italy Leo lost
to Yen and the Yip won against prasanna
and in the seniors the seniors we have
again all but one game done catchy and
still fighting with loogie but root lost
to grevich kaidanov Drew with Benjamin
wolf won with novikov his first win in
this championship and shabalov won
against acopian
with all the results known we can get
the final standings
so the Juniors after round five we have
three-way tie for the first place
avivanyu Mishra Andrew Hong and Arthur
go all share first place with three and
a half points and Brandon and due to his
loss he tumbles out of uh first place
and uh well
mishra's preparation that yeah
I don't even know what to call it
anymore that's just that's just crazy
stuff that was I like how Patrick was we
were asking if he would be coaching some
Juniors and he was like no after that
preparation they can go to me yeah
uh did uh
is uh Malik said playing this the best
way uh Christian because we were looking
at Rook C7 no Rook takes B7 is fine as
well as well yes why no problem so after
Rook takes it well actually B5 no
hate this you'll just refresh it I hate
this
Rook takes B7 Rook d8 on the board
correct okay and push them on maybe
what I'm pushed upon
not that one
not that one I was kind of surprised I
don't want to try like checkmate with
the night G4 what's the one that matters
okay B4 okay B4 what if I uh go King H5
now things are getting a bit dicey
though
yes B3 yeah G5
I guess I gotta give you a check you
really have to yeah King H4 okay because
G6 and Rook H7 cooking G6 King pardon me
King G6 yeah why not
because I give you a check again yeah
this is again it's not easy I have to go
to F7
right
but you have to calculate all of these
things you have to be very precise
wow and I have a feeling it's a one
tempo type of calculation so you miss
something
you count wrong and you're in trouble so
that's why Malik is taking all his time
right now he has 20 minutes more than 20
minutes so plenty of time to figure it
out you know analyze everything there is
sorry just refresh the board so G4 King
H5 G5
yeah one thing that you should probably
avoid is
taking on B5
all right so if I take you can play D3
suddenly correct yes and I'm no longer
threatening Rook H7 made so the pawn
gets across uh could I ask what uh why
he didn't play Rook C7 at what point
instead of Rook takes B7 why he didn't
play Rook to C7
what did the engine say both of them
lead to a very well I'm just asking
which is more precise both of them are
exactly the same assessment Rook C7
Bishop D3
kind of the same idea Bishop D3 and you
take on B7 and now I go Rook d8
we basically almost end up in the same
position well I put the I put the bishop
in front of the pond right but we are at
least defending the pawn on B5 I got an
idea for us guys why don't we take a
break
and uh the games will continue and we're
gonna see you on the other side of the
bridge see you soon
[Music]
hello Brandon welcome back to Saint
Louis it's nice to see you here thank
you yeah uh what are you busy series
these days am I busy with these days
yeah well besides chess besides chess
well I can't really tell my competitors
that but um I I've been doing a bit of
soul searching
um I haven't been home for
more than
you know a week at a time since what
February so I've been traveling quite a
bit and you know just exploring and
enjoying myself so it's been nice to
take a bit of the pressure off my
normally pretty fast-paced life yeah
sort of relax a bit we have a lot of
tournaments usually you play a lot of
tournaments and I can see whenever I
open like any American Events we are
there yeah and then Han how you How do
you see your future as like do you see
it as a chess player professional chess
player or do you want to do something
else which is connected to your degree
yeah it's kind of hard to say I mean for
now I'm sort of trying to go along with
both and see and see how things go but
for now I'm enjoying chess and seeing
where it goes so why not continue with
that awesome and it's your last year in
this tournament what are your
expectations
yeah you know it's kind of funny like
when I was younger I thought okay well I
have maybe what three or four more
chances to play this one I'm sure I'll
win one eventually but now I'm in my
last year and you know all these young
kids are passing me so it's tough being
the oldest but I don't really think I
have any expectations anymore I think
I'm just trying to have fun with it and
enjoy my last year here perfect are you
looking forward to play young kids
all these young kids you know I don't
think anybody would say yes to that
question maybe you would
no I think whenever somebody comes to
the board and they see their opponent is
you know less than half their height
maybe they start having panic attacks
so I'm pretty sure that's okay Universal
answer yeah okay and
um do you expect to win the tournament
in general I know you said you don't
have any expectations but let's say as a
goal is that your goal or just to gain
some rating points well I mean okay I
think I'll be lying if I said my goal
wasn't to win the tournament but yeah I
think it's kind of tough to think but
especially because everybody is so close
and level I think it's mostly we'll come
down to who's in the best form
um
so it's kind of hard to say and I think
like if I had to guess the winner of the
tournament will only be at like plus
three or something so it won't be a
crazy margin so I think
it's it's really anybody's game
perfect and good luck thank you and good
luck with the tournament thank you
[Music]
St Louis chess club is the Premier chess
facility in the United States we bring
the educational benefits of Chess to
thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as high
profile tournaments that attract the
world's best players become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
hello I'm women's current Master William
Tucker jonova I will be doing social
media for the US Juniors and seniors
chess championships follow us in our
social media and get more exciting
behind the scenes action
foreign
chess club is the Premier chess facility
in the United States and is among the
best in the world thanks to co-founders
Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield and Rex
sinkfield the St Louis chess club is a
non-profit organization committed to
promoting the game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
posting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chest lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions in our Galleries and sign up
for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
q-boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
hello I'm women's Grandmaster begin
Tucker jonoa I'm doing social media for
the US Juniors and seniors championships
here in San Luis follow us for more
exciting behind-the-scenes content
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program in the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grand Master
varusha nicobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between at-risk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since 2019. the St
Louis chess club has also created a
chess merit badge for the scouts BSA
quickly becoming one of the most popular
badges with more than 2 250 000 Scouts
earning the badge since 2011. students
of chess can also pick up a copy of read
and write Jess thanks to Club co-founder
Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield anyone can
learn how to understand chess notation
in no time we view chess as a valuable
educational tool learn more about our
Scholastic programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
foreign
and welcome back to our live coverage of
the national championships here are our
standings for the juniors after five
rounds yeah after round five we have
three-way tie for the first place
Andrew Hong and after girl all having
three and a half points out of five as
Brandon Jacobs son suffers a setback
there walking or allowing a mate and in
the seniors results thus far with one
game remaining right we have the big
matchups still going on but we have root
against gurevich grevich one kaidanov
Drew with Benjamin wolf won again
novikov and shabalov won against again
we're being treated to so many decisive
games three out of four and we suspect
four out of five and in the girls
results this far so the girls we have
one game remaining so tank won against
Leo lost to get and give one against
prasanna and we have Christian with a
guest
Carissa another victory for you but this
one I mean you came back from a very
difficult position I have to say out of
the opening and we discussed a bit after
you said that this move Knight to D2 was
not in your preparation or maybe you
missed something you forgot something
what was it um yeah so she's only ever
played she takes D4 actually
um she's had like a quite a few games in
at this point in this place so yeah C
takes G4 and so most of my prep like
most of me memorizing my prep was like
in this line and some deviations from it
and so I wasn't expecting Queen C7
um but you know I had this cover too and
I had D5 yeah normal move yes and I
believe here at the Knight V6 I was
supposed to play Bishop E3
um where waitress has like a pretty
comfortable position perhaps and then 92
is coming and everything works out so
what's the difference Carissa why why is
Bishop 3 so much better yes I think
after 92 C4 my Bishops kind of forced
onto B2
and it just kind of sucks there uh
should not be on B2 it's like Locked In
by its own Pawn
um in Blacks the one with more control
on the queen side
um
and so kind of at this point I was like
hmm screwed something up you weren't
really happy with your position yeah and
allowing this uh Knight H5 thing wasn't
great either okay but I was hoping for
some sort of play with like the week
C4 Pawn
um
and we did some shuffling pieces around
so many tricked her
um
and you know this position is kind of
like the same it's 10 moves ago right
not that much has happened a lot of
shuffling but one thing that was
happening is Gracie was getting lower
and lower on time and you were still
keeping up pace definitely maintaining
your time Advantage was that part of the
strategy
um try to get her down to her last few
minutes yeah I wasn't really sure how
she was as like a player now she thinks
a lot or she's kind of more chill with
it
um but once we got to around this point
she had like you know 20 minutes left
and I was feeling pretty good about the
situation I felt that maybe it could be
time to start looking at some breaks
create something in the position and
that's
well she actually helped you with this
move Rook to ba to create those breaks
in the position because finally the C4
Pawn
is not only hanging but is being lost
yeah um what do you think she missed I
think she just missed that it was
hanging all together
um and she was just trying to play
quickly to make it to 40 moves and that
just ended up being a blunder yeah and
you found this nice move Knight to B2 if
you go Knight to D2 she still has some
compensation after Bishop to H6 but he
played it quite quickly and I have to
say after this it was all you in this
game nice break
Chris a good victory for you very
important Victory especially before uh
the break Alice Drew her game now you
only have a point behind her tell us a
bit about this Dynamic right now in
tournament how do you see it
um I mean I'm pretty disappointed with
my results so far I had like a really
bad game yesterday
um this one also wasn't ideal but I'm
hoping with the rest day I kind of can
collect myself
and also as for the tournament standings
I think it's still anyone's game
um you know as long as I'm not trailing
by too far and I can sort of keep Pace
until we play you know everything's
still in my hands and so I feel pretty
good about that what are you going to do
during the rest day to ease your mind
maybe get some walks in what's the plan
um I don't know I'm probably just going
to
hang out with some friends
in the tournament
um spend some time with my dad just
relax a bit really we have to get back
into the grind
congratulations for your Victory Carissa
guys any questions no just our congrat
congratulations improve your play and uh
well enjoy enjoy the experience of the
of the girls Championship Carissa thank
you absolutely
has we only have two games remaining
this game of uh uh Iris uh
we thought it was about to finish like
in the first two hours it really is one
of the strangest games I mean I when we
we go back to a certain moment and it's
kind of a hilarious moment right here
when you see this move F3 you think to
yourself that's it why he's getting
destroyed Yeah clean ready to fly into
the king size exactly Queen G4 Queen no
I'm calling this one and then the
strangest thing happened that after
Bishop A4 forcing us to uh realize our
threat somehow from this position we've
got the current position and you think
to yourself there's no way that white
would ever survive and it's it's ongoing
it's amazing we have seen some tenacity
but this maybe Takes the Cake in terms
of hanging in there I mean black is
still enjoying an extra Pawn Advantage
everything
I had before why can we be happy to you
know be getting a break and white has
this spawn on A5 that can possibly push
like why does happy day survived to
begin with just you know to be here is
it it's amazing and uh wow
defense wins championships right and
finally the seniors
um
it's great when the two leaders are
facing off uh against one another it's
not the last round of the US champion uh
the the the Championships but the last
day before the free day and it's well
it's it's a nervy right because it uh
this Dynamic of the the past ponds
uh
and here we've I think we've caught up
with the players finally and uh Max is
just hoping against hope that he'll be
able to settle his Bishop on the G6
square and follow it up with a D3 if you
can get that that's the dream come true
and that's the problem right can he do
it well the problem is that you have a
clear plan and I have a clear way to
stop you I can go King H5 I'll go check
and now King G6 ah this is this is the
the the we had looked at this before
right tracking
right so that we can play G5 and G6 and
that's the problem yeah it's just too
easy because I know what you want to do
I know how to stop you and stopping you
is actually the right way to continue
this game exactly it's the best way to
continue this game so uh from this
current position we understand that
Black's dream is to blockade the pawns
drop back with the bishop on G6 so that
he could then play D3 and and
we can stop you okay can we look at some
fantasy lines sure all right let's look
at some fantasy lines
what if I go Rook B7
no
no D3 for me that would be check made in
one so I have to go back now I go to G7
Rook it's a G7 and I run D3 all right
yes now I take I run you run uh check
first
no check
so now I cannot go D1 because that's
fancy
all right
yeah sure one more check on D3
a spike check that's about it no not
much of a fantasy he did play Rook to G
to B7 by the way that is on the board oh
are they actually going into that yeah
the maxim Loki has only three minutes on
clock
so he has to make his decisions fast
well Bishop G6 Rook G7 if I have to move
the bishop then G6 so uh I was so close
one move away come on just one move away
one more move coach uh strange no
stalemates right
like if you go King here Porsche
I mean you want
well you still have the Deep on that's
the problem yeah well you wanna
nah okay I have an idea so what if we go
Bishop G6 let me just happen on the
board let me just uh refresh my board
apologies I'm right back yep
F5 okay G6 threatening mate in one
and I thought I'm gonna take it now and
push but okay there is a stalemate but
the problem the problem is is you're not
going to be you can sacrifice your Rook
but you can't sacrifice both the rook
and the pawn to get a stalemate okay so
I give a check
E5 or H3 you just go away
threatening mate threatening me
too many threats yeah too many threats
now if you wouldn't have the Deep one
okay exactly exactly that's the whole
point you can't get rid of the you can
get rid of one of the pieces but not
both it's kind of very
study like because Rook H4 is actually
just a draw in that position yes if you
don't have the Deep one exactly King G3
Rook G4 you know it doesn't matter Rook
yeah it's completely Melrose right yeah
it doesn't matter what you take it with
you can take it King Knight Rook it's
still a stalemate you're saying that Max
is uh the amount of time but I'm just
curious as the engine's assessment is it
like plus nine is it forced mate plus
infinity probably plus infinity
times yeah
nothing to be done from Alexa what a I
mean third grade first half of the term
and for Malay can't get better four and
a half hours so wild card D3 I mean I
think it's uh perhaps a good time to see
those predictions I don't know I mean
I'm just you're thinking about just
throwing it out there I'm just thinking
out loud you know
uh-huh well uh my guy shabalov my horse
came through uh for for me today so let
it roll Let Let It Roll uh
I kind of feel pretty good about my
choice but okay it's the all-important
seniors
all right Christian be happy
thank you thank you wow you and they can
both look it's so far so good you know
wow it's been a lot of difficult event
so far but right which I've had one you
had that well he he's had three wins and
two losses because he had one setback
that was really really painful right
might have been in there with four out
of five because he's a
like Rook G7 threatening Rook 87
Checkmate by the way that did H7 win as
well
it did right so we had this position oh
nice point
now that it matters I mean it actually
really doesn't last check for maxim
I think in age to end we see the
resignation yes
that's no way of stopping checkmates
that's it
well done uh Bravo
Bravo I'm Alex wow
wow uh just to point that uh that
Christian was making here was Rook takes
push
um I think everybody plays Rook to G7
but there is a point there that H7 has
uh also pretty pretty uh
comfy uh when that leaves us with one
game remaining
in the girl section Iris
and what
I'm predicting that this game is going
to go for another four hours it's gonna
be a fight because the tenacity that
white has shown to even get to this
position wow remarkable and let's see
what has happened when we left it the
other problem that white is having is
the vulnerability of her King she's
missing a little bit of the pawn Shield
that usually she would need
but we see the players are also getting
low on time right and that's the moment
when blunders happen so Iris she's the
youngest participant together with Alice
Lee in the juniors girls she's barely 13
years old and now she's been playing for
a really long time exactly well the
exhaustion's gonna be a factor here
Queen takes A5 can't can't do it because
of the Pawn on G7 but I really like uh
what white has done she's doing her best
I want to say
tying the opponent down to G7 she's
setting up all of these tricks that
whenever you play Rook D1 sorry I'm
going to play A6 whenever you play Move
Like Rook D1 you know to to trade off
and go into a much better position I've
got whoops you know the old uh
sneak attack
and so you it's not it's not easy for a
black to just you know trade off the
Rooks or something like that but you for
sure you're you but then I think on B5
right yep you're enjoying the uh you're
enjoying being an upon ahead and now I
just sit sit and wait exactly there's
room G3 Maybe
or Rook G4 just to attack you on e4 you
know it's funny it's almost like I'm not
even sure you want to take that pawn on
G4 because
what did we just do we went A6 Queen
here Rook
or you wanted to try Rook G4 right I
wasn't sure no you like if if you could
take that pawn would you want to open up
the diagonal foot to your king right so
if I if I if I pass right
and I take
would you want to do that
normally I can put Queen on G2 right I
just tripping on the G5 okay let's say I
go here
so anyway you're being sneaky
here well with all of the games that the
seniors completed let's take a look at
the standings right so after round five
we have Soul Leader Malik katian with
four and a half points out of
water first half foreign
with three points each and once again a
big day tomorrow is the rest day but we
will be celebrating the 15th anniversary
of the St Louis chess club at Scholastic
center from three to eight there's going
to be a lot of festivities use you had
me at ice cream I didn't hear the rest
ice cream face painting duck chess
yesterday we're gonna fight that
kiddie pools with ducks there you know I
haven't had a good face paint in a long
time tomorrow is your day lucky day I'm
all for it so and ducky chess as well uh
in waiting here they are they are
printed with chess club Saint Louis
chess club logo and people will be able
to take their own dog home so they can
play duck chess right so I look forward
to
wow they are they're just so beautiful
with different colors
it's really amazing and we are always
inviting you to join the conversation to
have comments questions and I have a
question for you Yasser uh stump the
panel let's go so you are the two times
uh junior U.S junior Champion four-time
U.S Senior U.S uh U.S Champion right
what about the U.S Senior Championship
Trifecta no I'm gonna leave that all to
Joe Benjamin Joe Benjamin is a
remarkable uh U.S champion because uh
literally from the elementary to the
Middle School to the high school uh he
won all of the national uh championships
that you could then he won the US Junior
Championships then he won the U.S
Championship as well so he's literally
won all the titles and there's no way I
could catch him I can't go back in time
and win the elementary or the the well
come on Yasser we want to see you
compete right so when did we See You In
Action well you see this is the point
when you when you look at the players
and you can see that it it's it's not
that they don't understand chess Patrick
Wolfe understands chess perfectly well
it's the rust Factor right I mean you
come to the game and your clock is
ticking and even though you know what
the Right Moves are you you you're not
used to it you're not used to it anymore
so it's like you really have to get
yourself in shape and I feel like
there's a lot of rust to scrape off and
it's it's not easy getting into shape
these days you know you know it yourself
Christian you just let yourself go for
two months two months that's all yeah
and then you're really out of shape I I
never thought that that I would be
taking these type of breaks but I have
to say during the pandemic I took like
two or three years close to three years
of uh break so that was very difficult
to dust it off but I managed to do so I
actually played here at the St Louis
jazz club and this is pretty much the
place where I enjoy playing the most
because you get the one game a day you
get the great conditions great
competition uh it's just it just feels
good to play here
um so whenever I play I try to play here
but I recently played an open tournament
and I have to tell you I mean these kids
are wild they know absolutely everything
Patrick was mentioning that as well
they know everything and you can see
that 30 moves of theory I played against
the 2300 this was in Spain just a few
weeks ago
2300 that one in that tournament 70
rating points and in the next one
another 70 rating points so you play
this like sandbagging young kids just up
and coming young kids that haven't
played in uh forever but they have
studied chess for so long eight hours
ten hours a day at home and I'm not
studying that much for myself I studied
for my students right for the most part
and that entitles that entails a
complete a completely different set of
skills right well yeah so I respect your
would love to see you play to actually
fighting on the board and go and try to
be that you're a sinner Champion I uh I
have another story to share it was one
of the last tournaments I played in it
was uh there was a jubilee in Holland we
have this uh tournament listener it's on
the coast it's very very nice open event
and they were having a jubilee let's say
the 20th or 25th they said yeah so yeah
so you have to play you have to play oh
so I get dragged into the tournament
first of all like this two rounds in one
of the days
and through my first eight rounds the
average of my opponents ages are like
21. everybody's youthful and I'm just
feeling like oh this is terrible all of
these young kids and like they know all
the theory and somehow I'm actually
doing pretty well and I go into the last
game and finally they gave me my ninth
round opponent Afghan
[Laughter]
himself the great the the great
practitioner of his opening yeah it was
fun it was a fun tournament
and after the rest day it's going to be
a Sprint to the Finish yes we will have
round six on Friday against again every
day we have a round starting at 1 pm
Central Time right so one round a day
and if necessary there will be playoffs
on Tuesday July 25th and uh looks like
well I don't know playoffs because we
are seeing some clear leaders but I tell
you that rivalry between Alice Lee and
Carissa if they went to a playoff
I'd be okay yeah that's okay
and of course lots of Chess still to be
played this year wow amazing upcoming
events here in St Louis so we have the
chest 9lx September 7 to 11 the U.S and
U.S women's Chess Championship in
October right St Louis rapid and Blitz
right in sink World Cup the big event of
the Year also November 19th through
December 1st just to clarify for those
not even know the chest 9lx is the Bobby
Fischer chest chest 960 we took the
Roman numerals uh for uh Bobby Fischer
Fisher random if you will and the best
players in the world are going to be
here for that I remember the first time
I was reading it reading it it was I
thought it's chess 9xl so I thought some
giant chess
you bet that's exactly what it is that
uh yeah Fisher random wonderful again
one game remember remaining Iris game
you can stamp us with any questions how
about you you asked me uh what are you
going to play and now it's right back on
you uh young lady what's uh what's on
your professional schedule so far
I commentary focusing on chess I'm just
finishing my Academic Year
congratulations doctor thank you and I
know what's ahead I will have to think
yeah you will have to think about it
okay well we're we would love to see you
also playing professionally
and when's your next tournament there I
have no idea come on come on I truly
have no I'm gonna commit you to the
chess 9lx what do you think about it no
I'm doing commentary first oh so I'll
see you in the commentary Booth yeah sir
safe you're safe
I'm retired I always tell my students
I'm already retired I'm just playing one
tournament per year and that one just
kind of keep in shape and make sure that
I can put the use the things that I
teach my students as well but as you
were mentioning it's all about that
Cadence and Patrick was also saying
those type of things you have to find
that Cadence you have to find that
Rhythm and I have to say whenever I take
this type of long breaks and I come back
the first few rounds are so difficult
after that slowly slowly you get back
into a form but the first few rounds are
absolutely brutal and it's not something
that I necessarily enjoy not the feeling
that I necessarily enjoy well it's nice
when you have the feeling that you
belong but yeah you're in the good shape
that you you've come prepared you've got
some ideas yes you've got this
confidence that it's going to work
itself out but the moment you have a
really unfortunate setback like like
just think about the game of Mishra
today and the amount of preparation that
those two players have put in uh to this
tournament and if you mess up just
they're walking a narrow path right you
make one mess up or you don't remember
your preparation exactly you're done
right you're gone crazy
hurts let's take a look what is
happening in the last round so we do
have exactly Iris small against Shreya
manga I'm the youngest with the oldest
in the tournament
is that matchup yes of the oldest that's
interesting okay uh uh there's been a
trade on G5 she snipped off the pawn and
went Queen G2 we cannot and I want to
end fight emphasize do not take this
Bond and allow check that would not not
not be what we want uh so I'm assuming
like you actually can it's a prepared
you get some Perpetual yeah so if you
want to have fun if you want to risk I
mean Shreya was fighting the whole game
having advantage
okay to be honest I think that's kind of
an invitation
for a draw
K7
well I think her idea is to check right
sorry check and do it this way okay
still it's yeah
there's an easy draw right easy draw
right
as uh but this has been a
really bizarre game if you had asked me
what was the shortest game of this round
and you pointed this game to me I'd say
yep they would not have expected this to
be the longest game to go around
we are expecting check on D2 check on
the door Rook
yeah Rook A7 makes some sense but check
just yeah and go probably a pawn yeah
this King has to be brave now because
that's the difference
compared to Middle game and end gaming
end game you do want to activate your
king bring it to the center
oh you go after the a pawn I go after
the e-pawn and right
and that's it we make a draw
King F4 absolutely
take this guy
suddenly material is equal two pawns and
two pawns and one Rook each
yes
[Laughter]
it's funny how the Dynamics of the value
of the pieces change right
that the openings of the king of wheat
but in the end games the kings are
strong but we have a special guest in
studio with you Christian Malik another
day another victory for you this is a
dream first half at the Nationals here
tell us about your feelings right now oh
yeah I mean I'm just uh I'm so pleased
thank you thank you Christian it was a
difficult game um I had a difficulties
to prepare because I wasn't sure what to
play like E4 or D4
um
um and then I study a lot of Sicilians
then somehow I didn't like the positions
which could appear like from
Scandinavian I thought oh my gosh too
much stuff so let me play something
simple something like for those just for
the game you know and then you guys
started thinking as early as move three
right because I think we both uh well
that's I mean personally I have an
expert at all he's more water all right
and I never thought he's going to be
playing that way yeah C5
um for some reason never crossed my mind
it should be because he's a zillion
player and then when he invited me to
play around and I said okay if I play
London that's what he does every day you
know so there is no way I can play
London and I play just uh semi-slap
reversed you know let's see a tree and I
said okay so no Advantage but let's
let's play on this was the first
critical yeah I was surprised appreciate
I thought after E5 it's supposed to be
like
to like you know to to attack I'm like
yeah
and it seems like everything comes with
them exactly so yeah exactly and then
when he played that G4 that B3 Bishop B6
I couldn't believe I spent so much time
here but I couldn't find anything
decisive right perhaps it it wasn't
decided there was nothing besides it
okay okay yeah that's why no I think
this is 0.9 I see I see yes then I found
this idea with um
195 code H4 uh con F6 Bishop F4 so my my
initial plan was to meet uh Bishop C7
with caption 25 and playing F4
yes yes this looks good right yeah I
thought that's what I'm going to do and
then I said okay but what I missed uh I
told uh Max as well I thought he well he
plays Bishop equal H6 I saw the move I
thought I'm playing connect six GH 94.
then I realized he does have really
nasty move check exactly yes yeah and
then I'll take take E5 and then I'm kind
of got scared oh yeah for a good reason
I mean King H7 right right I said no no
no no I'm not gonna play that I mean
particularly against the max because I
mean he loves this type of cycle all
right he's amazing Blitz player right
and there were all Blitz players are
very strong tactically so I didn't want
to deal with that yeah because my
initial like plan for the game was to
play dry chest today just uh solid
positional chess make sure you're not
risking to exactly right yeah so HG
Bishop F6 I was in the white I was
hoping for Bishop B8 obviously but then
he didn't play it right so here okay you
won yeah uh yeah actually I thought you
get seven is an accuracy I'm not sure
yes I thought Bishop design was better
that's right yeah yeah it should be much
faster right because exactly yeah I was
so concerned about Bishop D7
I was honestly concerned did you miss it
during the game or I missed and when I
was going for this position I missed it
yeah but then there's some Bishop D7 I
think I was going to do
um 94 actually here 94 here yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so I was hoping
for that I mean but Bishop December was
definitely the best move I was gonna I
was uh scared now you're starting to
have something well yeah what's kind of
okay now I'm fine now I'm I'm uh I'm not
only fine yeah yeah yeah I'm not the
worst so if I take take FG uh G5 I feel
that's only move right yes otherwise I'm
I can't play slope three actually this
is the way how I teach my students you
know in complex end game always like uh
play for threats but don't worry about
the engine too much I mean yeah
is the most natural way of playing right
yeah yeah G5 here check yeah King G7
yeah here here here here
yeah this is the this is the critical
moment of the game in my opinion now
okay uh before H4 I could play uh Rook
F1 right
but this is a boring draw we can we were
actually looking at specifically this
line yeah it's boring draw just like
take yeah yeah whatever I take yeah take
take yeah I said this is like just draw
I I don't want to deal with that luckily
it seems like it's yeah no but there's
something else I saw it it was kind of a
line with like equality uh yeah so I
figured no I'm gonna play for H4 so Rook
C3 H5
Maybe I'm Wrong
I this is at least what I was focusing
on and my life was H6 King G7 not F7 I
mean Rook F7 King J yeah King G8 and
network F7 okay yeah
uh rookie seven check and rookie E7
check and okay
now you're probably yeah but it's
supposed to be drawn to draw yeah yeah
but I thought he he must play that but
apparently his computer will show
something yes I saw it right the bishop
B5 move Bishop B5 okay but this is yeah
but computers but I was very happy when
he played because he has lower time than
me and uh here he was a lot of time and
he played Bishop it I was super happy
because this is what I wanted to take
take a gift to Yes actually I'm not sure
if you see this when I played uh King
gift 2 it was always trick uh with net
F7
instead of no King F2 yes the idea was
let's say if he does anything else I
played the Knight F7 oh sure yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah so he had to protect the back ring
uh-huh but I think the check is bad
I think the position is already
extremely difficult for him right so
what did I miss I mean it said my 1815
and that's what that's what Andrew told
me my kids
yeah he said coach you missed this mate
I'm like what now you're threatening
checks
I'm told for this and you're supposed to
be the main Bird Okay
King F4 still wins
yeah
I don't think you missed anything the
advantage was still within yeah yeah
King G5 was good move right and after
that I think yeah yeah yeah nothing
actually happened yeah yeah it is no I
mean and again I knew they said it was
winning as soon as I had this setup I
knew this is like a lost
I had to make B like a little bit you
know uh careful obviously not to like
blunder
but obviously not like your your shape
is amazing right now how do you maintain
that for the second part of the event
well I made the changes before coming
here I mean last time I think when I
came here I prepared a lot I kind of
chest wise and my my brain uh wasn't uh
I guess you know good enough to actually
capitalize what I had to analyze before
coming here this time I took absolutely
off for six seven days I went to the
Mexico just to chill and vacation
vacation my wife told me just try to use
this laptop and what it divorce you so
and it worked out you know that always
works right I mean I spent time with
kids uh kind of uh feeling a lot of
energy and yeah I mean um yeah and
obviously honestly luck because if I
will lose to novikov you never know what
what will happen you know I get very
lucky against no because so I guess you
know somehow it starts on my side for
for a good tournament you always need
some luck so exactly yeah yeah that's
always the way it goes but I understand
pushing every day I mean every game even
it gets no bigger I could probably play
for draw with A6 but I thought I mean
just you know I wanted to fight I wanted
to play yeah you're definitely bringing
fight to the tables congratulations on a
great Victory we'll see you in a couple
of days thank you I appreciate it okay
our congratulations as well enjoy the
free day as we will as well we've got a
a celebration of the club coming up at
15th anniversary as we have one game
remaining and the players are just
trading off as as far as I can tell
we've got rook and pond versus rook and
pawn that's always going
but some they're not
that they're not playing for repetition
I have a feeling we can expect
repetition I thought Malik is going to
take us over the line exactly
all right so King F7 rugby seven
they start looking the score sheets
is thinking like maybe I can claim now
but why don't you make it like five more
times so that you're sure about it right
it's not like white is going to do
something different right exactly it's
it's a very
very easy to draw check nobody's going
to try for anything more at this point
and by the way we were having this
discussion at the start of the broadcast
well I in fact uh rehearsal with Chris
bird because Chris was telling us that
at the Grand chest tour in Zagreb
he was having a conversation with nepo
and nepo was saying that you know he
didn't want to make a draw claim
because he felt that he only had so many
chances of claiming to draw and he
didn't want to use one of his chances
and in case it's inaccurate right and
Chris was saying no you can always claim
a draw that you don't have you could
draw once twice Thrice I mean you will
you you the draws may be disallowed and
your opponent may get the awarded bonus
time but you can keep doing that right
there's no restriction he was I think he
wanted to claim 15 moves no Pawn
he had asked what move number is this we
we can't give you that information it
was told Aha and I guess they haven't
made the repetition no there was a draw
claim yes that we would
oh and we see someone is getting time
right
it wasn't it wasn't enough moves yeah it
looks like somebody is getting uh
somebody he's actually getting texts
repetition this is the lack of
experience yeah
exactly but the clock is still it's time
flickering
wow
okay just play like 10 moves Rook B6
Rook B7 for 10 times right now she's
giving Israel
so for sure I was coming I was
inaccurate so Iris
I'm gonna give you a minute back
hilarious both girls are just confused
like come on we repeat it so many times
it wasn't as many times yet right and I
think that's it wonderful drug beautiful
as we have round five in the books yes
nice uh again the number of decisive
games continue to Astound I think we're
around 60 for this right in seniors we
have only one game that finished in a
draw 80 crawl rate
and here are the results for the day so
in the girls section standings after
round five we have a soul leader Alice
Lee one of the tournament favorites with
four out of five and then there is a
two-way tie for the second place
karissaif and Zoe tank with three and
half a point each well for Carissa that
rivalry we expected Zoe welcome to the
uh Podium very very nice what show just
behind them exactly and uh the Juniors
were the standings right in the Juniors
we have a three-way tie after round five
five
Andrew hunt and Arthur Goa all with
three and a half points Brandon is
smarting after allowing a Checkmate
whoops an oversight because he would
like to be in the mix as well and in the
seniors in the seniors we have a soul
leader incredible place so far by Medics
at catian four and a half points out of
five and then there's Maxim logi 3 and
half points and a two-way tie for the
Third Place Gregory kaidanov and Alex
shabalov
and Christians sum things up for us this
was another great event program no
absolutely and as we are entering the
second part of the event it's obvious
that nobody is running away with any of
the events and we're going to have
fights all the way until the end and I
have to say these pillars are ready they
they're coming to the games they're
coming to the competition ready to fight
and as commentators as fans ourselves as
well this is specifically what we like
to see and we've been seeing that for
the past week and we will be seeing that
in the next four rounds but tomorrow
it's a rest day we're going to celebrate
uh I think it's World International
Church day as well as the Saint Louis
chess club's 15th anniversary so I
cannot wait for that I will see you guys
there and after that I will see
everybody that's watching right now in a
couple of days with round six bring your
duck bring your dog
you're in trouble
yeah and looking forward whoever is in
Saint Louis visit us tomorrow for that
wonderful celebration for that face
paint that Yasser is getting or Doug
chess
make sure to make it to the club if you
can see try it
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited